the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
the kings of the board are reigning on
high at the super bet chess classic in
bucharest romania
players battled it out for a chance to
stake their claim to the top spot of the
leaderboard levon aronian showed up in
style rebounding to defeat fellow
countrymen linear dominguez in a
convincing win but it was american
wesley soh who took sole lead of the
event earning his second win against
co-leader ian napomiacci the sharks are
on the hunt and there is blood in the
water day five of thrilling chess coming
up next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day five of
the superbad chess classic the first
stop of the 2022 grand chess tour held
here in beautiful bucharest romania we
start the day in chishmi ju park in
english-style vast garden filled with
beautiful landmarks such as the clock
behind me well the players are ready to
get in action so let's go to the studio
and start today's round with yasser
peter and alejandra
fabulous footage of the romanian capital
as we welcome you to our continued
coverage of the superbad chess classic
in bucharest the first stop on the 2022
grand chess tour
hi i'm peter svidler and with me is uh
the one the only assassin
five how are we doing we're doing great
as always peter it's a pleasure to be
here in studio with yourself hello
everyone and welcome to our coverage the
first three rounds featured one victory
per round it was a steady diet until the
floodgates opened in round fours we had
three decisive victories
peter do the honors and tell us our
current standings absolutely
uh wesley having won yesterday wesley is
leading the tournament the three points
out of four uh having had a very very
solid and uh good tournament so far
three players are chasing him with two
and a half out of four uh two of those
won yesterday leonardo maximo chile grav
and uh the local favorite bogdan dayak
is also doing uh very very well yan
nippon she currently is weirdly the only
player on 50
and the only player i believe with two
decisive games so far
and then there are five people on uh one
and a half out of four having lost one
and drawn the remainder remainder of
their games
so very tightly a tightly packed bun and
our format
uh the formula for this is it's a 10
player that round robin uh 90 minutes
for the for the first 40 moves 30
minutes for the rest of the game and the
30 second increment from one the
standard quote-unquote feeder time
control draw first are not allowed
whatsoever and we have a standard
scoring system with a one point for a
win and have a point for a draw with
four rounds in the history books what's
our current schedule like
uh today is the last last round before
the rest day so players are i think more
incentivized than ever to to give their
all and then formal rounds to finish the
tournament with potential playoffs on
saturday if necessary
alejandro good to see you my friend
where do we stand how do we get here
well great to start my morning with you
guys and let's take a look at how those
decisive games yesterday shook up the
standings how the players are in pole
position got their starting with maxine
by sherlock graf he had a quiet affair
to start the tournament he drew against
dominguez he drew a very quiet game
against wesley he also drew against
mamadiarov but yesterday he had a big
fight against fabiano carrada the
american came after him sacrificed
a bunch of material but
maxim just took it he said i can defend
i can calculate well and he
cruised with the extra piece towards
victory meanwhile levon aronian another
player that has had immense success in
the tour he had a rocky affair getting
here he had a wild game against rapport
the better of the draw against dayak but
then was completely lost against alireza
furuja somehow managed to save that game
from absolute destruction and then with
the black pieces played a very nice game
and defeated lanier dominguez now sits
on a plus one that while he was playing
that game against alireza nobody would
have believed that score and of course
speaking of dak the local hero bogdan
daniel he is coming in hot he drew it
with the black pieces against nepo he
drew a tough game against lavonna ronyan
then he had this crazy [ __ ] against
richard report it seemed like the
evaluation was swinging up and down but
just as mu 40 was being reached in an
equal position richard rapport blundered
horribly that took full advantage of
that and then a draw solidly with the
black pieces against mamadiara puts him
in a beautiful second place great
tournament for the locals so far but of
course it's the leader that we have to
talk about wesley so has been handed
positions he just adores this pair of
bishops of opposite colors on the board
him having the advantage with the
initiative and the better weaknesses
this happened both against shotgun
against nepal with an extra pawn he
converted both of them and now he sits
on plus two he had two all
very solid draws against mvl you could
argue he was even pushing against favi
but now wesley sits on first place and
we know he just loves taking this
tournament into cruise control but today
he has a big challenge and to talk about
that we're gonna go with our friends in
bucharest anastasia and christian
thank you alejandro and welcome back
everybody to day five of the 2022
superbad chess classic from location
here in bucharest romania to call all
the action and give you all the updates
throughout the day i am your host grand
master christian kirilla alongside my
brilliant co-host one grandmaster
anastasia carlovich anastasia welcome
back
yesterday we had an amazing day filled
with a lot of exciting events three
decisive results how do the people here
in romania react to that
yeah of course it's great to be here
hello everybody hello saint louis and
we're so lucky to be
next to the plane when you have chance
to go and visit it from time to time i
noticed that those spectators tried to
stay until the end because the games
were so interesting and many of them of
course used this chance to grab an
autograph and take some photos with
their
top players with their favorites it's
been a really nice day
absolutely and
tell us what do you have your eyes set
on for today in terms of decisive and
exciting games yes usually you know we
are trying to predict which game will be
the most interesting one of course all
my eyes are set to the game um between
levon narayan and wesley so both of them
won their games yesterday both of them
are in a really good mood we saw 11
yesterday during the dinner he is
confident he is happy after his victory
over linear and also after this really
nice draw against perugia and of course
wesley soy i mean is the leader of the
tournament but everything can change
dramatically if the one will manage to
win today with white pieces actually if
you remember the score lemon can has
some hopes because he won four games um
against wesley saw and lost only two
with some draws i'm expecting a really
good fight what about you big
all-american clash is definitely a one
to follow i have my eyes set on the big
clash between the youngest competitors
in the event that is pogdan daniel the
romanian superstar against ali reza
firuja who is only 18 years of age and
came into this event as the rating
favorite well these players have never
faced each other this is their first up
they have absolutely no information
about how the other player plays what he
likes what he doesn't like they don't
know anything about each other and this
uh is going to mean that we're going to
see a very intriguing fight also bogdan
daniel deck i have to say coming into
the event as uh 2670 well he impressed
up to this point two and a half out of
four plus one that is a great result for
the young romanian superstar up to this
point ali reza on the other hand he came
into the event as the rating favorite
the top dog of the event and
unfortunately for him he has not
confirmed he
lost but after that even against levon
aronian was unable to win a crushing
position well today with the black
pieces he's going to do something and
let's wait and see what that is going to
be how about you guys in st louis
well thank you anastasia and thank you
christian indeed let's take a look at
all the pairings peter please do the
honors
the pairings for today are uh up top
there we see two players who are perhaps
somewhat unused
yeah unused to being on minus one after
four rounds if i'd be with the white
pieces against shahriar uh yan
nipomnishi will be i think very
interested in the idea of bouncing back
from yesterday's loss because of the
white pieces against mvl another you
know very very promising match-up
they're both very very combative and
fighting players the central game of the
round of course is the game between
levon aronian and wesley saw uh which
was spoken about
already uh we also have the game between
uh richard rapport and linda dominguez
[Music]
another couple who would like to improve
the situation in the tournament and then
yes the game between uh bogdan dayek and
the rest of europe is very interesting
because alireza i think has not been in
the minors
for you know this amount of rounds in a
row for i don't know the last
five years yes
since he was playing in junior
competitions i was just gonna probably
not in the junior is that yeah
i would suspect he was he was getting a
lot of points in the juniors the four
candidates in this tournament are
remarkably all four are in the bottom
half
of the tournament uh it goes to show
just how strong the event is but also
shocking is we have a basketball player
from romania virgo stanesco is making
the first move today uh
is he towers over the chessboard he's
gonna have to
okay he is thinking about a good move
that is something that's a very good
move very decent move yeah
wouldn't be surprised if he actually
played chess to be honest and i think a
lot of a lot of professional
athletes do
do some chasing in their spare time you
see those pictures all the time of
players and dressing rooms people all
over the world you know
spending down time uh playing chess
which is nice
and
it's been great fighting chess and what
are they fighting for
uh
mainly pride of course as you can see on
your screen uh a thousand a hundred
thousand dollars of prizes
yeah and uh uh if you win if you win the
tournament i'll try to get 13 gcc points
and if you have to play tie breaks to
win it you get 12. and then uh it all
tapers down to
10.5 per 10th very very nice price fund
indeed 350 000 in a total for those of
you figuring it out and yes if you
finish well in the grand chess tour and
you get a lot of points there's a bone
additional bonus money with an
additional
100 000 in prize money for the grand
chest horror
uh winner and
here we have wesley so not only our
tournament leader but defending grand
chester champion he says damn it my
opponent's missing i'm starting his
clock
as as is good and proper
and i remember i went to the home of
bill walton a very famous basketball
player uh
here in the united states and he's a
chess player too so
yeah a lot of basketball players the
games are underway this is very
enjoyable because mvl has been
introducing kind of quieter openings
into his repertoire but today we are
going to get the neighborhood in his
game against jan and uh
i don't know uh you know perhaps since
the word has disappeared from a
broadcast i should use the word residual
i'm not sure about how much residual
neither prep uh is is left
[Music]
okay i mean
i was going to say
bishop b5 check has kind of like
prevented anybody from playing but
specifically
yeah this is weird
it is it is an unusual move order but if
let goes knight bd7 it transposes into a
position which actually has been
discussed quite a bit recently via the
normal b5 check move order i'm more
interested in what the plan is against
bishop d7 i suspect it might be bishop
d3 question mark question mark because
really i
i mean i really dislike the idea of
trading those bishops this early but
maybe we just go knight c3 and you can
ignore you're trying to prove that the
bishop is is worse yeah
it's actually looking at this
d7 96 is just so comfortable what we
were saying is that uh players who are
trying to play the night off these days
are really uh getting annoyed by the
movie bishop b5 check i understood peter
that the reason and there's this sort of
a newfangled way of playing this
position where they take with not with
the queen but actually with the knight
i've done this myself and madness has
done this yeah tonight and after night
of six you can actually leave the pawn
on a forum prison castle
and this has been a a topic of some
discussion recently it's not that stupid
really there's also the uh and the sort
of the
somewhat more conservative but maybe
slightly more weird move instead of
castles here which is also quite topical
has been played by very strong players
is bishop b5 g3 here
no kidding which really does look like
you know it's it's a novice playing
these moves but it really isn't there is
a there is a point to luring the knight
37 where it cannot really go to c6 which
is really the best square for the
sicilian to attack this knight on d4
after bishop b5 check do we have a move
no nbl's yes
not just yet king's over and alejandro
you've got a big smile on yourself face
something's
something's making you a happy camper
we got richie being richie that's what
makes me a happy camper look at this e4
e5 how many times have we seen that
before on broadcast and how many times
yesterday we looked at the move knight
on g1 not to f3
but to e2 and immediately doming is
starting to think i i can tell you the
answer to your question precisely
zero not quite a novelty apparently
there's a voucher carlsen game here in
2017 of course i have actually i believe
looked at this no
why
why why did you do it because i have
young young colleagues and friends
who make me look at things oh my word
knight e2 can you explain it to us
at all no no there i mean there is no
logical advantage of having the knight
on e2 that are on f3 except you would
think
you you you don't want to play the
petrov basically so you are you know
quote unquote preparing for knight f6
how so uh and now you can play g4 and if
knight takes e4 you have the move f3
which you wouldn't normally have in this
position because your knight will be
there
so the knight has to awkwardly retrieve
the knight take on e5 even this is
supposed to be equal yeah yeah i mean
we're not really you know claiming any
advantage here i'm just saying this
exists and is not as
completely pointless as it you know
because your knight is on e2 you get to
play f2 f3 but another question
over under on how long linear thinks
on move two here after the move knight
e2 i'm going to call 10 minutes 23
minutes
what
23 minutes
probably not but if anybody's gonna do
it it's lanier yeah i'm calling ted by
the way uh on our marquee matchup
between lavonne and wesley we do have an
appearance of uh lavonne in the playing
hall as we have a symmetrical english c4
c5 absolutely
and it's something they both are
incredibly capable of doing i lost a
very painful game to wesley
upstairs from here last year in the
sinkhole cup where i did something
ridiculous against the symmetrical
english and was basically lost by move
15.
well then yeah it's an achievement yeah
it's an issue
what have you done uh knight uh f6 and
knight c6 uh
kind of a peculiar move order for me
someone computer
you know g6 is like everybody's go-to
and if you're going to play knight f6
in these symmetrical you're going to do
knight f6 and d5 rather
probably quickly
i'm curious as to what he's trying to
achieve
yeah the year actually has already made
a move so we were all wrong
i said ted yeah it was much closer yeah
you you you win you win the spread but
yeah yeah we had a young fan there
really worried about lanier yeah
thinking things through
okay and what else do you have for us uh
alejandro
uh not much a couple of openings just to
go to see what everybody's doing uh
bogeytan and ali reza are gonna be
playing as sharp kings india and they
move bishop et already in the border
expect knight f3 uh to come up
more or less what you would expect from
alareza something sharp something that
will keep the game alive bishop g5 over
you were expecting you were expecting uh
you were expecting a knight of three
there yeah now not that
they move h4 in this position one of
those new tries right where you play h4
against basically any fiance
but with the bishop on e2 you're
actually throwing the move h5 on the
next move let's see how this one plays
out because this is going to be fun h4
against the king's indian and alaris are
also going for it saying the king's
indian is my choice today i'm not afraid
of a risk
nice absolutely
um and by the way just uh funnily enough
after knight e2 that eight minute was it
eight minute think uh knight uh f6 i
think you played d4 yeah yeah but d4 is
the the entire point there yeah and
otherwise 92 makes no sense whatsoever
and as you were pointing out if uh
linear does capture you have to play f3
actually because g5 bishop c5 you might
regret your
life choices quite quite severely yeah
yeah no d5 uh the did you say d e or d
do you fight gdp g5 makes no sense
d5 bishop is also
rather awkward somewhat unattractive
yeah yeah you can play queen d5 and
pretend it's all
part of the game part of the plan but it
really isn't bishop takes f2 and then f5
i think you're kind of lost honestly
right
i would not be surprised to find that
this is just just straight up
exactly so
okay but there is as you said knight
takes f3
the knight has to go back to an awkward
time i assume d6 and f5 i think the 605
is what the machine does here why it
goes like queen d3 and the game
continues
okay i think something along those lines
i i did at some point have it in front
of me on my screen but i
ages ago successfully blocked it out
because
you have to empty your chalice
in order to fill it up with something
else
well we'll definitely keep an eye on
that game by the way we mentioned a
number of players in
desperate situation to get victories
especially the players with -1
picking up on the game between
fabi
my pick for the tournament and shaq
well it's not looking good for either
player on the onset of the game yeah i
mean it's one of the more solid
sublime sublimes of the petrov here in
my eyes this is sort of the chinese
petrol because i think the popularity of
these systems where black goes on bishop
5 and 96 is very largely due to the
efforts of uh sort of a whole brigade of
chinese players as you as we see on our
screen perhaps the most famous recent
game from this exact line including the
position we have on the board right now
is between yanipam nishi and one hao
from from the candidates
uh you yankee has also been playing a
ton of this and uh
and others as well it's very very solid
uh impressions yeah and white needs to
be extremely precise to maintain even a
shot of
pausing problems here because
the structure is so symmetrical four
versus four three versus three very hard
to create an imbalance so basically
white currently has some slight
initiative due to better development
slightly more active pieces but if black
manages to parry this first wave without
like committing any uh
major gaps yeah yeah but also like
without any structural structural
changes
trades will start happening along the
e-file and then the position
very much
equalizes itself so
but this is very very topical i would be
shocked if
fiber didn't have a very sort of a
concrete idea as to what he is planning
to do here all right let's uh return to
the nepal game in just a moment
because we do have uh
as you've reacted with a whoa
peter tell us what what what
what's going on c2 c4 hanging the pawn
on e4 whoa yeah
uh all of these things kind of flow into
each other there are there are lines
like this uh and this is kind of a
i would
like i i don't know if it's an improved
version or not but this is a like a a
new version uh a fine tuning of a
reasonably old idea uh if you give a
check on move three
uh because this is what we will be
we will be comparing it to forever
constantly have to discuss here yeah if
you have a check on move three and black
goes bishop d7 there is the most c4 yeah
the move c4 exists here i i've actually
played this myself in uh definitely
blitz games and maybe even uh some
rapping games somewhere but fighter 6
you go knight c3 here you don't go g4
exactly you you don't just leave your
pawn and basically in all of these
structures the point of going c4 as
early as possible is precisely to be
able to play knight c3 uh with the sort
of the beginnings of the marathi
structure already on the board right uh
but jan is doing it via a different move
order where
uh if you don't take on e4 right now and
mvl has already declined the invitation
by the way
uh if you don't take only four we might
see some transpositions to those to
those those exact structures yeah and
i'm assuming knight takes e4 is probably
met by
castles or i mean if you cut like these
pawn sacrifices actually do work a
surprising amount of the time but here
you beat gary kasparov
with one of these bonds
exactly like that i think i think there
it's much more obvious that you have
enough of a development advantage than
here i thought maybe queen of three
queen f3 but maybe queen a5 check is a
good reply because i thought maybe we
can just
because knight of six queen takes b7 i
think is really kind of resides right
yeah yeah yeah so you you can't do that
at all right and the polymer seven in
general is
is the one you don't really want to lose
queen eight but if i check
bothers me because i don't really
understand what the reply here would be
uh without you know allowing some
stabilization maybe i can actually play
king f1 but this is one of those
positions where
uh
without asking alejandro what the
machine says it's kind of guess work
uh but it does feel compensation i mean
well maybe even dangerous it forces
knight c5 but with the point of me for
od5
is a good good shot but my point was
including a5 checks so that once it's
played
a5 check once we play knight c5 b2b4 is
at the very least a sacrifice maybe
maybe it's still playable actually
before queen before bishop b3
it certainly looks like this is uh
initiative all day for white and in in
any case let me do it with the knight on
d2 right rather than the or that as well
yeah as well yeah
i thought knight takes two might be
playable but then we have such a
development advantage that we're
probably not unhappy uh so that would be
my my first very very kind of early
guess as to what might be meant but i
think mvl very understandably says
thanks but no thanks to all of that
and uh and goes into uh goes into a much
kind of a safer situation with 96 g6
then as you were pointing out white has
achieved his so-called moroccy bind with
his pawns on a c4 and e4
yeah and these positions
aren't supposed to be all that bad for
black to be honest with the amount of
light uh minor pieces already off the
board i would assume
uh this isn't horrible but
exactly this type of structure has
always been kind of the the the end goal
of playing bishop b5 check and
particularly black it's 37 in response
because it's impossible in most cases it
will be impossible to equalize by force
and then you know you get to play a
position where yes black is by no means
you know defenseless and has resources
and i honestly i suspect the objective
quote unquote objective evaluation will
be very very close to zeros and right
but
it's a game it's a game we we've
successfully established
you know some kind of a foothold and did
not allow any of the forced
simplifications well i think this is a
the position this is a position which
both players will happily embrace as
it's not the fabiano
shack game that it's just
i i
i'm not pleased for those players who
need to win uh alejandro you you you
need a fight you need a fighting
position you want the fighting position
but it's still not that late in the
tournament and let's remember that favi
needs to keep some stuff for the
candidates and i think that he will be
okay with some kind of slight positional
pull if you can get it from shock i was
looking through this game and just so
that i can
answer your questions after c4 knight
takes e4 is playable but the computer
says queen f3 is such a huge advantage
for white that you shouldn't do this and
the reason is that after queen a5 you
actually have the move b4 which i assume
that without prep you don't really go
into this but
never probably knew it queen takes
before bishop d2 knight takes d2 knight
takes d2 and the problems of defending
the b7 are surprising but very difficult
to parry because if you put the knight
on c6 i can take twice the development
advantage is still very big this king on
e8 is going to be stuck in the center
for a while now let me check dominguez i
think has not played after the move d4
okay so very very surprised this is
where the 23 move thing comes this is
where the 23 minute thing comes in
that's correct meanwhile the game
between deck and alireza i love when
games in very theoretical variations
suddenly somehow find a way to not be
theory anymore king's indian how many
times have we looked at this structure
how many games have we seen with this
configuration of the aviancado against
the strong center but by move 8 h4
knight c6 d5 95 h5 and c6 there's only
four games that have been played exactly
in this position so i love the
creativity that the players are bringing
as usual stockfishers hate the king's
indian to start out with they've gotten
better at this but this particular
version they don't like it too much and
they're good for a very computer-esque
h6 alpha zero we call them
type of uh pushes where
it as yaser is baffled
confounding confound this is modern
chess right wow it's absolutely modern
chess there's been an understanding
lately that this pawn on h6 can become
extremely annoying for the black pieces
later who will have difficulties
maneuvering around because of lack of
space and also because many times black
is the one that wants to open up the
king side so despite the fact that for
years this pawn push all the way to h6
was considered a mistake because it
helped black's defense because it didn't
open up lines against the king lately we
found out perhaps that's not the case
the pawn on h6 actually is very powerful
the bishop on h8 feels uncomfortable
about it and we'll see if this pays off
for the romanian
wow i mean the move bishop e2 i was
thinking of the opera box system and
kind of a shout out to yuri offer i was
wondering if bishop g5 was coming
exactly which was
my old stomping grounds as a tribute
yeah bishop g5 is what i played through
much of my career uh gary um
kasparov got
an advantage against me and i had to
give up my beloved uh averbach system
but it was definitely not with the
concept of
h2h4 that i was playing
uh this system is white yeah and knight
six is the interesting bit here for me
because uh this move order is
i mean separate but if you play c5
instead of knight c6 it transposes into
a position which
these days these days is much more known
from the
third h4 move against the the grunfeld
right and you get it via this mobarida
and this is this is sort of very very
heavily trodden ground you play g5 v6 h5
uh and uh there have been a lot of very
very high level games here ed5 ed5
through k8 let's say
uh they play king of one here they play
a knight f3 uh bishop g5 i think is a
move here as well there's been some very
uh
serious discussion uh discussion on this
topic and i've been i've looked at this
for for my own greenfield series when i
had to address the question of what to
do against three h4
and i came to the conclusion that it's
playable but it's not really entirely to
my taste and i gave something else
but uh i was kind of fully expecting
alireza to play c5 because this does
feel like the most perhaps natural move
in the position but uh he goes for a
much more much more combative structure
because
the reason i didn't like c5d56 here is
specifically because uh how little i
found in those positions in a way of you
know actual winning chances for black i
believe black holes but
i also couldn't really figure out how to
uh you know get particularly white
particularly yeah i get particularly
excited about these types of positions
because it seemed like
like white's ready to go probably is not
not the main move here i think they go
uh yeah
knight f3 or something let's not go too
far into down down that rabbit hole but
uh yeah alireza uh chose something which
uh
leads to much more fighting positions
with a a lot more
uh a lot more potential for for double
edged and uh and uh
interesting play now presumably after
the move knight dece knight c6 i beg
your pardon
daniel played d5 right away to avoid uh
the possibility of maybe h5e yeah e594
will die d4 generally generally in the
king's indians yeah this is something
whenever you get a knight on d4 you're
kind of a happy camper which is why we
saw the move e5 d5 95 h5 yeah after c7
c6 this move i i understand alpha zero
and
well quite frankly alpha zero's alpha
zero but you play h4 h5 against a and
shadow set up so you can play h6 and i
just yeah we're actually still following
a game between two two very strong
indian players all of this has been seen
in the game between aravind and ajibon
in india
so
clearly
bogran is not doing this empty-handed i
am always a little bit confused about
how
attracted everyone has become to this
concept of playing h6
with the pawn on e7 with the pawn on e5
i don't think you would be questioning
it no but with apollo 7 meaning that the
bishop on h8 is very much alive because
the long diagonal is still very open
exactly it confuses me just how much the
engines love it honestly
still despite you know i have seen the
alpha zero games i am aware that
you know this is something that
that machines quite like but
uh
here for instance i don't know knight f3
bishop f3 97
bring the other one to e5 play queen a5
bishop d7 you know get get your normal
kind of king's indian type play
safe in the knowledge that your king
side now is not going to be
opened up is it
because the computer move after knight
takes f3 statistics
i was wondering about gf yeah really i
was wondering whether i'm just you know
too you know blithely assuming that this
bishop takes when it's really not
and then must be three queen g2 and i
guess the king stays somewhere around
the f1 square i don't think it castles
queenside although i can imagine some
scenarios where it does but
it could also stay in the center for
quite some time or go to f1 and just
stay there i'm not
see yeah for for me this is a real
generational gap i mean again i was
raised on my 60 memorable games by bobby
fisher where he he had the formula h4 h5
sac sack mate
he didn't say
h4h5h6 and don't sacrifice
six and then win the end game exactly
that was not what bobby bobby said we'll
keep an eye on what should be a very
exciting uh game between the two youths
uh what do you have for us alejandro
let's see how lanier handled the
position in this
semi-petrol i'm not really sure what to
call it after the move 92 knight f6 was
played anyway and richie played the move
d4 perhaps here lanier noticed that
after knight takes a4 this f3 led into
complications he wanted nothing to do
with that instead took on d4 which
actually seems like a very reasonable
solution once you look past a couple of
moves e5 more or less has to be played
you can't really gambit this pawn on e4
right and queen takes the 49bc6 is bad
so e5 is pretty much forced 94 was
played in this position and then queen
takes d4 hitting the knight and this
kind of resembles this position with the
knight on f3 right but the one that's
not on f3 it's on e2 right d5 takes on
d6 is forced because now bishop c5 was
coming and taking your pawn on f2 knight
takes d6 and the move knight bc3 knight
c6 played on the board and compared to
tons of petrov's and positions in which
white could argue that when the queen
moves
there's a little bit of an initiative
you could move the bishop out long
castle but for that initiative to be
true i think your knight has to be on f3
this bishop needs to be ready to go
exactly otherwise your knight is kind of
hemming in your pieces i can't imagine
blacks actually worse in this position
and we do have asymmetrical structures
three on three three on three
perhaps not surprisingly
is solved in my opinion all of his
opening problems but he's done it also
in a kind of dry way he's not really
allowing any tactics or any imbalances
the way that knight takes e4 f3 allowed
he's just happy with playing black and
killing the game
well look it looks pretty good for uh
for for black in my eyes but let's join
our friends in bucharest romania how are
you christian and anastasia
thank you yasir well uh we just wanted
to join you to kind of give you a quick
update because we have a lot of very
interesting
ideas being played out in the opening
phase of these games and one of them is
the one in report versus um
dominguez yes and this is the game that
you actually wanted to talk about tell
us a bit about the story of this knight
e2 move uh okay i just wanted to mention
that i was at the plane wayne at the
time and uh after richard played this
game this move 92 uh everybody started
kind of laughing you know i saw nepal
who stood up and he saw the move 92 on
the board and he was just couldn't
believe his eyes and he started to smile
and reach us saw him smiling and i mean
suddenly everyone um noticed the move
and started and i think everybody now is
in a good mood you know no matter what
happened in their games and i think the
only player who was not laughing was
actually linear himself he started to
think about the position
and though you could see him probably on
the commerce yeah so it's really
interesting and i think all the
spectators also were a bit confused
about that move um i i also saw it the
first time and i actually had a chat
with sevina bulmarga who just came to
visit the plane venue uh the leader of
the national team of romania and um but
by the way christian what about you or
do you meet your friends here in
bucharest it's your town actually
absolutely yeah it's always uh such a
pleasure to come back to bucharest to do
commentary for super bad work but also
it's such a pleasure to be back home and
i was of course chatting with a lot of
uh former players former friends while
still friends of course but with uh
which i haven't talked in a very long
time and we were discussing the games as
well and they were pointing out look at
this 92 look at this 92 and i was like
okay this 92 i know it's funny but let's
try to understand uh compare it with
knight to f3 knight to f6 because this
is obviously what richard was trying to
uh
avoid right because dominguez is so good
with the petrov knight to e2 knight to
f6 now d4 is going to be a very
intriguing game but another game that i
was uh having my eyes on of course is
the one that i mentioned at the
beginning of the broadcast as well the
one between dak and fearuja and actually
the president of the romanian federation
came and we were looking at the game up
to the point where that played the move
bishop to e2 and after that i told him
if he follows up with h4 we're going to
have a huge fight and he immediately
played that move h4 and uh he was
shocked he was like oh my god what is
happening we're going to have an amazing
game and uh yeah i think uh this one is
not going to disappoint for sure guys
back to you thank you anastasia thank
you christian i always like that when
somebody's made a move in the playing
hall 92. it's like all of the players
get up collectively go over there they
start high-fighting one another laughing
at your move and it's like you guys get
out of here you're bothering me never
happened to you peter then i've had a
kind of a similar experience once where
uh i played a very important like it's
it's kind of a traumatic story in the
end but it started off it started off
funny i
perhaps the only real time when i
surprised vici in the opening in the the
entirety of our encounters over the
board uh he played an open spanish
against me and for some reason i knew of
the existence of the novelty in a very
topical at the time position uh which he
didn't which like it's a 100
caught him yeah and
and then the entire tournament was
coming to a board and giggling because
apparently like
75 percent of the players in the
tournament knew of knight takes f7
but just about only vicious only vicious
didn't which is really really extremely
rare yeah yeah and yeah and it was a
kind of a funny funny situation to be in
but then basically uh as usual i knew
the novelty was there but i didn't know
any follow-ups so i spent like an hour
and a half in the next four moves and it
was a really really messy game and
it didn't end well but
yeah i've had that once wonderful i just
want to turn our attention to the game
between uh ian and mvl because a couple
of moves here we did again this was our
kind of maroxy bind position and queen
d3 and i'm so used to seeing the move
rook on f8 to c8 in such positions and
you follow it up with a7 and a6 i really
don't look at any of the moves and then
came this move queen c6 was a bit of a
surprise
and then okay bishop d4 you're
challenging this diagonal and
maybe on a good day you're even
threatening maybe to capture this knight
and jump to d5 and find
the black a little bit awkward in those
positions a7 a6 and then the immediate
jump knight d5
not even a castles or a bishop takes f6
and knight takes pawn takes bishop back
and it it always
well i don't know
i was raised believing that this
positions were better for white because
e7
is a little bit
more i think it's a better target than
c4 depends on tempe i would suggest i
think uh it very much depends on how
much pressure you can exert against the
e7 pawn immediately and also a very
important plan in these types of
positions is actually h4 h5 because uh
simply putting pressure on the e7 pawn
alone will not win you the game because
black will defend upon this deep into uh
in in their position right but if you
combine it with the idea of opening up
the king side the player the the cramped
nature of of black setup does often
offer uh offer wide chances for for
success but
here uh
if you put the position of the castles
on the board as jan already played
castles
we are still some tempe away from doing
anything on the e file at all i can
start with b5 here for instance i don't
know if we're supposed to react on i
suspect we don't i suspect we just go
like rook a1 and allow b take c4 right
but then black gets a target on d5 to
play against
uh we will take on c4 we'll play it on
rook c8 rock c5 from b8 and b5 there's
going to be a very obvious
uh i guess the other rook i don't
particularly want to block
you like the a6 pawn but there is this
awkward check
yeah you might have i guess i'm still
taking white here after king g8 you go
rookie three rook fe one yeah but it's
not very much and uh
also
with only with only the heavy pieces
left on the board and the [ __ ] i think
very very very um relevantly in the
current position there is no rook only
one yet
i want to ask you the question please
how high do you rate the the the
probability of actually winning the
position after e75 gtx e6 um
yeah don't think it's anything
yeah i don't think of it that way i
think of it more as like do i have the
pressure
but do you specifically hear with all
the rooks on the starting square so like
okay i've just castled so everybody's
happy and you're saying e5 of course i'm
doing episodes yeah there's no question
about that yeah now the question is
you're recapturing isis
i'm thinking with the queen here yeah so
you're just taking the isolated pawn and
you're happy
happy no but i think with the pieces
where they are like i go queen f6 here
and i try to push for b7b5 as early as
possible
perhaps even immediately
i mean i see a lot of weaknesses this i
think is just a draw no bc4 just a draw
oh my gosh
i mean
i see i see two results yeah but i think
it's like 80 20 is what my what my point
well that's a pretty high percentage
okay i yeah i
would uh i think you hold this with
black i don't think you hold it
while enjoying it at any point
but i think you hold it but yeah
nepo preparation
if you're holding upon down yeah nice
i'm not a pawn down i know you're not
yeah
but yeah mvl disagrees and nvl
i i can't really say this with any
degree of certainty but i i get the
feeling that after yesterday
uh this might actually be
jan just making moves because normally
you know somebody of his strength
somebody who has just played the world
championship match he's on 133 after 18
moves or whatever it is right now 17.
yeah you say this is definitely home
prep
i think
he might just be in the mood for
you know making some logical looking
moves and trusting his hand because i
think he was very annoyed yesterday oh
no doubt about it you hate to lose such
a game yeah as he lost yesterday and it
was an important game after all it was a
clash of absolutely tournament leaders
and again i'd just like to put it before
our panel and as well as invite our
audience to join the discussion
i'm stunned that the four candidates in
the tournament are in the bottom half of
the of the cross table what's going on
well actually
jan is on 50 so he he he but still he's
tied for he's like fifth or so he is
fifth yeah um but he's the only one
who's not in the mind
right
you know our candidates come on guys our
candidates
have a 50 or less
between themselves chess is hard what
can i say uh but this is a particularly
tough tournament i feel that everybody
that's coming in with ideas
that's not a candidate can just say i i
don't care i'm going to use my ideas
whereas the candidates they're like
thinking about which openings they're
going to be using eventually which
openings we're going to be using now and
now i'm not making that as an excuse
look at this uh
headed to the candidates people fabiana
carono playing his one two three four
appearance in the candidates jan of
course on his second having won the
first time he showed up and richard
rapport and alareza fruits are headed to
their first candidates in madrid next
month certainly very strong players
there's a lot of pressure right now in
ferruja to most especially most
especially to perform he's the youngest
player he would have been the top seed i
believe he's still the top seed of that
tournament i don't know
past him right well he has but uh it
still hasn't been officially announced
the ding gets in i mean we we all assume
that but i think feeder hasn't really
made an announcement yet yeah yeah
but in any case yeah i mean ferocious
coming here and they're taking risks
right i mean look at how she's handling
this knight e g4 right he's just coming
in and taking some breaks the thing is
he hasn't been able to fully convert
some positions
i'm being told that it is a novelty as
we had mentioned knight takes f3 and the
only other game played their adi we
mentioned
uh it it seems like farouza has gotten
good positions right but that miss
against arunian was huge it's just huge
right it's just
the switch from something you would
expect
to something that okay that's not so not
so bad listen to jan with the black
pieces i mean
sorry with white it happens it happens
once in a while absolutely it's not
something absolutely crazy but
crazy is not converting that position he
would have been a normal 50 percent
yeah
with that
talk about the move 95 to g4 a moment uh
i understand that's a novelty and white
just says okay i'm very happy i'm
castled uh my pawn on h6 is an asset not
a liability it is defended after all and
i always feel it's a huge asset uh i
love putting pawns on h6 and just
getting that space this knight on g4 is
very happy about the pawn being all the
way here because it is a target for the
knight and it cannot be evicted by the
pawn coming to h3 but where's your
counter play exactly here you guys
mentioned you don't want to touch the e
pawn because there is already a pawn h6
and in some ways this is a long-term
strategical prophylaxis you don't want
to play variations with e5 you don't
want to play variations with e6 you'd
rather um blow up the center somehow i
think i want to play the variation with
e6 but if you play e6 in this kind of
position so you play a move like bishop
g5 the engines are saying take either
one of the pawns and then play something
like bishop g5 but i'm just going to put
the move bishop g5 because i like him
and i take the pawn and open up the e
file for my rook yeah here rookie 8.
yeah this kind of play
it's okay but the more you go down the
lines like for example the e-file opens
you're gonna have some background
threats eventually so white is happy
long term that some files get open here
even takes takes i assume queen d2 is a
good movie your queen d2 is fine and the
engines love white they just absolutely
love white this one specifically they're
giving a plus 1.5 advantage already for
the white pieces they're saying you have
weaknesses your knights are pretty but
they're not doing very much and i'm
controlling most of the center don't
forget that black is still playing with
a lot of pieces on the back row and
you're trying to open up the position
but where are the pieces going to go
before you open up the position that's
also not so clear even the move bishop
d7 doesn't help your position very much
you want the pawn on d6 defended when
you go e6 so
by putting the pawn h6
i believe white is challenging black to
find a useful plan
peter chess is hard yes
and jesus is very hard very well aware
but we have some tweets but we do have
uh we don't have uh people tweeting in
so they can rock our world everybody
joan
uh yeah a tweet from john dodd uh uh
by far all the players play like a
computer my question is would bobby
fisher or michael tile uh survive in
this generation
um
yes
i mean the easy answer is yes but you do
have to kind of ask for some
clarifications if we take if we take uh
michelle bobby and give them you know
their amount of opening knowledge by
1970
and beat them against the modern players
with the amount of opening knowledge in
particular that they have
that probably skews it very much in
favor of the current generation but if
you uh if you give the legends of the
past i don't know a year to get
reacquainted with you know how things
have moved on
uh
i think yes very you know both of those
would very easy to stack up against
absolutely great chess geniuses
i'll just i'll just speak a little bit
on that topic about bobby because bobby
in the second half of his
life uh essentially came to the
conclusion that chess was being played
out with the theory that computers were
really um killing uh chess with you know
30 40 moves of theory and that was why
bobby liked uh fischer random where you
know you you you get a unique game by
just uh mixing the the pieces on the
first and last ranks
uh to avoid uh the theory thank you for
the question and one more tweet
a question from chirper bar in the truck
yeah
who is mark please tell us more about
him well what we have is is this very
very long chain
and we wrote them up and we don't let
him out and there he is this is
grand master verrusian ocobian uh
this is selling it short this isn't
hard to say like assistant
i think he's got like olympic medals
with the american team
yeah yeah but look he's pretty good he
he once won the saint louis open
somewhere
i'm pretty sure he won a a club
championship maybe maybe it was a blitz
selling him short i liked that that was
pretty good yes uh but varus is a very
accomplished grand master uh we're
fortunate to have him helping us uh
keeping us on our toes as far as
novelties are concerned databases and
sometimes even telling us the best move
or two
yeah so that is verusion
uh what do you have for us alejandro in
uh this game between mvl and netbo not
much to say specifically about the
position but it's the time usage but you
guys mentioned about that preparation
because b5 came on the board and
instantly nepo threw down the move b4
clearly some kind of preparation and
the engine say zero zero but not every
move that was played here by the engine
made too much sense to me uh for example
queen f5 is something that i would be
very afraid to play off without any
preparation because it does allow take
stakes and a potential c5 with the pawn
becoming past black has enough resources
to trade off the pawns and make a draw
but it's not something that i would
instinctively think about something more
natural like b takes e4 queen takes c4
and something like rook's fc8 check
f6 is a normal idea here but it gives up
the e6 square so king j8 is a much
better move and a4 and it's saying well
white still retains a little bit of
pressure you will have h4h5 ideas later
in the position rook fe1 is going to
come at some point and where exactly do
you counter play as black because you
don't want to focus entirely on the
queen side white will be able to defend
those very nicely and you don't want to
give up the c6 square right so there are
some things that black has to be worried
about even though the engine says this
is no problem for black .01 if i looked
at this from a human perspective
it's easy to see which one side would
you would take and i think that's the
type of opposition nep was trying to get
in in today's game
and uh i wanted to turn your attention
peter if you don't mind in the game of
lavon aronian because
we were not taught to do this i don't
know about yourself i mean this is just
theory as
i'm following the game between lavonne
and wesley so our two tournament leaders
wesley so with plus two up against lavon
who miraculously finds himself a plus
one a very happy lavon aronian so we
were not taught to do what exactly give
up our beautiful we we've spent time
putting our bishop on this long diagonal
you know i don't know fianchetto is the
bishop but you give it up i don't
entirely disagree because this line i
actually have some experience with and
uh
on the black side of it i haven't really
played this with wise very much and
this is annoying the the question for me
is like which one is more annoying
because
you can very certainly you you're not
obliged to take on 6 and move 10 there
and there's a lot of theory actually
starting with you can play knight c3
here black normally goes bishop d7 uh
you go bish b3
uh and then you have two ways of solving
the problem of connecting your rooks you
can go for some plans of roxy one king
c2 king b1 or often they play king e1 of
a forking of two a nice way of castling
by a hand uh with rook c1 king c2 and
the second choice you were mentioning
was f4 you won king of two and then one
year
one one goes you're connecting your
rooks and you're happy you're about your
bishops
and uh the
the position i believe is pretty close
to equal but it is
you equalize it with work with very
precise play because if you go a little
bit wrong there and white establishes
this kind of a bind with the very two
two very strong bishops on the
two diagonals and so again knight c3
bishop g7 bishop g6
right
and we go i don't know uh
i like this
apology incoming uh
um i like this uh king c2 very much
castling by hand we'd like to say i mean
because the bishop on december bishop of
five check count to play though
there is there is an issue with with
this plan
that is true and i
well yeah
i can meet it with 94 but maybe i'm not
happy i don't know uh is
am i
i'm doing something once you've played
94 i think i'm much less worried and
also i haven't castled king side yet so
maybe i just castle queenside here
uh so i mean this very much exists and
has been played by very strong players
but
the idea of just taking on c6 before
bishop d7 has been played and then just
playing against that one weakness
uh is also i mean we've seen it in in
all kinds of uh
specific english opening structures i
think the idea of just spoiling the
structure and playing against it
giving up the two bishops so early
though it seems i don't know
counter-intuitive i uh
what can i say yeah i'm surprised it's
uh
you're not aiming for very much here but
you are playing a very very risk-free
position where
um
sometimes if black is not very accurate
he will get
quite significant pool on on the queen
side and it seems like levon is also
he's sort of trying to out wesley wesley
here
he he got a very safe
very quiet position and uh
he will start looking for small
advantages after the move
uh we we we didn't see the f2 f4 king
king but we did see the f3 idea and uh
lavon has just pulled his king to e1
what surprises me uh f2 is a very nice
square but you're spending so much time
getting in there exactly exactly it just
wow it just feels to me that somehow if
i after the move king
especially
it seems to me that somehow if i could
just get my pawn to c4 and put a rook on
b8 or a 504 with that or a5 a4 yeah i
i should be getting some
nice
tickle against the pawn on a2
again this is our match-up between our
tournament leaders and we'll keep a
careful eye on that position and
aleandro turning it back to you and the
game of
fabi it's progressing quickly so let me
catch up on what's happened here between
fabiano carrana and shaq mamadiarov we
have uh we left off the position around
here somewhere queen d7 h5
five more or less forced shaq to give up
this dark squared bishop for this knight
on g5 but is it going to be enough for
an advantage
rook fe-8 takes takes and this is the
position on the board the move bishop f6
no immediate threat of queen h3 because
you could trade those queens but it's
looming you can have queen g3 queen h4
at some point your dark scores are very
weak and there's no immediate counter
play so black still needs to be a little
bit precise rook takes you one rook
takes c1 has been played and i assume at
this point you play the move rook e8 not
so much knight e8 because you run into
bishop e5 and it's not easy to get rid
of this construction of course f6 is
impossible because uh the pawn on g6 is
hanging queen g3 at some point will be
very dangerous f3 knight g4 is also
coming so you can't evict the bishop
right away it is much it is very
important in this position to start with
the mover k8 you could consider queen f5
but that doesn't get rid of the bishop
that would lead into a
very annoying but very slight advantage
for white but rookie 8 seems to be okay
i don't know exactly how white is
planning on fighting for the advantage
here you would like to play them with
bishop e5 but unfortunately f6 more or
less works tactically even though you
could take on g6 you have the problem
that after queen g7 uh this knight rook
on the a8 is obviously defended by the
knight and the bishop but this
problem with the rook on e1 is not
defended and white ends up losing a
piece so rookie on the board i'm curious
to see exactly where fave is trying to
get any sort of advantage any sort of
nibble here against shaq because shaq's
playing quickly and it seems like he's
solving most of the problems according
to the engine
yeah it
feels like black is doing
pretty well uh it seems to me um
peter that the youths
are uh the game to be watching right now
as uh farouja's uh
come out with a move queen b6 a little
bit of a puzzling move for me but uh
take away take it away what do you think
i think it's nice in connection with the
knight on g4 where currently uh
alejandra was playing bishop g5 in a lot
of these these types of positions so we
are somewhat disincentivizing you know
or at least or alternatively
incentivizing the blunder of the pawn on
b2 exactly so white is uh
prompted to find a way to protect the
beats of pawn
yeah prior to finishing development
just because this knight on f6 is
putting pressure i want to say against
the pawn on e4 i've and a lot of kings
indian defense players run their pawn to
a4 a5 a4 and then a5 and and follow it
up with queen a5 but ferruccia
chose queen b6 and like you say
inviting blunders of the pawn on b2
hitting f
f2 as well knight takes f2 uh
there is a hint of it even right now but
i'm guessing it wouldn't like against
somebody like something like rugby one
yeah yes i don't think it works just yet
although
yes you can play bishop take c3 queen
takes c3 i was about to say
doesn't get me mated because you take on
g2 with check so all right well uh
makes it awkward for white a little bit
on the other hand i've been hearing um
alejandro telling me you know you just
put the pawn on h6 you're not afraid of
endings you kind of welcome them in some
ways
i wouldn't mind it here i guess so it's
it's one way to react to queen b6
because we are playing a position where
yeah we've definitely given up on an
idea of a direct attack on the king side
here with white oh for sure
so uh yeah perhaps getting the queens
off the board while also opening the a
file for the rook on a1 and then trying
to play with our spatial advantages
is something that you could definitely
consider yeah queen b3 is a bit awkward
you could maybe you could maybe make an
argument for something like queen a5 or
queen c7 here and saying that
it is you who has misplaced
your pieces a little bit compared to i
mean it looks like black lost a tempo
but
maybe you know the queen on b3 is just
straight up worse than the queen on g1
but yeah apart from queen b3 i'm i'm
actually kind of struggling to uh
to name a proactive reaction
it really should not be
you know using those words in the same
sentence uh a4 i thought about it but
once again i'm i feel like my king's
indian pedigree is just not enough to
understand if this is good or bad for
white because they do they do this
sometimes with white but exactly to my
eyes giving up giving up all of these
squares just looks painful i wouldn't i
wouldn't want to do this with white very
very good
and let's just uh recap and tell
everybody where these two youths
stand at the moment
daniel as we see at plus one yeah very
very contrasting fortune so far uh
bogdan daniel is definitely exceeding
expectations he he came into the
tournament as an underdog
clearly the lowest rated player in the
field has had a very very good
tournament so far and conversely uh
farouza our
turn
our tournament favorite if you want to
put it that way by rating at least
uh is struggling at minus one oh but
it's not because of the
positions it's just that at certain
moments he's really failed to capitalize
his opportunity hasn't gone well for him
in critical
was he was at some point definitely
better against uh against jan and he was
absolutely winning
on yeah and
yeah things things are not going
according to plans so far for for the
young
iranian slash french phenom but
uh
tournament is still
you know there's still five rounds to go
counting this one he still has chances
to correct the ship aleandra jump in
with this queen b6 uh for peter and i it
looks dodgy but what can we say
uh
for a human perspective i agree it
doesn't seem to be the first move you
think of but it does have some practical
value and practical values are we're
going to really be talking about because
the engines absolutely hate the way that
alaresa plays and in general i hate
these variations of the king's indian
where you don't play very specifically
down the main lines
for example here the engine is saying
plus two but
not obviously not a plus two position
this is something that is just kind of
weird and practical and tons of mistakes
can happen but yeah the engine says a4
plus 1.8 and very difficult for black to
actually make any kind of uh
of repealing the pieces that white has
but he's playing a very practical move
which i also was very attracted to queen
b3 you try to open up the b file a
little bit safer to trade the queens in
this position and just prevent the
counter play saying the space advantage
uh
produce well into the end game the pawn
on h6 into the end game is going to be
very annoying and a little bit of a
safer approach by deck which i i really
like i think it's it's a great way of
killing counter play and the king's
indians king's indian players come in
trying to go get you with complications
and you just kill their mood
help me out here just play a variation
that might have gone a2 a4 the preferred
move of the computer and a7 a5 all right
a5 the computer likes rook a3 but 91 it
thinks it's just much stronger doesn't
exactly hit the knight on uh g4 but it's
just yeah i think the id is actually
9293 once again my eyesight serving me
well there
uh
good eye good eye meter and somehow
eventually you get this knight off of g4
you get the queen out of b6 black still
doesn't really want to play e5 because
it doesn't accomplish that much but what
do you do with this bishop it's pretty
controlled you don't have b5 ever
say bishop d7 and i try to put a rook on
c8 maybe yeah the rook a3 you start
getting all these problems typical
benoni issues here right so rook c8 just
which one aca let's say ac8 rook b3
queen a7 i don't know where now we go
and now we go knight t2 yes
and you're just laughing at everything
that black has done till now because
what have they done if you open the c
file you give up the b5 square you don't
want to open the c file but then what
are your rooks on c8 and bishop on d7
doing you're not you're really trying to
exploit the exploit the c file right but
there's no exploitation there's no
there's nothing you can do because
you're just too weak on very key squares
that are being left behind when the pawn
breaks happen
nice thank you for
for that especially uh
on having said all of that queen b3 very
practical decision by daniel as he uh
seeks to er to just
keep his uh yeah the engines
the angels obviously think this throws
away much of the advantage but i think
it's a very understandable decision
because exactly honestly to a human eye
it's not immediately obvious why the
position after a4a5 is so horrible i
think i'm picking white there but i'm
you know i think you know everything is
very much still up in the air and yeah
the evaluation of 1.8 by move like 12
here with equal material and no
weaknesses frankly right it's quite
striking yeah but this move knight e1 is
also really remarkable because i was
thinking that with the inclusion of the
moves a4 and a5 that i would very much
like
to put my knight on c5 and then when i
saw this move knight e1 as alejandro
explained
i feel like i'm suddenly
stuck
in the mud a little bit this night on g4
i can't go knight d7 needs protection it
very much hampers the potential counter
play that that you would like to create
on the queen side it's a very clever
move and i think this is what perhaps
was missing just the the understanding
that you can you can move a developed
piece back here and it actually
uh improves your position uh quite a bit
it's a difficult move to find absolutely
well we'll definitely keep our eye on
that one i just wanted to turn our
attention we haven't seen it in a little
bit this is the game between richard
rapport richie as we like to call him
and lanier we thought that after the
knight c6 linear was really solving a
lot of his issues queen a4 for me is
slight surprise bishop d7 i would have i
would like to get on with business and
just
castle asap yeah i think white goes
blackbeast before in castle's long here
nothing else really makes much sense to
me i still don't really believe white
has any advantage whatsoever but it's
the position is actually less quiet than
you would think you do get you don't get
opposite color but if you play with g5
i'll play h4
and
look to sync your knight in uh and
you know if you take on f4 my queen on
a4 which is currently kind of awkward it
gets repositioned on a good square the
kind of a usual square in these types of
pet shops
so
it's still a little bit of a bite for
white i think like and
okay bishop d7 as well
it doesn't create a threat this is the
the point here um from the kasparov um
kasparov karpov matches where where
the knight was actually on f3 in that
match game uh knight f5 was the way that
uh
uh
um karpov solved his opening troubles
and i remember the line of roman gingi
osville very much he says
after this move white has a little bit
of nothing
in knight f5 he felt solved completely
uh the position for black 37 instantly
replied to with bishop du once again uh
richie clearly wants to cast a queen
side here and and then think about where
the pieces belong bishop d7 unless you
you have some kind of a clever way to
follow up that actually does exploit the
awkward queen on a4 i don't quite
understand why it was required it's a
it's a natural enough move
maybe linear himself wants to castle
queenside but that would be i think
slightly artificial something like queen
of six castles long castles long
which will be you know very unusual yeah
95 to begin with but
there's something um
i want to say attractive about you play
bishop d7 i play bishop d2 in the
opening i mean the echoes of the two
moves do we perhaps go 95 and then some
knight to c4
once again trying to trying to justify
previous play i'm i'm not a huge fan to
be honest i'm just trying to figure out
why we went bishop d7 exactly and
yeah i mean if we won if we won the dark
square bishop here maybe we aren't there
i happy like i will take on jitsu rook
and i need to find a way to get my king
to safety and then i'll be fine maybe
there is no way to get my king to safety
quickly enough though there isn't that
there is a an issue that one day knight
d5 could be very disturbing right i mean
if you try to get your king with the two
bishops here i am prepared to advocate
for queen f6
my biggest issue is that it seems to be
a pawn sacrifice i i don't really mind
the end game all that much i do mind the
end game if it's a pawn down and i don't
have any concrete compensation 95 i'll
castle long
uh you will take on f6 and yeah my issue
is which h6 is always met by four i can
play bishop c6 here and
claim that i have compensation and i
think the claim is not even it's not
even entirely you know i'm not lying you
know i think i do have compensation
absolutely because uh the the desired
knight d4 does run into [ __ ]
six absolutely yeah okay uh very well
this is yeah this is very very far down
the rabbit hole none of this happened
and none of this actually is likely to
happen i think
i
i think uh i i i think the commentator's
curse of nothing like this will ever
happen
is already proven is wrong and the clock
times as they as richie and lanier get
into rather creative position
is decisively
as per usual yeah that's one that's what
you would expect yeah
honestly this is the major point of 92
and moved to of course of course because
definitely one of the sort of
slightly understated perhaps compared to
you know the brand names but he is very
much one of the premier
um of our age okay and getting him to
play on his own from move two is kind of
invaluable considering how much how much
he likes to think over the board yeah
remarkable achievement to be sure over
to you alejandro and the matchup between
mvl and nepo
it's a game that might be a bit dry but
i'm starting to get a bit worried for
nepal's position let's take a look at
what happened we left it off after the
move b4 and queen f5 did come on the
board i don't know if nbl knew this
position he was just remembering or if
he just found the queen of five was a
good move over the board anyway the
engine is highly approved of the move
queen five queen d uh
queen e2 is one of the many moves that
white can play everything according to
the engines is zero zero takes takes
rook fc fca check queen f6 and here
nepal's thought for a little bit before
playing the move queen e4 wasn't really
sure if he should take the end just
wanted to go queen b6 and then i was
looking at this with playing around with
it not just uh seeing what the engine
top moves were rook ab8 of course is a
very logical move but also one of them
looked at the move rook c3 just trying
to double up on the c file and then
figuring out where i wanted to counter
attack uh on the white position you can
go rook here and rook c4 try to get some
of these pawns you could go a4 but after
rook ac8 i am pretty active and i am
forcing you to weaken your pawns the
edge is starting to not like white's
position very much you can see a small
minus here and there that indicates that
white has is the one that has to be a
little bit careful not to end up losing
a pawn in a worse position that you can
probably hold does this sound familiar
to anybody
i don't want to see nepo having to
suffer through another end game and i'm
not saying that he's quite there yet but
it does the computer does think that a
couple of the moves he just played were
a bit careless
and we know that's a slippery slope i i
went from my earlier suggestion that
perhaps he is somewhat bluffing today
with the speed of play to thinking that
no i think he actually is uh
very much in book when he replied to b5
with b4 instantly i kind of liked before
i thought it was a very clever move
but the way he continues playing very
quickly and the way he reacted to queen
five is you know i'm i'm back on team he
just wants to play quickly today
because yeah
i don't think this is great i think uh
it still is very much within the margins
but i i'm pretty sure it is white who
needs to be careful now and yeah well
for me queen f5 was a great response by
nbl and i didn't like b4 personally i i
did want to bring it bring it back there
and say that yeah mvl is very much on
point here because yeah queen of five
requires a very precise assessment of
specifically as alejandra was saying uh
of the end game of the queen takes on c5
exactly and uh yeah he he correctly
understood that there is not much to
fear in that end game and went for it
and yeah i think jan is pushing uh
pushing the envelope a little bit yeah
it's still it still is of course uh an
equal material exactly heavy psn game
which should be a draw but
as we get uh prepared to take our first
break i just wanted to bring to
everybody's attention that cue boutique
absolutely
very nice vinyl show the merchandise yes
show the merchandise here you get the
grand chester or boards everybody yeah
this is a premium premium 20-inch vinyl
roll-up board featuring the official gct
logo
uh it's a burgundy and cream uh
uh
yeah basically indestructible yeah
it will uh outlive all of us
two and a quarter inch square is uh
perfect for on the go and travel and is
available online as is with most things
that we are uh showing you here at
cubitiquestl.com
and as we go on break we asked the
players what they thought of their
opposition in this bucharest tournament
see you on the other side of the break
[Music]
the granchester is always inviting the
best chess players on the planet this
year we have a very fun eclectic mix of
talent who are you most excited to play
and compete against i think the most
interesting will be the players who i'm
going to play against in the candidates
tournament which is my next classical
event after this one
so faruja
we he's taken a break from
uh playing a short break from playing
chess i guess to prepare very seriously
for the candidates so we haven't seen
him over the board in some time he's
also one of the hottest players in the
world for the last you know year or so
so it'll be very interesting to play
against alireza
um against janna
of course as well he's also playing in
the candidates tournament
ravport also playing in the candidates
tournament so there's a lot of guys here
who are
who are playing there which will be very
interesting to see how their form is
coming into that tournament
in general i'm always looking forward to
compete against everyone but of course
we have a newcomer
at least on the full schedule of the
grand chess tour he happens to be
to be french as well and to be playing
really well so of course
so i think
it's going to be an interesting matchup
i'm i'm looking forward to to see away
first i don't want to say any places and
special because for me all players is
very good
[Music]
i think it's an
amazing tournament i'm very happy to be
here
i think all the players are great and i
really if i want to be honest
i would like to i'm looking forward to
play all of them because they are all
very great players
and
i think it would be great
tournament
ah not really i think the whole the
whole lineup in general it's very
challenging
it's very nice for me to to be a part of
the granchester as a regular player i
mean i had the invitation before but
just for one or two events i really look
forward to play
against fabiano
i've lost to him and the american cup so
i want to have my revenge yeah really i
can't name one person maybe shakira i
like to play with him he plays a
very interesting chess and uh yeah also
like you know uh i have a very bad score
against him so
maybe that's why i don't know so i'm
interested to see how fabiano is doing i
think he's working very hard for
candidates also we have alireza ferozia
who i believe is only
18 i think it's turning 19
if i remember correctly in a few months
so it's number three in the world right
now i guess the one who i'm looking
forward to compete is not participating
this year but uh
every player is
is really fine here and uh
despite uh we have uh
mcdon daniel here participating with us
i think it's also will be very very
challenging
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
and here we have shots of the playing
hall there in bucharest with the
very very young fan clearly checking out
uh you know comparing the booklet with
the
the photos do they match peter that's
what i'm gonna say
i mean
do the photos match with the players so
he's very very curious
nice as always
i must say personally i was always
delighted when uh children brought their
program books and asked me to sign them
i know for a lot of players they're
anxious to get back to their hotels and
sometimes they run by the kids but i do
i always appreciate it and that's right
that's a very very heartwarming uh
heartwarming short uh show there in the
area absolutely as we as we return to
the cold reality on
on the boards a tepid round uh i still
think the game of ferugia is the one
that we're going to keep our eyes on but
the game that you have in front of you
alejandro feels well
tepid
tap it but
i think if you had to be one side a few
moves ago we were saying obviously white
right but now it's obviously black and
actually netbo is going into a little
bit of a thing he finally stopped
blitzing out every single one of his
moves and by this point the engine is
saying look dude you could take on e7
and be immediately lost or you could
find the defensive move rook b1 so at
this point it's not like every choice
that nepo makes keeps equality now
there's a couple of surprise things
around the
uh the board this one surprised me a
little bit the move rookie how does favi
put any pressure on shaq's position well
he just sidestepped rook going to f1 and
mahmet has gone into a huge thing
almost uh just about 30 minutes right
now
after the move rook f1 looks like not
the most important move in the position
but it does put some serious pressure on
the clock i assume that some of the
queen maneuvers into the king side are
dangerous f3 knight g4 keeping this
clamp on the kings that are dangerous as
well the engines are saying you can play
between e6 and you will still have to
figure out a couple of riemann universe
in order to fully equalize but it's
still well within your hand really so
play those moves queen e6
b5 bishop e5 and the engine here very
importantly wants to go the move rook e7
and this is probably
probably the hard one to find okay there
are no real threats at the moment and
you want to get your knight on a c7
that's not doing very much
somewhere useful it's also useful to
play the move uh queen f5 and some when
this knight is defended yeah uh so you
have to defend it first right right
knight c8 in order to defend it and then
play the move queen f5 even knight to
five in some locations they're just
thinking rookie seven is important but
you're still going to be okay in this
position so again continuing with queen
f3 i mean i'm dreaming of knight g4 and
i'm gonna go knight ce that's crucial
yeah i get that in knight g4
and now knight f5 in this position 94
also works according to the engine but
knight is like better covers h6 prepares
f6 because remember the knight on e8 is
now covering the square as well as
prevent us pushing the pawn from f7 to
f6 and this bishop is now a little bit
uncomfortable
surprisingly
black according to the engine is already
a little bit better right so
you still have to be careful with white
as well rook f1 however has been a huge
surprise for shaq not known for this 30
minutes thanks but he is deep in the
tank in this one all right we'll keep an
eye on that as we move over to the oh he
might be ready to play yeah
he's been he's been tanking for long
enough yeah
what moving away from the danger zone
what is that
that will help us out peter knight a6
yeah double question well
explain the engine immediately thinks
white is winning
wow
wow winning might be a strong word but
okay very strong advantage what is what
is the movement what is what's the
purpose of the move yes i have no idea
like i'm so this is one of the more
buffing decisions i've seen in in quite
some time especially considering okay
the lines you were showing they required
something else but look this was a
beautiful move
rookie 798 is a is a maneuver you might
not see but but when we realized we're
fighting for the square yeah i was i was
trying to connect it's not that hard for
me the most difficult thing to explain
about knight a6 is that if i saw this
position and you told me it's blocked to
move
you want to play
exactly i i understand you completely
knight a6 peter again yeah but also i
wanted to point out that uh
even if you don't see the the
intricacies of cuny six just how bad is
the end game after queen f5
like how how desperate do you need to be
uh i mean i don't think you're doing
this right like i really don't believe
in
me either i'm just like
rookie six knight ce8 as previously
shown yeah i'm starting i'm starting to
pick black here one question once i get
that i think the point is you take on a
five after the queen of five okay uh oh
sorry bishop is not there yeah you take
on a five knight takes a five you play
some you know either bish p5 or an ig4
first i don't know which one is more
precise white has a little bit of a push
but once again i go rookie six here i go
98 next move just how bad can this be
it's not not at all
if you feel a little braver you can take
with the jeep on it it's not bad at all
and and this is my point like
why
why isn't black seizing the initiative
with the rook coming uh using the file
you can go rook siwan here and it's it's
a bit of a sea wall it's a bit of an
empty gesture but i was calculating the
atlanta i think i mean you kind of are
you just shouldn't allow the rook to be
too okay bishop first okay okay but
but
you're right i mean i would be playing
queen f5 and saying you moved your rook
off of the e file yeah
and this is even without touching on the
you know absurd absurdity
visually of the idea of going 96 here
away from the center we're not really
threatening night before either i really
don't understand what's going on
and let's
we're going to see shaq make a move that
has just absolutely befuddled
everybody on panel knight a6 yeah how
does that move
yeah
and the the the reason i'm harping on
about queen of five being safe is that
uh to my eyes you occasionally play
moves like knight a6 when you really
really dislike everything that is
naturally available to you like you're
right you found an easy repetition
you found the refutation of queen e6 and
then you start looking for outlandish
ideas which might surprise your opponent
exactly but neither queen e6 nor queen
of five are in any way bad
exactly so why would you feel the need
to misplace one of your pieces while
giving white additional time to launch
something on the king side it's just
very very confusing now
you said alejandra that the move knight
a6 visually looks terrible but
not only that the computer says yeah
you're lost i mean this isn't a man
versus machine you can make moves on on
your own here exactly i mean the moves
display themselves right right any any
towards the king side
side but specifically the move bishop b5
should be five sims very strong just to
open up the f6 square for
latent possibilities yes
if i can calculate properly knight
before it just blunders a piece so
before q2 probably just kind of resigns
right right and if or queen a3 i thought
picked up a piece yeah but also this but
also extremely strong and so you're not
playing knight before i'm not really
sure why your knight is there it doesn't
matter exactly uh but what is your
continuation because you have to get rid
of this
yeah and then we just go f4
yeah this is this is where you get mated
because your knight is so nice
like this is sort of yeah this is sort
of the point right oh boy oh boy uh and
of course anything i mean you don't even
i don't even know what you're doing
anymore because
everything uh is
it's all play
on the king side and uh black's king is
defenseless um i think shakira may be uh
you know he is
obviously i mean he's curious
he gave some very very nice interviews
he always keeps a kind of a shiny
disposition and you know he has a very
nice natural sense of humor and he's
been kind of laughing at you know his
blunders yeah his blunders and his miss
evaluations and how his miss evaluations
improve from round to round right but he
also clearly is unhappy being on minus
one after four rounds and i think knight
a6 is a move of a man who
you know wants to start to have things
happen in his game he doesn't want to
defend some end game which he probably
will defend but which will not give him
you know any any winning chances but
yeah if fabi if fabi plays well today
this this gives him a very very big
opening to
uh to to kickstart his tournament
exactly well yesterday fabi did play a
very nice opening he got
an edge as black against mvl something
very very difficult to do at these
levels but then got completely outplayed
by disability yes yeah by mispla
mishandling the game uh what about mvl
what's going on in mvl's game and now
alejandro i feel i've seen this story
before nepal losing a game playing
quickly in the next one but not
accurately and stumbling quite a bit
they've got into this endgame and you
might think well three against three one
against one one against one is this some
kind of draw not quite this pawn on d5
is a lot weaker than the pawn on d6 it's
just so much easier to reach
the rook on d1 is not nearly as active
as the rook is going to be on either c5
or coming down to c2 depending on where
you're going to allow me to do so the
engines are thinking that after the move
h5 in this position black already enjoys
a very significant advantage more than
minus one and it doesn't i mean it's
probably not within winning distance yet
right but you're suffering this as white
you're just suffering the rest of the
game
with white and the trend is very very uh
discouraging here for exactly the active
this beautiful activity of black species
especially on the
the queen vis-a-vis the two queens you
can just see that the screen on b4 is
much more annoying yeah the queen on
each absolutely but also structurally as
uh as alejandra correctly pointed out d5
is just
d5 is actually weak and d6 pretty much
never is right because there is no way
to attack it even the rook endings are
not entirely equal if you imagine the
queen's coming off and black you know
pushing rook on c5 and starting
yeah and starting with king of 16e5
ideas but yeah this is a very important
game in the context of the tournament
because uh mvl with the win probably
will be tied for first because uh you
know
lebron is not losing that position no
he's leslie he probably you know he
might not win it but he's not losing
that position against wesley exactly it
is absolutely risk-free so nobody will
be on plus three so plus two will be a
tie for first so yeah a very very big
big game there for for mvl and a
disappointing game for uh for yan
because yeah when he does that i mean he
clearly is a strong enough player like
his hand is a is a very strong chess
player exactly
but uh he is playing against the best in
the world and mvl clearly is on uh you
know on decent form today making the
right decisions
it feels like at some point it probably
was advisable to stop blitzing and just
realize winning chances are probably
gone and it's time to make a clean draw
exactly which is
g2 g3 maybe within reach right i really
don't think that you're losing this
every time no absolutely not but you are
still you are suffering it's a very
annoying position yeah uh turn our
attention again to the game of uh bogdan
and ali reza after the move queen b6 we
kind of see what uh alireza had in mind
while putting the queen on b6 he played
the move knight h5 which you know you
got to give guy a little credit for you
know he's looking at cheapo potentials
and he's trying to encourage queen takes
b6 so he can enjoy the half open a file
and i really like this move uh very much
uh
knight h2 just putting the kibosh
on this demonstration on the king side
saying but also nothing it it also
brings us very much back to the idea of
going 91 because if if white played 91
instead of queen b3 none of those
shenanigans would be at all possible
because you just you just get the
uh get the knight on g4 in your in your
sights and there it is
it stops all of this come to play uh
dead on its tracks and we have a soft
draw offer in the game right now because
after knight h2 alireza replied after
some thought with knight hf6
and uh bogeyman is i assume still better
but
uh he does have the option of playing
knight f3 and kind of asking the
question do you do you think your
position is and your skill advantage i
think this is what we're talking about
here because i think alireza understands
he is not better at the very goddess not
at all yeah
but we have news from from bucharest so
let's go to the
bucharest studio
and it's funny that you say uh that
peter that you don't think that right
now that has as much of an edge as he
used to have also he doesn't seem to be
feeling as comfortable as uh in the
previous couple of minutes well right
now after this move queen to b3 it does
feel like it's just not his type of
position i really like ali reza's stance
i think ali reza despite the fact that
the engine is saying is plus 0.9 i don't
feel that the players understand that
and i don't feel like the players see
this position as such i'm definitely
sensing a shift in the attitude of these
two players this one is very very
intriguing i have to say i like
both of the players chances
but
in the past couple of moves more ali
reza's chances are seemingly improving
now another game that i was having my
eyes on is the one between levon and
wesley that one wesley yesterday we
remembered that he was actually smiling
uh during the game and we couldn't
understand why he's smiling well it's
happening again
he's smiling from the beginning of the
round and even so right now but does he
have a lot of things to be smiling about
in this position because sure
opposite color bishops potentially very
close to equality but he's on the
suffering side of the equation so let's
see if he's going to continue smiling in
the next few minutes and hours uh
anastasia what did you see in the
playing hall yeah it's nice actually
when you are in a good mood during the
game maybe he just enjoys playing chess
and why not to just smile sometimes you
know it's better than to be in a bad
mood and i think actually nipple is not
in his best mood at the moment when they
saw him at the plane when you he was
doing
those faces you know it seems like he
doesn't really like his position at the
moment and uh probably this is what we
can see on the board also this ending
maybe can be a bit unpleasant for white
it's not something you would like to get
out of the opening and out of the middle
game right but okay what to do i think
today i think he has more chances to
keep the position than maybe yesterday
but i don't know let's see he's not
happy with his position but i think
things are going quite well for linea
dominguez he offered this uh queen
exchange and rich spent so much time
thinking maybe how to avoid this queen
exchange but he's still thinking yes
actually for 20 minutes i don't know 120
to already 57 minutes 23 minutes as of
right now and still pending what do you
think he's going to do is he going to
exchange the queens he's going to try to
avoid it
and if so how do you avoid it yes i was
trying to find at least one good square
for the queen to avoid an exchange and i
couldn't find it actually you know
whatever i was trying to do the computer
was telling me something bad so i
believe he has to go for this exchange
sooner or later maybe by playing queen
takes c7 or knight c3 in the gs3 and
then probably um we can admit that
lanier sold his issues in this game so
92 was a
interesting surprise but probably didn't
work out so well um and now they're
actually getting close on time as well
yeah and that's a huge point when we're
talking about linear because lanier
usually is like 30 40 minutes behind his
opponent so only 10 minutes that's a
victory i count a victory for lanier not
in the actual game but a moral victory
yes for sure guys back to you
yeah thank you both indeed and uh we did
see that move bishop e5
not surprisingly by fabi and bishop e5
really is putting the pressure on black
as you can see there's these dark
squares around black's king it's just
that they're so weak and i think and
we've removed the defender from it yes
we've removed an important defender from
and from the king side and i think it's
really important that when you see the
move knight c4 and the instant we
[Music]
rejoined the rejoinder thank you that's
a beautiful word f2f4 just simply
defending the bishop inviting any kinds
of captures and you can just see that
the moves queen g3 and knight g4 are
terrifying for the second player
you instantly understand that something
has gone severely wrong for shaq
in this case and the move knight ace a6
uh the previous move
uh
i think shaq is is coming to
the realization realization
that uh yeah
something's frying and it might be uh
himself a little bit too fancy yeah
and uh
i'm also impressed by how quickly fabie
played bhb5 it's not a very difficult
move but just sort of the
uh
the temptation to spend more time trying
to figure out why knight a6 happened and
maybe missing something would have been
quite strong but yeah he just you know
he doesn't let it bother him you know
because his opponent made something
extremely weird happen
but it probably isn't good so why
why worry your pretty head about it
exactly just make make a strong move get
up from the board go for a walk and you
can so easily see that queen g3 ideas of
queen eight excuse me queen h4
and mate on h8 as well as queen g3 with
the idea of supporting the knight coming
to the desirable
f6 square it's it
it plays itself and it is
we think it's a winning position at the
moment pretty much yeah yeah very large
advantage uh let's just jump back how
i
i don't know but for me i just hate
white's position here i'm just glad i'm
not the one having to defend this
because there's always this b2
anchor square that something dreadful
might just drop in absolutely it will be
bad news for me and in the meanwhile too
uh simple ideas like queen c5 yeah all
of those things are correct it's all
good so your hope here is that you know
the the material is depleted enough that
somehow
you can just sort of greenly defend
every single threat and and there will
be not enough progress simply
due to how how limited the resources are
because yeah it's a very very annoying
position to to have to defend for the
next i don't know 40 moves well what one
way of blundering the game right away i
don't know if blunder is stronger but
you may be the desirable rook d3 and
then you see this move queen b2 and yeah
i mean i can still go back to roger
right so it's true that you don't you
haven't lost anything uh
yet but you do feel like you're you're
you're going on the back foot uh
but this is exactly what i'm talking
about and in this version i go rogue d1
and i continue like attacking your
pieces and
hoping that it that it somehow preserves
like rook c2 maybe i go queen of three
and then i go rook g3 and maybe i get to
trade a2 for a3
and then my life improves tremendously
any trades of the a pawn would be a
definitely white's by the way h3h4 on
the board not the first move that comes
to my mind well eventually i think you
have to because you have to expect black
to play h5 and i don't think you can
allow h5 h4 i think uh basically the way
the way you definitely lose these types
of positions with white is if black
actually manages to soften something up
on the king's side so you have one more
additional worry to
uh to occupy your calculations so he
wants a stable situation on king's side
so that he can basically kind of remove
the king side from his mind because
nothing is going to happen there right
and generally you want f2 g3h4 to to
achieve that and he's saying that like
it looks threatening on the queen side
but currently there are no
actual problems he needs to face
straight away queen c5 i guess he goes
rogue two alarm rook c2 would be uh
sub-optimal so he goes rogue
he goes queen e4 if allowed after that
having secured the c4 square and we
shuffle
and
i mean we all know who is enjoying the
better of the shuffle sure but it's
still a bit of a shuffle i
all the you know pronounced pessimism
that we are you know is uh espousing
here is
i still feel like you draw a very
significant proportion of these games
with white you just really really hate
everything while you're doing it
it's a
it's a grotty defense that's for sure
and alejandro uh over to you uh what's
caught your attention
not much those things have happened in
about 10 minutes as well we have some
maneuvers in the young game but i'm
wondering what fabi and shaq are going
to play out because bishop e5 is on the
board i'm just
trying to figure out how shock is going
to continue the game in a logical way
um and it's it's really not that easy i
mean he gets pretty much destroyed in so
many different variations for example i
was just trying to put in the move queen
e6 maybe get f6 in when this queen moves
away because this queen is coming to g3
knight g4 queen h4 you guys mentioned
are very strong moves but if i go queen
h queen g3
then for queen h4 f6 which i was hoping
would kind of hold for black if i have
to move my bishop back problem is f3
comes
and with the knight on a6 are you
playing a piece down you're playing a
piece down on the king side right you
have a knight on h2 jumping to f6 and
this knight is nowhere near where it
needs to be this is with no surprise
lost after the move rook f8 takes takes
queen h8 and white starts picking on
material and black's position didn't get
that much better you're still you're
still gonna be under the pressure of a
king hunt so bishop e5 i'm just trying
to figure out what shaq is going to play
here as you guys mentioned knight c4 f4
it looks so visual visually nice for
white because you're going to go queen
g3 knight g4 and you're going to stop
counting pawns it doesn't matter if you
give up the entire queen side at this
point the knight coming to f6 is going
to end the game right so i don't really
know what shaq is playing to keep the
game going because he wants to put up a
fight right right you got a bad position
you want to settle down put down a fight
but where where is it where is the fight
exactly the fight which direction is he
going to take here
yeah
i don't see the fight i mean your piece
down uh on the king's side yeah the
knight on a6 is his terrorist sorry
it's just one of the more mystifying
misplays i've seen from a very very
strong player in a long time because
like everything in everything in your
being must scream that this is not the
move you you can make right
the position isn't safe enough for you
to be you know removing stuff from play
and he will play queen e6 it does
require some calculation from why it is
a logical move i think it probably is
the most tenacious move in like in human
terms right uh here but i mean queen g3
is not a difficult move to make and the
calculations the calculations don't
really seem uh you know all that all
that in human friendly like it just
feels like you uh you just do it and you
just uh you just
go go over there uh somebody who's
getting a smidge of something perhaps is
uh lavon in his uh game with wesley so
when we left it well we left it quite
some time ago and somehow the players
have contrived to get into this bishops
of opposite color position
a little surprise move for me was this
move rook b8 i as as black i'm always
dreaming to get my pawn on a4 so that i
wonder why it hasn't been played yet
exactly uh so okay a little bit but at
this
moment if there had been
draw offers allowed
it wouldn't have surprised me to see a
drop but four is an interesting a way to
try to exploit the fact that the rook is
on b8 and the pawn is still not on a4
because rogue g1 is obviously a bit of
an annoying threat but i very much like
uh wesley's reaction because i think if
you're autopiloting here you can play
something like kinky seven to have king
of seven as a reply to rook gwan then
why it goes into e4 white goes king e3
next and why the joy is i mean it's not
much you still don't win very many right
but it's a nice little advantage for why
clearly white is the one calling the
schottky instead wesley goes uh with a
very concrete bishop d5 from g1 rook g8
saying that
if i don't let you play to e4 at all
your structure is just not better than
mine and your advantage is completely
gone
uh and yeah ruxin rock g8 rook g3 king
e6
uh you started by saying uh perhaps uh
levon has got nibble here i really don't
think so i think now that e4 has been
prevented
pretty much conclusively
i just don't see why this has to be
worse for black at all i can even maybe
go for g6 king of five plans if i wanted
to the king will be quite safe on f5
g6
it was funny because
to my mind i was trying to understand
the um
the plus
of having the rook on g8 versus the pawn
on a4 for example and i thought it might
be
attached to the move rook here rook to
b5 so that on a good day this rook would
uh slide across for example rook to g8
and now if you got your e4 setup right
then i'm going for rook to h5 and king
e3 while i've got check
ideas anyway so i thought that was his
intent when he played rook to be eight
but but i issued g5 he just valued
stopping e4 more than than all of those
ideas sorry uh what did happen after
rook g8 by the way or if i would you
think is sixth as well it is on the
board yeah okay that's what we're
discussing
i think black is completely fine i think
maybe you even are sort of incentivized
to play a2a4 but lev i don't think has
done that he's played something but it's
not uh g1 he's got rook g1 i think we go
g6 here and uh and i really do like the
setup with the g6 and king of five
because i think it's entirely safe on
the f5 there's just nothing in the wide
in the y position that can ever threaten
the king on f5 in any way maybe we can
play rook e3 check with the intention of
meeting king of five with rookie seven
to at least have one active piece but
it looks empty to me it looks like it
should be a very very
holdable position for black i don't
really
even h7 is not really that much like i
can go a5 a4 here i know i wanted to
yeah seven location exactly exactly that
one i do like uh yeah but i i because a2
i would very much like to echo your
sentiments as to uh
i'm slightly mystified by rook hp8 i
don't know what it was trying to achieve
but right there is so much leeway for
black here that i think he's still
entirely untroubled
well for wesley so drawing as black
against one of his key competitors would
be a great success as he is enjoying uh
clear first
at plus two and lavone with the white
pieces trying to
make something happen here after this
move rook g1 i like g6 a lot uh king f7
give some probably also also pretty safe
but
g6 and playing actively with the king on
f5 uh gets my two thumbs up let me again
check in because did we see a repetition
yes we have we haven't not actually not
yet well i mean we saw one right yeah
knight h5 knight h2 on the board knight
aj knight f3 yeah this wife hasn't been
played yet no yeah
clearly is
uh as we were uh talking about when we
went uh uh or
in a different direction end on break
yeah
the equation here has to be whether he
rates his uh
chances of outplaying his young opponent
of from
we have to suspect also he probably has
to suspect from an inferior position
whether he rates basically his skill
edge
as as larger
than uh the advantage he will have to be
giving up if he doesn't repeat here
because i think bogdan is you know quite
clearly uh
content with repeating if knight h5
happens here's uh
both of them actually spent a lot of
time getting here move 14 they're both
down to like 40 45 42 minutes i just
like this idea of 18 and 20 year olds
sitting there saying well my experience
tells me
that with my higher rating i should be
playing for a win what are you expecting
alejandro
uh we'll go back to this game between
richie and lanier because the angels are
starting to give white a little
something something in this position uh
we left it off i believe in after the
move queen takes before check in
bucharest but after queen e7 knight c3
i'm just gonna put these moves on the
board uh bishop c4 came attacking the
spot on f7 and i was looking at the
engine evaluation it really wanted to
either go rook edge fade a little bit
passive or play the move knight c6 with
the idea of coming to e5 defending the
pawn on f7 and attacking the bishop on
c4 saying like you could take on f7 but
at this precise moment i can go rook hf
hf-8 and take on f2 you do have to
calculate some variations uh regarding
this kind of stuff but knight d4 bishop
f5 there's no real danger to the rook so
you're going to be okay there instead
lanier play the move bishop c6
which counter attacks of course the pawn
on g2 you cannot really take on f7 but
let's defend both of them at the same
time let's defend f2 and g2 at the same
time let's play the move f3 and ask you
a simple question how do you defend this
guy right you could play f6 but that's a
very ugly move just shutting down your
bishop on g7 you don't want to play that
nobody likes such moves no no you're not
playing uh f3 f6 you're not playing f5
either it's just as ugly you're not
playing rook hf8 because i'm going to
force you to play f6 right bishop g5 you
don't have another move that's not f6
because how else are you going to deal
with this diagonal right so suddenly
it's becoming
very concretely awkward
for linear to defend this pawn after the
move f3 actually the engine is even
suggesting a very inhuman move bishop d5
just giving up the bishop because they
don't really see how to comfortably
defend this pashki i think maybe uh his
intention was to meet f3 with 95 and he
will come to the realization that if 395
runs into bishop g5
or bishop takes bishop takes d5 and then
bishop g5 and yeah these positions are
very annoying but uh richie played
something else he played ricky won
rather quickly by the way i like the
move f2 f3 it kind of does uh kill your
enthusiasm for the bishop on the long
diagonal with the move f3 but rook h1e1
came very quickly sorry you were
pointing out a variation that you
suspect linear
intention was to meet f3 with knight d5
and yeah how did it go peter what did
you you have a choice here between mr g5
immediately or taking on g5 with the
bishop and then bishop g5 both of which
uh clearly don't equalize for the
question is how bad this is
and i suspect actually pretty bad yeah
it's uh very annoying rokeichi one might
actually now be allowing some of that
because there will be bishop take c3
into mezzos can we play 95 here
95 in this moment after uh the milk
rookie one so i instead of playing f3 i
get my rook on e1 any way of exploiting
this and the difference would be if you
let's say if you go bishop d5 bishop d5
bishop g5 or that i want to play bishop
takes c3 here bishop takes c3 this exact
moment bc and let's say rook d7 or f2
honestly here f6 i think it's also f6
yeah
this might be just trading too yeah even
if it ends up costing me the f6 pawn but
the uh but it forces you to trade and
i will make a draw there i don't dispute
that i think that that is a good point
um
knight d5 can i do something
well i i don't know is knight g5
worrisome a little bit
well even if you even if it did
uh force you to play h6 it's not it's
not that hard right now i could spend a
tempo on that for sure it's not
heartbreaking
nice any hearts being broken and as you
just take a look at the
the classical chess matchup they've only
played five games not much between them
but well i mean uh
a loss for
rapport yeah uh let's just take a quick
look that ali reza is the one with the
least amount of experience between the
two he's only 18 again
you know 20 year old but 97 was played
by laressa not interested in a draw yeah
so you are mentioning while we were
doing our rehearsal for this broadcast
that alareza needs to do something minus
one is not gonna cut it going into round
five and he's agreeing with you he says
knight h5 i don't want to give my
opponent the possibility of a draw of
course the game of chicken there a
little bit you don't know if dak was
actually going to repeat the position
maybe he would have liked another
variation but 97 already on the board
completely changing up the idea of
coming to h5 we hadn't mentioned in many
variations that we'd like this idea of
91 to tether this uh
defense of the knight to g4 so the 97
was impossible alireza taking advantage
of it probably going to c5 soon
that being said is are his opening
troubles over him
not quite the engines still love white
but they do like a kg move here the move
queen c2 moving the queen back preparing
to meet knight c5 with expansions on the
queen side in this kind of positions the
queen on b6 might be in the way it still
likes to move 91 at some point to target
this knight on g4 still loves the space
advantage let me see if avi has played
nope still thinking after the move queen
e6 and in this position you already see
who is the one vying for the advantage
because check it out we had this
position rook d2 rook c1 queen d3 rook
c3 queen e2 and you could go rook c1 and
just finish the game of your mvl but mvl
is not interested in finishing quite yet
more or less like yesterday's game
between wesley and nepo there's one side
that can decide when the game finishes
he can pretty much always make finally
threefold repetition and finish the game
like that but instead he's gone queen b1
rook d1 queen f5 trying to keep up the
pressure making nepo keep finding moves
keep avoiding blunders blundering a2
blundering d5 maybe blundering the king
sometimes with some sort of battery on
the first rank and it's this pressure
that got to network yesterday will it
happen again of course so far he's
defending well but defending for the
rest of the game
yeah defending with the white pieces
isn't anybody's uh joy
but let's open up the conversation to
our audience and look at some tweets
what do you have for us peter uh a tweet
from megan duffy uh great chess players
seem to have amazing memories are gm's
brains wired differently
uh that's uh yeah opening yeah an
interesting conversation right there
speaking for myself speaking for myself
i remember
having dinner
with um
ben larson
and the great dane said to me i asked
him i said come on ben what's the secret
of gm's
what are they very very good at and he
said well two things
i said yes and he said first they need a
great stomach
i said pardon
he says well we travel a lot we have
these really varied diets and you need a
great stomach i go okay what's the
second thing he said a great memory
he said
a lot of his colleagues had great
memories yeah and that is
definitely true but there's also
exceptions like
we keep on
not every day but the the the topic of
the the great rivalry between karpov and
kasparov comes up and
gary famously i mean possibly the quote
is apocryphal but i was told that when
he was a very very young man he said
that uh the moment he will actually need
a telephone book and that's obviously in
the days before mobile's because this is
nobody remembers phone numbers because
your phone remembers them for you right
but when we were growing up you you you
actually needed to uh right
yeah and he said the moment i will
actually need to start writing down
phone numbers i will quit chess
[Laughter]
that stopped you and it caused you to
think
there are also stories of him showing up
to his first ever soviet championship
and being able to quote the most recent
issue of the chess informant from start
to finish with annotations which are
also probably not apocryphal and on the
other side of that same uh divide is
anatoly karpov who uh
for a you know a tremendous chess player
one of the all-time greatest had
honestly a
not an average i think a poor memory
would be a way to describe it for once
again from reports he's he's always had
trouble uh he
definitely compared to some of his like
compared to gary everybody has a point
but
even even compared to some some of his
you know less illustrious uh competitors
didn't really you know make him less of
a player necessarily like he's achieved
quite a bit in his life
but in general yeah i think i think
memory is very much something that is
required
and
maybe even more so these days with the
amount of information
a professional chess player is supposed
to process with the amount of uh games
being played that you're supposed to be
uh keeping keeping abreast well well
let's uh get the national uh champion
coach here to jump in are chess players
wired
differently their brains uh their
memories alejandro i think we wire
ourselves to remember patterns and
recognize a lot of things there are a
lot of chess players that i've noticed
have amazing memories some of them have
photographing memory but i feel it's the
exception like most chess players they
just have a good memory for chess and i
don't feel that they have a particularly
exceptional memory for anything else in
average of course we're talking about
many geniuses that come into our game
and they are good at many other things
but i've seen plenty of 2700 2600 grand
masters some of them with outside of
chess memory being good and some of them
being bad without really affecting their
uh
their chest or their chest specific
memory which sometimes i feel can be
incredible even if they don't remember
even like what day of the week it is
but that's also that's also a very chess
specific thing because during the
tournament that's true like they kind of
all blend together you know how many
days you're away you are from from res
day but whether it's tuesday or friday
you kind of stop
caring
yeah exactly unless it's like a fixed
menu
at the restaurant and you know it's like
pizzas on wednesday or something like
that
it's actually funny that you say about
anatoly karpov because for western
american players especially i mean
anatoly was this guy who just played one
e4 with white and seemed to win every
game
because his
opening play was so good because his
play was
we always kind of thought of him as
having a great memory but i do remember
one very funny moment it was at the
melody amber tournaments in monaco
where
vichy was white and isolated queen pond
anatoly was black the game ended in a
well-fought draw blah blah blah they
came into the
uh analysis room
and you know you just kind of put the
isolated queen pawn with 18 moves on the
board and vishy saying gosh here i just
didn't know how i could continue with
my advantage i didn't know what i should
do
and anatoly said your advantage what are
you talking about it's my advantage
vishy said no no no
i'm white
i'm better i i have the advantage no no
no said anatoly you you you don't have
the advantage i have the advantage
and vishy said look
talia
this is your game
from the soviet championship against
tigran petrossian
you were white and you won this game
this game by playing this and
and karpov was like taser for like the
whole five seconds he says okay in this
position you're a little bit better but
after a few news
i will soon be a little bit better a
little maneuvering and i will have the
advantage it was pretty funny i mean but
uh
i i think gary has an exceptional chess
memory it's just it's phenomenal
he was also he definitely uh
when he was growing up he was just like
he had a
how about you how do you rank your own
memory
are you good compared to your
i think i'm probably sort of uh yeah and
once again it's it's very chess specific
i think i have a good number of a very
decent professional memory i have a good
memory for numbers uh
but i have
on the other on the other side of it i
have absolutely horrible face
recognition memory like i i i've been
embarrassed more than once failing to
recognize people absolutely
shaking your hand
so good to see you again peter
and you're like
who are you yeah
and it also like it's very difficult to
keep your face under control so that it
doesn't show on your face you have no
idea who you're talking to so yeah it's
those are incredibly incredibly
embarrassing spots yeah i have one in
particular it's kind of a longer story
but uh
and that we have five games running but
maybe for some other time where yeah i
i'm still ashamed it's like 25 years old
i'm still ashamed
you don't make a good date
what's your name again
alejandro uh chess memories like you say
the chess patterns and chess players are
very good at remembering chess patterns
do you
uh rate your memory as god awful awful
absolutely awful yeah yeah compared to
some of the my peers uh my child's
memory is really about that who do you
consider like extraordinary
extraordinary yeah um well gary was
absolutely extraordinary you could talk
to him about games that he played
a million years ago and he'd be like i
felt this i was doing this and he'll be
in a car ride just remembering
exactly what he was thinking it's just
unbelievable the way he thought about it
but for me
it's just awful i'll be looking at some
position on the megabase
i think wow this is a very interesting
position oh it's annotated great let's
look at the annotations annotations are
pretty good i'm like oh this guy made
sense let's see who the author was and
it was me
that's not very good
we admitted the annotations were good
high quality
it's very very nice
for me
by the way i mean i've always thought
i'm okay just nothing special but where
i think i am somewhat extraordinary
is where movies are concerned for some
strange reason i can remember entire
scenes of movies and including the
script and what the actor did and what
the actress said
and
that really annoys yvette because
we'll be watching some movie and
i said oh i know this i know this she
says no it's not it's
no we watched it together i would tell
her no we didn't i go yeah and i just
dictate what happens for the next half
hour she's just like throws the remote
down
still marriage i know i know it is
annoying it is annoying by the way f2 f4
smackdown by fabi uh
uh not the move queen g3 but f4 this is
very logical very logical very tempting
too right right following it up with f5
in many positions but does it allow
knight e4 though it doesn't knight e4 is
not not really a move in this position
unfortunately because
it's just killer right the thing is that
it's more about closing the diagonal
right you're closing the diagonal of the
queen to h3 which is why i was
mentioning f5 even without the move
knight d6 that in many variations you're
just going to go f5
yeah and i think this just loses to
something right well this is it probably
yeah
check
very much like that arrow i can see
behind alejandro on the big
demonstration
it says f4 knight b8
you have to bring the stupid knife back
to the game he's on a6 he has to come
back yeah the engine is saying f6 go
back to b8 fight for f6 especially try
to eliminate this bishop that's causing
such hassle but it's not such an easy
move to play because check out what you
have to get yourself into as black it's
pretty scary perhaps you do it because
you don't find anything better f5 you
have to take with the knight queen h3
threatening checkmate there's not a lot
of choices here you can't really play
knight g7 and allow my knight to come to
g4 so you have to go f6 and here i
assume the idea is going to be g4 uh you
can't really move the knight because
you're going to lose
you're going to lose f6 exactly so it
takes on e5 you take here you take here
and it looks scary to play this position
with the knight on b8 rook takes f5 is
playable king h1 rook g1 is also
playable the computer is saying the
rookie king h1 is actually the correct
move
looking at this from far you could just
land the move king h1 think this is not
holdable exactly and give up but what
are you going to do otherwise because f4
f5 is pretty much an unstoppable threat
not to mention that ideas of queen g3
queen h4 queen g3 knight g4 not have not
gone away they just become stronger
black needs to hurry up and bring this
knight but it doesn't solve his problems
but he's done it i've been told that he
did play the game he played my b8 yes so
the idea of knight a6 was to play knight
b
and fight for the d6
well well done yeah yeah the the old
soviet quote of you know we uh we create
difficulties for ourselves to then
successfully solve them exactly exactly
i just wanted to show
as we prepare for a break a very quick
gary kasparov story because i just
thought this was so wonderful uh it was
during the soviet union and the
spartakia these internal competitions
and they were on the bus
going from the hotel to the playing hall
and everybody's shouting about this uh
budvinic pawn sacrifice position
and gary you know shouted at the top of
his voice
that this was this game was played
between these two players at banya luka
and uh
yuri balashov who've been rather sitting
rather quietly
shouted in response
gary is right and it was played in round
nine
[Laughter]
everybody got very quiet because if you
get the players right
and you get uh the the location right
that's great nobody knows what route
it was plated and apparently yuri
belishoff had an insight in the crowd
good memory yeah sounds like somebody
with a good memory yeah we're going to
take a break we'll see you on the other
side as we continue our coverage of
round five of the first inaugural event
of the grand chester stay tuned
[Music]
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear
when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
to our ascension
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we all know st louis is a championship
sports town from the 11 time world
champion cardinals to the stanley cup
champion blues
but i bet you didn't know about all the
championship places there are to get out
and play here like the world chess hall
of fame westport social and topgolf and
now even our own mls team so whatever
sports your team is into you can always
bring out your a game in st louis
oops sorry st lou is always exploring
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to round five of the super
bad chess classic in booker estromania
as you uh see the coverage of the wide
shot of the playing hall with
all five games still very much in
progress and people are thinking about
their decisions and this is the current
standings with uh wesley so
on top there on three points and uh
seemingly very comfortable in his game
today against his compatriot levana
onion
and other other games still very much uh
in progress exactly well let's pick it
up right from the game between our two
tournament leaders as wesley so as you
say enjoys the lead with plus two three
three points out of four he is black
against lavone irony and i would say
that things are really going his way we
had reached this position uh g7 g6 rook
h3 now i think a lot of players would
play h7h5 at this point wesley said
actually
king
as he took this pawn and during our
break
i think we all confused ourselves
because if we were looking at this point
i think everybody said oh well i'll just
play a5 a4 yeah i'm wondering if there
is something tactical here that we are
missing some kind of an idea uh that uh
based on this
perhaps something to do with e4 check
but i don't really quite see how to
follow it up
uh and yeah i would like to have a pawn
on a4 so that it never hangs and bishop
takes a2 becomes more of a threat maybe
in some positions yeah what yazar is
showing is i mean it looks like a
playable line but i can take on f6 and
take on bitsu and you're very happy yeah
for sure
yeah and
so we thought a4 and we just compared
the kings we stopped and said well white
suffering
a different approach and i think this
move might have been
well
maybe number three on my radar of
of choices uh i mean the idea is quite
clear uh wesley feels that the rook on
e7 is a little bit too active so he
wants to be able to to chase it and uh
trade it off perhaps uh and levon
understanding that he says i will choose
the square and we should it will get
traded because after hang on a second
you can play rook takes g6 after rook g8
correct maybe this was also the reply to
a4 then
things are coming together in my
a4 we still go g7 well then i already
have
a rookie we actually yeah we're much
better equipped for it better
here actually compared to the other one
exactly exactly it's a bit mystifying
right right so he did play rook
h8
rook oops excuse me check rook h8 rook
g7 so is he supposed to play rook h6 now
i suppose so i mean this guy is
hanging this guy is hanging i mean the
honestly even if you play let's say rook
hg8 here rook takes g6 rook takes g7
rook to hg7 bishop takes a2 you're
probably not losing very many of these
positions if we are if we're honest with
ourselves
but why do this exactly
yeah the unclear part is why why are we
suddenly back on you know discussing
whether black can be slightly worse
h6 seems comfortable enough but then why
have we played with hh exactly some
questions here that remain unanswered
but
alejandro what has caught your attention
not much there hasn't been a lot of
moves since we left for break
still after the move knight b8 f4 was
happen we do see that mvl and nepo seem
to be repeating they play pretty quickly
and it feels that maxim got about as
much as you can from the position but
there's not that much there's a queen g1
check that you could throw in the king
would have to go let's say all the way
to f3 but because you're stuck on h1 and
we do not have a repetition we do have
the repetition we
uh with a draw
probably nepo not thrilled about how the
draw occurred but i think by the end of
it
yeah pretty happy it's fine yeah
um
and we know the engine was giving uh
maximum a very large advantage at some
point considering considering the
symmetrical nature of the position and
the the lack of you know obvious glaring
witnesses but it was one of those where
i think against accurate defense uh
you never know exactly how you know how
much better you are and you feel like
i've tried something it didn't pay off i
don't think mbl will be brokenhearted
about not winning that position
how about the game of ritchie versus
lanier see this pawn on g5 and usually i
get myself excited when i see these
pawns on g5 which kind of dominate it
does get traded all fights does it oh
that would be unfortunate uh so you're
looking at something like rook takes
king takes and you're thinking
why are you thinking with the key i
think you're supposed to go down here oh
you wanna you wanna have because i want
to exploit because you the open file i
thought it was sensible to take with the
rook to disincentivize h6 because after
gh rook g8 will be annoying but that's
true you might actually be correct
because i actually wanted to play h6
anyway
probably
i can take no i
don't want to improve your bishop until
it's required i want to go h6 gh and
then take on b5 play six and recapture
an a6 ah fancy play syndrome
just take on h6
what just take back on h6 and that's it
it's completely fine yeah and you go
rook d a check you want to allow rook to
hack that's fine what
go no no no not here not here uh before
you take on
here
you go here oh you mean just to allow
this wow
because you also have issues yeah rook
h1 is a threat and we are going to unpin
ourselves quite comfortably with taking
on b56 and king c7 in the future so yeah
i can definitely relate yeah that's a
good point
that is a good point wow i hate self
pins like this um
okay so pardon me i was going to
recapture with the king yeah i would
still like to try to play h6 regardless
okay good because if this works out
tactically i think my my problems are
instantly gone so
so rook
down to the seventh
i wanted to go hg and start suggesting
that rook h1 is a very annoying threat
it truly is yeah
i've got issues on the because obviously
trading g5 for f7 i'm not that happy but
f7 i think i can go rook h1 rook f8 my
t8 and you lose material exactly it
wasn't the plan at all
so it seems like this is holding it
seems like yeah
the position is just a little bit too
symmetrical rich it it seemed like
richie was getting a a little bit of
something something but
currently uh
it looks to me like linear should with
with a couple of accurate moves should
be very close to being home and dry and
how were the youths uh playing when we
left it we had seen the move
knight d7 eschewing
a potential repetition that we saw with
knight h2 and guess what
yeah though is a logical motion scooter
recommended move queen c2 not easy to
play after you've just played queen b3
though well you know knight c5 is coming
you know you really don't want to be
taking on b6 so you preempt it by
playing queen c2 and then you have a
wider choice after knight c5 you can
play rugby before as he has done you
could play rook b1 and perhaps hint at
b2 before but black generally just plays
a5 themselves so rugby one feels like a
bit of an empty gesture
and let's go to bucharest as christian
is with mvl
thank you yasser uh maxine first of all
uh quite an easy draw for you with the
black pieces also it felt like you were
putting the pressure on your opponent
tell us a bit about first of all the
opening phase because it was quite
intriguing with this early bishop b5 did
you expect that at all from your
opponent no i really didn't expect i
mean i expected bishop d5 check to be
possible but some normal move than move
three
um
but yeah yeah so i wasn't sure about
bishop decision or 97 so what are the
differences
compared to the earlier bishop to b5
that moved three that you mentioned well
it turns out there's no difference
because after bishop d7 and c4 it comes
back to line i analyzed
uh
which is why i took this decision to
play bishop december because yeah i
couldn't see any other moves that would
make sense on c4
uh like i just spent some minutes
calculating this but yeah 94 and the
phone immediately there's no knight e6
because i just probably the bishop is
also made i'm pretty right the bishop g5
yeah so that's the problem he played c4
he played c4 and then and you were back
within your book at this point yeah and
i'm not completely sure whether i played
the most accurate moves
but
basically yeah when i found queen five
i thought it's very safe so
the main idea is it looks dangerous of
course these two pawns but here i just
go a5 now
what i wanted i don't know if it's the
most clever thing but
i know b4 seems to be working yeah and
then v3 b2 and they grab one of the two
pawns you use this as a decoy yeah you
decoy with one of the roots and then you
pick up the other pawn so jan played
quinitu and well i was surprised because
and he was missing everything of course
you don't want to
take on f5 but at the same time
this allows you to take the issue yeah
and yeah i thought he should play for
and indeed i mean after books you want
suddenly
yeah and sure might
yeah
i mean i
i don't know i'm just
i just knew i'm better but i couldn't
find any constructive plan
maybe here i am
played careless maybe i should go for
h5h4 but
what was the general uh psychology going
between youtube guys during the game did
you feel like his hands at this point at
all of course ian was uncomfortable
because well i mean you don't
normally end up in such
positions but
at the same time i don't know why i
i just started
you know blitzing out moves like a 43
which
of course some moves that makes sense
but maybe i'm not the most accurate and
here yeah
i could feel that
things were not the advantage was
sleeping yeah because it looks very nice
and
yeah my general thought was a i will
look at once i get to this kind of sort
of position i will look for my chances
but then it turns out yeah so what was
the one plan that you had in mind at
this point rook c1 would be one would be
two basically
the idea
there are plenty of ideas so i can
exchange works
i can exchange queens or i can try to
create an attack the problem is
exchanging queens would be the best but
you need to have
this hook on c3 already as an old d3 or
even kfc so with the rook on c3 you have
enough time to bring the king
king to e5 and i think it's can be very
dangerous for for young absolutely so
so yeah this was my main hope but turns
out
i cannot really do that
here i want
maybe to
to exchange books but i cannot really do
and do that in a in a good way so
i don't know so you thought that if you
exchanged the right yeah here like for
instance c2 looks normal but yeah
probably no no no no no no no no no no
no
no
yes and no b6 and you're just just in
time
because king f6 you take
and here's the thing now you managed to
keep your pawn and with this system yeah
yeah he came to v6 and here maybe
maybe king f8 yeah
yeah maybe i should go king of f8
shouldn't be enough because now he gets
to interrupt
we do have another result yeah that is
the game between levon and wesley which
finished in a draw
getting back to your game
yeah so yeah if i just wait queen to d1
and it's fine so probably i should have
been a little bit more
you know accurate and also
more sensible
to uh you know the details of the
position because
to me um i mean it happens to me that i
think there's no
no big difference that i can play
whatever when
but then the advantage slips away and
that's what happens you knew that you
have an advantage at this point but how
much of an advantage yeah
i knew i had serious pressure but i
didn't think it should be enough winning
yeah
so
uh so that was the
issue but of course i should have
managed to
to put in more pressure and yeah here
like of course like here for instance
here's
uh yeah no here you cannot actually take
any one way
oh oh this is actually
losing for white it seems like
yeah you just simply don't have a way to
to put your queen on on the right square
seems like i was not careful so if you
go all the way to here
yeah here could be
b4 followed by queen to b2 and then you
cannot keep control over okay so but
yeah okay oh okay that's that's bad
that's really bad
actually
um
yeah i
was just sat on the drive didn't even
consider okay one
yeah it's it's it's a difficult move
because you feel like once the rooks are
off the board then white will be able to
defend everything no i mean i told you
originally that one of the plans was to
exchange works
and so what i didn't realize probably
is that
okay if white has the king on g2 g2 then
it goes queen c4 and with the queen
nancy if it's an immediate draw but here
it doesn't have this setup conjugation
if you go king g2 now queen to e2 just
wins yeah because queen to a1 falls for
queen to e4 right yeah or going to be
too evil
yeah
okay yeah that's bad um because
of course i mean apparently after rookie
one it's still not winning but uh
it's definitely serious pressure yeah
serious pressure still ah
bad means but still a very decent result
with the black pieces now you will get
arrested what are you going to do during
the rest day
uh what am i going to do tonight first
first of all i know what we're gonna do
tonight we're gonna have some nice
dinner and then
tomorrow i'll be you know
checking um
what could happen in the next four four
games you know in terms of openings and
all in all relax as much as i can
perfect thank you very much maxine for
joining us and we'll see you
after tomorrow yeah thank you christian
thank you
guys thank you christian thank you mvl
and uh we have this draw between our two
top
leaders i want to say and these are
other people replaying the drama they
they are they understand how you make a
joy in this version b7 and then c5 very
very professional not king takes a four
first he goes c5 and then he takes off
that's that's the way that's the way to
go about things very very uh admirable
understanding of the
the intricacies of this position right
um okay uh with these results our
current standings with three games
remaining
yeah uh station l at the top remains uh
unchanged uh wesley is leading on plus
two three and a half out of five we won
also drew today maxime also drew today
against jan so the only player who could
potentially uh challenge wesley uh
challenge wesley at the top there is uh
bogdan dayak who is still playing his
game against
fallujah which is definitely our sort of
big hope for for a sharp fight uh fight
b is much better but fabian is much
better in a slightly one-sided affair
whereas the
the ideology game potentially could be a
huge big mess but i was also not moving
which which has been a little bit
concerned because he's been thinking
here for a while for 30 minutes on this
move after f4 and i bet he's spent 30
minutes here
and if you don't play f5
why did you play before and
because remember what he did yesterday
we were harping about him going either
94 or before the 94. yeah and then he
completely found a third solution out of
nowhere that ended up losing him the
game
so
where is his mind focused in right now
if he's only looking at f5 at some point
he'll play it but
way before the 30 minute mark because
what is the second candidate move in
this position what else is catching his
attention here
it's not clear i mean if you were going
to play queen g3 you would have done it
in the previous move moved before no
question about it i just wanted to say
that for mvl i think
he just came and he's speaking about his
game and he more or less is very pleased
with himself he got to the moment where
the engine's saying hey dude play rookie
one and then he's like he got tasered a
little bit and he goes oh my god it's a
horrible feeling because i just let a
big advantage slip yeah he
clearly as he said himself and that's
what all also what we were discussing
here in the studio that
you absolutely know having this vision
with black that you're better but you
don't know how much and you don't know
whether you know there's anything
significant or precise defense will hold
it quite comfortably and at some point i
think he just kind of gave up on the
idea of having the advantage
yeah he felt that young jan is defending
accurately enough so it's probably equal
when there's the counter punch of your
g8 which makes you want to grab the draw
quickly but after rookie one it would
have been actually quite annoying for
white too quickly to continue the
evaluation isn't isn't bottoming out i'm
pretty sure you can still you can still
put up a fight perhaps you don't even
lose but
uh
yeah
for young who probably also at that
point thought although all the problems
i've saw have been solved it would have
been a bit of a call a bit of a cold
shower and uh
yeah a bit of a missed opportunity there
by by emblem and again we see uh
wesley so when he has pole position he's
a very good uh
uh
player he drew drew very comfortably
against one of his near rivals uh with
the black pieces and again we have the
game uh between the two young youngsters
rook a1 to e1 and i was sitting here
thinking you know like if i'm black i've
got these pieces kind of sitting on the
back rank uh
f7 f5 is a move i want to play
absolutely but is it a move that
i'm prepared if i'm undeveloped
am i taking too many risks peter
i i mean you are definitely taking
strategic risks doing it but this might
be the last comfortable moment to do it
because i have a feeling rook e1
is i mean it looks slightly artificial
but i have a feeling if you make some
kind of a waiting move white could
actually consider playing hp2 g1 and
pushing for a 45 themselves
and uh
with the bishop on d1 f5 v5 becomes
completely unattractive exactly like
this
yeah this is unplayable right so if you
want to play a five you probably want to
be doing it when the bishop is still
only two and f5 also creates very
immediate tactical threats after ac4
threatens the bishop on f4 and the
bishop cannot really uh i mean bishop g5
maybe is a good reply though which is
something i well i was hoping for bishop
five though right yeah exactly i was
hoping that this bishop was going to uh
tuck out uh on the fi square in case of
knight takes e4 yeah so what is the
reply after f5 maybe you have to take on
f5 and play queen g2 but then you know
some of our pieces which have been
completely dormant
yes are finally looking at squares
yeah and uh as our producers remind us
here uh it might be the last few moments
of that being true but so far we're uh
17 moves in and also two hours into the
game with white having 30 minutes on the
clock and we still have all 32 pieces
along the board not a single trade
and let's jump back to bucharest as
christian is with wesley
thank you uh yasser wesley first of all
quite an easy comfortable uh draw for
you would you assess it that way or did
you feel any sort of pressure no i think
uh i was
worth for uh one or two points in the
game
but i think
uh lev one didn't push it the third it's
good like i think f4 was inaccurate
because now it's very long well first
critical moments first of all in the
opening i was expecting e4 yeah because
that one's very good that's like e4 e5
stuff so obviously i prepared a lot but
he certainly prepared c4 as well he
played a lot at the american cup
yeah but i just assumed that he would
play e4 like he always seemed to want to
play e4 against me for e5 and if youtube
cancel but like here also when he played
c4 i was very confused like i prepared
something against e4 but then i realized
whatever i play he's gonna play jittery
next move so
if i go here then i have some lines
prepared against the night moves but
i realized during the game that he will
just play g3 no matter what i do
and also here
like he doesn't move the knight so he
plays g3 and it's very flexible because
he doesn't have to play knight c3
in many lines so here i was going to
play the symmetrical english and i'm
fine after knight after but then i
realized that levon plays this
d3 this silly setup with queen d2 and f4
which is not very good but i just
assumed that levon prepared something
tricky here i mean i played myself with
white but
it's not a very good line but it's very
tricky so absolutely and you are
concerned about his preparation and
maybe combative spirit at this point you
want it more of a quiet game yeah i mean
obviously he has to play for winnie with
the white pieces
of his half point behind but
yeah and i just want to get a position
which i have looked at recently
and this is
not one
so then like here i thought they would
play knight c3
but then after knight s3
obviously the main line is like knight
553 and now black can play knight c7 or
g6
but uh it seems lebron was trying to get
us into new new positions to a new
position more of a tame approach by him
just keep a slight advantage
were you concerned at any point that he
was building up the pressure um
first of all i think i thought that was
the big moment where you felt you're
under some some tension first of all i
thought this end game is pretty equal
but i haven't looked at it for months
but i just remembered that
some position like this g6 i think
boris girlfriend has some memorable
games here
and then bishop d7 and i think if white
gets
okay one killing one d1 yeah that's a
boy fan game but i remember black
supposed to equalize somewhere but i
couldn't
remember exactly but i was very
surprised when he took
i mean
he played it quite fast yeah so
obviously he has he has prepared he has
some knowledge here yeah he has prepared
some variations i mean black
can
it's impossible to be black and be worse
because of the bishop there so i was
quite happy with what happened in the
opening but i mean it wasn't wasn't so
easy like yeah i remember i looked at
some h5 stuff but uh
yeah like h5 to control the light
squares and the idea i think is after
king e1 h4 g4
black and yep
looking during game of thrones very good
so i guess the idea is e4
oh try to simplify the position we
exchange some pawns yeah so actually
this line is probably the easiest way to
equalize because if you turn the e
points then and you can probably cover
on the opened e file with one of the
bishops so you should be safe enough yes
i think h5 maybe
black quite enough to move the knight
and i guess bishop e6 and then
i don't know some f5 h4 or something
like that because h4 you don't want to
allow g4 right yeah h i guess h4 g4
means playable maybe y flight is better
but maybe f5 min and then h1r something
like shooting some pawns right computer
lines but what i played is the human way
like here
in f2 i mean i was slightly worse like i
couldn't figure out a4 bishop or bishop
e7 is also playable
but i think that one said what i played
is okay and you guys entered this uh
opposite color bishop and game
but now you we're on the defensive
side right yeah yes really we're on the
offensive side today on the uh defensive
side yeah at least i'm not done
seems like you're attracting the
opposite color bishops in this
tournament this is the third game uh
with this imbalance yeah with i mean i
was okay with an endgame but obviously
i'm slightly worse maybe i should have
played a4 rook p1
d7 knight beat i mean obviously this
engine is not very strong
don't worry too much about that energy
yeah i think knight is very strong
because if he played here bishop e7 and
get rook v8 and with the bishop player
it's hard to believe it would be worse
so knight d2 is strong because he's
threatening c4
so i took so
and here i think f4 is a mistake but
maybe lebron told me his
advantage is not that big i thought he
could play e4
it looks quite less than four black
like a4 f4 i mean i wouldn't mind
playing this with white because the
bishop on feature is very solid got it
so now after the exchange yeah and you
have a good way to attack on the g file
as well right here of g1
yeah i think f4 he played f4 too quickly
i was much more worried what was the
difference um
from the variation that you showed us to
the the game i get that move and now
you're controlling e4 yeah now prevent
him from playing e4 yeah i mean i think
if you played e4
black position slightly worse from bit
suffering i mean a computer gives a bit
less space
right
yeah also the difference of the dark
squared bishops
the problem like b5 i thought
boom white can also go something like
this
yeah the main problem is that uh
the presence of the eight points
prevents my bishop from getting out both
d5 and outposts on d5 very nice very
very happy when i thought f4 and once
you uh established that beautiful uh
bishop on d5 you got this point
you sacrificed the pawn momentarily yeah
and i saw you i came into the playing
hole and you played this move a rook to
h8 how were you feeling uh at this point
i i saw the clocks and i was getting a
bit worried 53 minutes for uh him 27 for
you worry thank you thanks for being
very in front of me
no i think i spent a lot of time the
opening but when he played f4 my play
was very easy so quite quick i wasn't
worried at all i think i'm not sure if
he missed something like f5 bishop e4 or
something like that
but uh in any case here
black's just totally fine with king
comes to f5 like there's more than one
rook a7 or king f7 probably also okay
uh hero h h5 is also okay
and here both king and five working at
seven
i mean i thought i wouldn't be worried
getting checkmated on f5
so yeah
g5 or something like that yeah
you're always escaping yeah yeah the
funny part is actually if you take like
you get checkmated
with e3 yes
but i would be worried about
unfortunately h3 rookie 8 but yeah i
thought this lineup was like
that's a funny one yeah that's a
self-made
you're going into the rest day at least
as of right now as the leader of the
event what are you going to do during
the wrestling
uh well rest day supposed to rest
try to get back to my flow i mean i
think tomorrow
grandchester is holding a
fundraiser for
the victims of green so it's very nice
i'm going i mean it's uh
terrible that this month this war has
been going on for a couple months now
and also we're so close to it here like
in the u.s you probably can't
barely feel it in the war but here for
eastern europeans it's very dangerous so
uh i also saw a lot of
my friends russians just friends
who left
russia at least of the moment so
it's very sad for them i mean i'm very
happy that we set up the grand chester
and stuff
and as my mother always says all i have
to worry about is losing a chess game
meanwhile for millions of people they
have to leave their homes
wesley always very thoughtful thank you
very much and we're looking forward to
see you after tomorrow yeah thank you
guys back to you thank you christian
thank you wesley enjoy your rest day
plus two feels like a good day's work uh
let's turn our attention to uh the game
of alibia because that's really an
intriguing
moment uh and i think you were right
peter when you said if you're going to
play f5 it's one of those now or never
moments and ali ariza played f5 but then
he followed that with a rather
surprising move i thought bishop i think
it's just
he's playing very very concretely yeah
because the bishop on four is hanging
obviously you don't really want to be
giving up the pawn on h6 because i think
the most natural move in the position
otherwise would be bishop g3
uh because it's the most solid it over
protects the pawn on f2 which actually
is relevant as i will attempt to show in
the moment yes uh but
you know poland h6 is your pride and joy
and you don't really want to give it up
for nothing here you put a lot of energy
in getting it there right and you just
lost it for a while and uh yeah it's a
it's a kind of a tricky one because
quinte2 seems logical and uh actually
what i was going to say is completely
pointless because i was going to point
out the variation bishop take c3 be take
394 but after coming to two no no or
pardon me excuse me yeah but but
obviously quinjito bishop take c3 white
takes with the queen not with the pawn
using the pawn h6 to uh not have to
worry about uh not have to worry about
rook takes f4 right
but queen takes c3 is which is something
which is something i originally missed
right so 22 does look logical uh and
then you have to you have to wonder why
it was so beneficial for black to take
with the rook instead of the bishop
maybe he just wants to play bishop d7 or
kf8
and it makes sense increase the pressure
along the
uh right that's right by the way i
remember i was in bonn germany during a
match between vladimir kramnik and deep
fritz
and vladimir made a move got up from the
board and was like just gonna go get a
coffee was enjoying the move and it was
maiden one yeah it was played on the
board and it was sort of like oh
yeah
it's a famous how many of these have you
seen live
this
apartments
that was it made in one on the board
that that that that that was a cold
shower alejandro have you experienced
something like that it was like made in
one i blundered made in one one you did
you did
i i've it's since i was a kid i don't
think so i was about 12-ish i was a
reasonably decent player by that point i
didn't give a grand master made in one
but i couldn't understand that one
because if you didn't find the made in
one this sounds weird but the second
best option
also looked tempting but it was a
perpetual
made in one or perpetual bachelor yeah
and i also played in a tournament very
very strong grand master blunder made in
one but me personally not since that one
time during the uh i think the very very
last soviet under 18 right i i just uh
i thought i was completely winning yeah
and uh it turns out i wasn't who knew i
i do remember from lanares
there was a game where nigel short
famously moved his king up the board and
it's not against jan timmon but he's
against alexander big al believsky
and uh well
nigel was better and he moved his king
up the board and right into mayton one
actually had this happen to him twice
yeah but not all i think always on the
on the winnings
on the winning side of it yeah because
that the game i was referring to i think
is rublevsky bielawski from the
novosibirsk round robin in 95 where
werblevsky just blundered something like
queen f6 a1 made mate with the kingdom
or couldn't be two i think with the
queen on b1 and the pawn on a3 which is
a really weird made to blunt one
actually
but yeah and and that that short
billowski game is also quite famous you
know exactly uh let's pick up the action
uh well first of all you got uh fabi uh
what is fabi doing fabi went into a
think and came up with this idea after
the move f4 knight b8 he played the move
queen a3 we're wondering what else can
he be thinking about we thought the move
f5 came as an automatic with the idea of
queen h3 later
but this seemed to be this kg idea now
after 94 he wasn't interested in the
yasser sarah one school of chess queen
takes a7 queen takes b7 it is playable
just to give you some sample lines queen
takes a7 uh f6 is playable you would
have to save the bishop with f5 for
bishop f4 you cannot take on b8 because
knight g3 you start having problems with
the queen coming to e3 the rook hanging
and this king surprisingly weak now that
the piece has left its side but if i
wasn't interested in any of that it was
playable according to the engine uh
instead after 98 queen a394
here he played the move f5 so it's like
he was waiting for the knight to come to
e4 and then after pawn takes he's played
the move queen h3 the difference the
knight is not on d6 so f5 is handing
hanging immediately play continued with
the only moves for black f6 rook takes
f5 and knight e7 these moves are
absolutely forced we already knew that
if you take the bishop in this position
then queen g4 check followed by rook h5
we'll just finish the game as there's
made threats on um the h file so 97 was
played and the move bishop f4 after that
and this is currently the position we
have on the board eight minutes for five
not a lot of time 32 for shock still it
looks like a very dangerous position for
the black side you do have a pretty bare
king with the knight coming to g4 and a
lot of pieces trying to reach it but the
position is not hopeless there is a
strong knight on e4 there will be a
couple of counter chances if white is
not careful so for the time the engines
are saying black is in a dangerous
situation is still advantage
white
but black is the one that has to find a
couple of moves but
it's not the same type of advantage we
were talking about earlier where it was
just kind of crashing through and there
was a night all the way on a6 they
couldn't come back and defend the king
the king has been given this time for
the knight to return to its defense with
knight a6 to b8 to d7 and now it's at
least participating on this side of the
board so a completely different scenario
in which white doesn't have the tempe
that he had on the previous variations
we were looking at to just dismantle the
defenses here black can take his time
play move like rookie seven even king f7
is being suggested so the knight g4 can
be met with queen takes f5 of course
knight g4 queen takes f5 knight h6 jack
would pick up the queen right now so
king afraid a prophylactic move against
knight g4 or rookie 7 which looks very
natural to me just bring the rook to the
seventh rank you never know when rook h7
or rook 27 will be a good move of course
perhaps not immediately because well
actually in rook g5 you have knight
takes g5 so yeah rookie seven and bring
the rook on the seventh rank
wow i mean not only that it uh
i i feel like bobby spoiled at his
advantage he spoiled his clock
was like too
minutes on his clock suddenly he only
has eight minutes and he's letting his
opponent back in the game it's very
visible that his advantage has
dissipated because black is a lot better
equipped to dealing with the threats on
the king's side with the point the fact
that the pawn f6 got to f6 and survived
right it closes down much of the of the
attack that white hat on the king side
you still you still have some some
chances here of course knight g4 as uh
alejandra pointed out is still coming
despite the fact that the rook on f5
will optically be hanging but knight h6
check solves that issue very
conclusively but rookie 7 rook g7 the
king might start running towards the
queen side yeah and we also have traded
off some of our attackers by this point
so yeah rookie seven rook h7 yeah
to cover the king feels like shaq is
back in the game let's just turn our
attention uh briefly uh to uh richie's
game for yeah this is where this is
where i did my you know off camera uh i
did my
startled dear expression there because
richard just went b2b4 and i thought um
yeah i mean why not but also why
both of those
he wants to get i can actually explain
this after after the initial shock has
faded away yeah you want to gain space
on the queen side and the the move h7h5
that linear played just then uh is a bit
of a draw for because if you go gh
ambassador rook takes h6 uh the
structure is so anodyne that like
nothing will ever two three three yeah
so and and richie is another another of
those players who does not really like
finishing chess games when there is
still a chess game to be had so he
maintains uh maintains the tension and
he wants to gain some space on the queen
side but if he starts with c4 which
maybe optically looks a little bit more
natural that allows c5 right and black
will also gain some space and black
would very much like the queen side to
look like a7 b6 c5 with their
light square bishop knight coming to g6
king coming to c7 uh that's a very very
harmonious way to to continue here and
by playing b4 richie is saying i would
like to play c45 myself i would like to
challenge the eventual knight on d6
because black would very much like to
establish an iphone d6 here and i want
to do it in such a way that disallows c7
c5 or at least makes it much harder to
uh achieve
linear played rook eight and move on
which is great i mean you're taking an
open file i mean
doesn't really yeah he wants to go
rookie three g3 maybe so if i play c4
here
c4
also there's maybe an idea of playing c5
b take c5 rook e5 maybe that's what he
wants
that's intriguing maybe that's what he
wants that's a nice way of mixing things
up and
creating uh
mutual chances
and as we uh
try to uh decipher these games uh we
want to always invite our audience and
ask the panel we have a tweet absolutely
how do i pronounce bush garage i would i
would say yeah uh provided that magnus
plays and with maximum motivation who
among the candidates do you think has
the best chance of beating him in the
upcoming world championship match in
which segment classical rapid tiebreaker
later later would being
armageddon i guess yeah
yeah let's take a look at who all is in
the candidates and of these eight
players who do you reckon would give
magnus a run for his money
i
if i had to choose one name i'd kind of
i think
ali reza probably is the sort of the
least known quality even though banks
have been doing fine against him
completely fine but i would be choosing
out of the out of the three names there
i think the three names are fabi alireza
ending lyran
and uh those would be the that was like
bucket bucket a for me to choose from no
disrespect to the others like jan has
been playing well and he i mean first
half of the match in dubai was extremely
even like it will go down in history as
a complete blowout because of the finals
but like first five and a half games
you you if you had to give advantage to
somebody i would say jan had the better
of the first five and a half it's sort
of irrelevant because the mash didn't do
the plus right
but it was a very close match until i i
completely agree and even the marathon
game that he lost i mean that if he
could have taken the bomb it was close
to winning at one point
alejandro jump into the uh question that
the the viewer posed who do you think
could give magnus the best run for his
money i think mannix himself said it
right he wants to see the new generation
come up so alireza's definitely in the
picture but he said that who are the
best rivals against him right now and it
comes to favi and dingleran they have
been the ones that pose the most
problems the people that he thinks are
the strongest players and if you see
that field of candidates there's a lot
of creative creativity there's a lot of
resources a lot of talent but does it
get up to the resources and talent and
the dedication especially in a match
format that fabian and dinglaran have
put in and i just don't think so
uh well what do you think about dude
richard and ali
i think i think they're very dangerous i
think they're great they're very
dangerous they're exciting players uh
especially when it comes to duda and
richie
but
pit them in a match format against
magnus especially richie man that's
trouble you can't you can't play e4 592
and and hope to win a world championship
it's just this is not going to happen no
yeah i mean uh young shirts of did
actually knock out magnus
from from the world cup that he
eventually won and
in 2021 so and broke a streak yeah i
mean
clearly everyone who is in the
candidates deserves deserves to be in
the candidates they're all very strong
players but yeah you do have to start by
naming those three because those three
kind of caused magnus problems over the
years dingler and i think comes you know
about as close as possible from from the
current players of being an awkward
opponent for magnus magnus lost tie
breaks humongous lost classical games
grand chess tour yeah
ding appears to be sort of unafraid of
magnus which is a very important
starting point
instead of feeling comfortable playing
magnus in any format
but
yeah
pretty much everyone in that field
will feel they they have they have a
shout but i would start with those three
and uh
also you do have to sort of mention the
uh the
the question that is hanging in the air
of whether
magnus actually plays uh has the
motivation to play as he himself
i i don't think this is a marketing ploy
no i don't know at all i think he is
very very sincere in perhaps not
enjoying the format of the current world
championship as much as
uh as uh some other people and you know
he's played enough of them to feel that
you know he doesn't have to prove
himself very much anymore he doesn't
really like the grueling classical
matches like the 12 14 game matches that
he's been playing exactly and uh
it's it's a bit it's a bit weird because
we for a while now we haven't had the
situation where the world champion says
yes i'm the world champion but i'm not
that interested in defending my title i
will you know
we will burn that bridge when we come to
it right uh but it's it's a topic and uh
we we kind of know he will play alireza
because he pretty much said so right uh
for otherwise yeah for the rest it would
be extremely like for it's very
difficult for me to see him updating
like when when it actually when when
christian
the shove you know two million euros
i don't think he struggles for cash
i think i think it's just the idea of
giving up something that he fought so
hard for he
will be problematic even for him but who
knows something i hadn't thought about
but the candidates traditionally has
been a tournament in which one person
wins and the other everybody else loses
and would this candidates be a little
bit different now that magnus has said
that and you think well if you get
second
right there is a chance yeah
as well that might be challenger as well
right right yes it might change the
dynamics a little bit
uh
very very much so i would just like to
echo one other thing is that
um i've known um magnus since he was a
very young boy we played on the
hilversum chess club together and
his father hendrick i i've watched him
develop and flowers a young man and
grandmaster and world champion
and one of the things that has always
caught me about magnus is he is so
upfront with you he will tell you
truthfully
with complete
this is what i am trying to do yeah
absolutely and uh when he says
i could abdicate
yeah i don't dismiss this i mean i
really don't
he is one of the more interesting
interviews in in in world chess right
now actually i think he gives very very
forthright very honest interviews which
are very
very good to
to listen to because it gives you a
unique unique you know overview into the
mind of somebody who's been
dominant in the world chess for exactly
i'd like to turn our attention uh and go
back thank you very much uh for the
question by the way as as that was very
very much a topical discussion as to who
uh would be uh the best challenge for
magnus uh we see our rook takes f uh
five in the game bishop g5 chosen by by
bogdan which is a
good move obviously you put pressure on
e7 it feels like
you're not entirely sure if the seven is
actually hanging or maybe black can you
know uh use the time to develop some
pieces but queen ga chosen by lyres i
think very clearly indicates that he
feels e7 was actually angry exactly and
it's intriguing for me like the queen on
b6
you know
it's not that great you you think you
have some threats maybe i don't know on
the f2 square
f2 is properly defended
are you going to play queen before it's
not really it's kind of empty but
if you if you were to ask me what would
be a really good square to be on
i would say f8 i'm tickling h6 i'm on
the open file i'm supporting even an e
with my queen on fa pardon me i am
supporting e7 e6 because i'll be
defending d6 and somehow the queen on fa
f8 to my way of thinking is far more
useful than on b6 i like this retreat
queen d8 which is
my question is what what is the follow
up for white i quite like this position
optically but uh
like you would maybe like to play bishop
d3
but you very much hate i think the idea
of allowing rook takes f3 gf-95 i think
uh black absolutely jumps at this
opportunity to ruin the structure on the
king's side
no question about it if i have to play
gf3 i stop yeah bishop bishop g6
this this is where i'm not taking the
rook on f3 obviously
uh for for for reasons that you
mentioned i don't want to deal with gf
and knight e5 but okay uh bishop d1
is a kind of a saner option here very
much
renewing the pressure against the e7
pawn and asking uh asking alireza to
commit to something and he clearly does
not like the idea of playing bishop f6
he could have played it on the previous
move but uh trading the bishop on h8 for
the bishop on g5 and leaving his king
even
with even fewer defenders i i don't
think appeals to him very much he might
be eventually forced into it but he he
would very much he's resisting yeah like
not to do that
and by the way we have seen throughout
the first four rounds that
uh daniel uh
he's a thinker too he's been getting the
time trouble quite a bit and he only
he's left himself six against twelve yes
six against twelve on move twenty he's
played quincy to d2 here which is a nice
consolidating move but perhaps slightly
less forceful than the rest it's not
like alireza has a sea of time like
we're used to him having i mean right he
usually has tons of time by this point
but he has 12 minutes as well
players are
really playing so well the position is
very difficult it's a tough position i
like the move queen d2 i really like the
idea of putting this bishop on d1 in
many locations and i think the move
queen d2 makes it even stronger because
in some positions you will play the move
bishop c2
challenging the rook on f5 challenging
the work on f5 saying do you really want
to take on f3 in those positions because
i wasn't so convinced that black jumps
at the possibility you are getting rid
of this knight on g4 and there are no
direct threats the move queen d2 defends
the bishop on g5 as well you don't know
when to move like knight h4 is a cheapo
or attacks the knight on g4 and the rook
on f5 and remember that at some point if
i take on g4 you take back with the
bishop on g4 e7 is hanging at the end
right right so there are there are some
variations you're going to have to
consider uh in this position and
alireza quickly plays the move queen f8
very very understandable very
understandably g7 needs to be covered
because yes i was i was even thinking
that let's say if you play bishop d7
there just just as a kind of a sensible
passing move even like d4 precisely that
was a move that i really like because
again
uh the these uh
awkward mate and one threats
are
kind of a showstopper otherwise
obviously you have to calculate because
94 rook takes g5 exists and after queen
takes g5 you have to calculate bishop
xd4 or bishop f6 first or something but
it seems to be working out yeah it seems
to be working out so i do like this move
queen fa very much again sidestepping a
lot of those threats uh for example
knight
i don't know
the thing about knight h4 is that now
you have to calculate bishop take c3
something that was not available in many
other variations because g7 was always
made now it's not made the queen guards
that square and now rook takes g5 looks
like an extra piece as well as 94.
if i'm taking
if i'm taking with the pawn there is
that 94 what you wanted to say yeah i
think we do play bishop d1 and then we
go from there because bishop d1 just
kind of
covers improves our position in every
possible way we attack e7 we control the
e4 square for all these tactics that
we've just been discussing no 94 jumps
for you sir
and yeah if you want to play bishop f6
you can play bishop f6 and then we will
consider whether uh taking is good or
whether we can actually maybe even
ignore it and there we go bishop d1 is
expected bishop d1 as expected and again
time trouble for these players what what
move are we on it seems like they've
played too slowly
and they've used virtually all their
clocks 12 minutes versus
five six minutes
and uh the increments and it's very
awkward uh some some very tough
decisions are going to be required in
the next few moves absolutely
this is the one to watch yeah we have
two more games going but they are
compared to this they are a lot drier
even though i briefly glanced because i
was wondering if fabi uh if what fabio
was doing is uh
any good and apparently he is back to
being quite a bit better uh in in his
game surprisingly uh but now it's more
of a positional advantage i don't think
he is really even trying to to give mate
anymore but he is kind of tickling the
queen side and provoking some weaknesses
and uh it's it's awkward to meet this
movement b3 because if you play b5 you
will have you will have some weaknesses
to address and white can then switch
perhaps to the king side again play
queen of three
uh black has the option of playing okay
trading the rooks but then your end game
is actually not entirely equal i can
take they give a check from h5 play
knight g4 perhaps
and uh
you still have some issues to solve and
we have also with white successfully
managed to weaken the queen side
potentially for some end games
yes
anytime you give me a position like this
where you put a knight on f5 i'm going
to be in my uh element uh thinking oh
boy have i got uh
good things happening for you you
mentioned in the game between richie and
lanier you would you would dream to get
b4 c4 c5 and richie aspired for it for
that after the move rook e8
i especially liked what you said i think
i i think i know why he didn't do that
at least yeah yeah if c5 bc5 rookie five
i think the point is we can play knight
of three
brook takes c5 bishop takes g6 and that
end game
we're not a pawn up because we will lose
the opponency forwards check
but the knight on c8 is kind of awkward
and apollon g6 eventually will be quite
weak let's go king b2 here fg rook takes
d7
white has the more active rook and the
ball on g6 if it was probably ends the
game
yeah because the g pawn will become
extremely dangerous we'll call that the
g pawn express yeah so so it feels like
this might be the reason not to not to
place e5 and linear indeed decides to
be a bit more conservative played six
yeah e7 b6 and let's go back again uh
for farouza i mean again
we've been saying this all the time a
big big big tournament coming up
uh in the candidates and it's important
that he comes into the candidates with
i want to say
not a head of steam or you know win in
the sails but at least a good deal of
confidence yeah
you want to be in a good mood yeah it's
not like winning this tournament is not
necessary but if he actually ends up i
don't know finishing on minus one as he
currently is that would be horrifying
yeah it will be a very serious dampener
on on his although i think fabi
uh before he won that candidates in in
2018
he scored something like minus four in
bike right right
i think he won grand kid just before
exactly right exactly he had that great
great result in congratulations
um so these things are always somewhat
arbitrary like just just how much a very
poor result in the run-up to the
candidates actually harms your
candidates but clearly you would you
would prefer to do without like i mean
that's exactly there's no argument that
exactly
one of the things uh in the old uh
cycle is you know you qualified for the
candidates but you qualify from these
incredibly long inter zonals so you
would usually be coming from this you
know very exhausting long interzonal
tournament where you did very well
congratulations that's how you become a
candidate and you'd have wind in
yourselves and these players
like myself would spend the next two
months trying to
prepare uh themselves but uh we want to
see something good happening for ali
reza in this game well not this game
this tournament please alejandra jump in
well we're gonna switch a little bit
because they are in time pressure fabi
is playing against shock we did look
more or less at this variation after the
move queen b3 peter you mentioned b5
which is very logical uh mahmet took a
very similar step instead of all the way
to b5 put upon b6 maybe hoping to fix
the structure later but the same we're
asked to be queen f3 rook 8 shade he had
to cover the h file takes takes checking
g8 is the current position i expect the
moving ig4 kind of place itself fabi is
down to
2 minutes and 48 seconds to make five
moves of chess knight g4 at least
doesn't seem very difficult and he does
retain a very strong initiative because
it's obvious which king is the one that
is being hunted down right the engines
say it's decisive
but wow but i i expect for it to require
some precision because i don't quite see
the killing blows
in many of the variations but the
engines are saying this huge advantage
for white i can't imagine that he won't
play knight g4 here though okay how uh
hasn't
yeah knight g4 obviously you just want
to put the knight on this gorgeous
outpost f5 yeah then how does it go for
example just go ahead and mod f8 we give
a check we give a check uh we probably
go king queen g4 queen g7
and then i'm wondering if you can just
play g2 g4 and kind of pass the move to
no but that allows queen f7 that is not
that great
g2 g4 yeah i wanted to just kind of say
you have no moves here because the
knight only 4 cannot leave its pose
because of 96 check knight on f8 is also
not very active but queen f7
unfortunately just bugs me yeah i do
have one move but unfortunately it's a
very good one yeah yeah yeah uh
you did everything rapidly and pretty
well uh
there's no
and he's actually played 26 check
instead which is wow clearly the other
move that is worth considering there but
not not as good yeah because the king
can actually run towards the center and
we are driving it towards the better
squares but he could play queen g6 check
do the computer like this no i know not
at all right
is forced here clearly you never put the
king in the corner
and then
i assume he's still going knight g4
right right
i just
i'm not why do you put it with this move
order
yeah i'm not sure why this is supposedly
better than the other mubarak and he has
played knight g4 yeah knight g4 on the
board but maybe he was afraid that he he
found the position after the knight on
f8 being a very good defender and he was
disturbed by it the knight is a good
defender but
what the edges wanted to do was keep
that king on the king side so even if
you go back to this variation after the
move knight g4 knight at f8 check check
and don't go for the g
don't go for queen g4 queen g7 you need
to type black up you can't play queen g4
if you felt like it but after the move
king f7 stop there the king wants to run
to the queen side he can't currently
because he's not there yeah a7 is
covered e8 is met with knight g7 so the
king's not going to go anywhere like
a284 a4
you know a4 c3 try to zooxant black and
on the queen side it's slow and it's not
clear especially when you're in time
pressure right you want to look for
something immediate concrete kill the
king but there's nothing there there's
no concrete blow which is what i was
mentioning earlier
that finishes off the game you just have
this positional advantage and black
can't really make a lot of moves
instead we do have queen g6 check on the
board uh king f8 and
i assume can continue running 94 we
probably play king e7
i assume he wants either knight d3 or
knight h6 i don't know which one is
stronger they seem very similar to me
and if you want to really taser your
opponent like yasser likes to say yeah
you can play knight c3
knight
c3 yeah how this works i don't know but
it works hold on the previous
yeah at this moment yeah yeah right now
queenie one queen h4 is a perpetual yeah
and queen h6 let's go of the knight on
g4
yeah but like who does that
computer
it's a funny movie though it is
it is a very strange move indeed i don't
think we'll see knight c3 but i am being
told we got to go back to the game of
dioc for a moment because he is really
uh low on time yeah and for a moment i
would suggest probably in this case
means until they're done with the time
trouble unless something really dramatic
happens on other boards because yeah
this is where all the action is going to
be i love this move uh rook f5 f7 i
think it's
i think it
well he's based beautifully he's
basically trying to be as non-committal
as possible exactly to give his opponent
enough rope
but also avoid all the tactics that may
or may not occur after moves like knight
d4 and or knight h4
a move that
would discover attack against the knight
discover attack against the rook instead
you say okay i'm turning over he's got
to move to you
and you've only got a minute he always
has a miniature he always has he starts
he always has 30 seconds he always has
30 seconds or 31. oh my 49 seconds for
it's a lot of moves i know you're
surviving an increment but it's not a
position where you just survived yeah
and here i think you want to double an e
file but you don't have enough squares
which is where an idea of trading that
the trading the knight on c3 for the
knight on c5 comes in so both knight a4
and knight e4 he's reaching first b pawn
and these players look like b3
b3 is the kind of a wave
uh did my spidey sense
doing six start tingling
or something yeah you just put up you do
is that a is that a cookie
is it my birthday i mean you you you're
not sure about how much you were
undefended the night you don't win it
right what why i mean you're not up upon
at the very least i could take on h6
take on c3 take on f8
yeah and then you send the rookies out
but that end game is really nice for
black i think you do pretty much
anything else like here i go king takes
a fatal
it's just a very very pleasant thing
i think i i'd actually much rather play
some kind of opposition pawn down than
this yeah v3 seems to be seems to be a
bit of a mistake and this is where
uh i think the calculation by reza that
you know in practical terms he's playing
against somebody who i mean he's a very
strong player bogdan and he's been
playing really well but he also keeps on
playing on increment
yeah
especially
that has
there are thirds there are 30 pieces on
the board here and stuff is hanging
everywhere so yeah it's it's going to be
difficult for him to keep i think he's
analyzing this is also tough on six
minutes at 30 he doesn't have an hour
and the thing about knight h6 is that
even on the variations that you went
upon
how good
is it but tell explain to me the move b3
because i'm still trying to understand
why you like i play bishop d7 instead of
the move like i was kind of like
commenting like
bishop d7 i i developed
what what does b3 do for white space i
think he just wanted to make like a
solid positional move and b3 is
something you do
i mean
i think it's a weakening uh sort of yeah
i mean um
i mean
from happening versions
i think it's straight up you just go b3
bishop d7 and a3
b3
yeah yeah
that's just a plan we should do seven a3
well kasparov would play a4 and then we
go knight
and
okay i'm told that var is smiling now so
we we pleased him
um
looks weird to me b3 okay i don't like
this move yeah i'm not the fan but i
don't think it spoils very much
unless knight h6 yeah is
once again my my good eyesight will be
my undoing here because after that takes
h6 the machine goes bishop g5 e3 i think
which is a movie you cannot make no no
no i mean the bishop
yeah yeah bishop e3 is the main move but
i think knight h6 maybe you have the
move knight a4 i think this one makes
more sense to me
knight a4 yeah you cannot take on a4 but
then we go neither five it's a good
square for the knight and particularly
if you're planning to take on c5 it will
give us a very nice d4 square
yeah yeah yeah and knight e5 i guess
comes in though yeah this is very very
nice play for for the pawn yeah or you
can even like throw in take stakes
yeah we could leave and d5 is hanging
knight a4 but this is kind of the point
right doesn't matter where the knight on
h6 goes or how you defend it i'll take
on c5 i'll take on c6
and then i'm i've ruined your structure
i've just tried your structure
definitely
i i completely agree with that and uh
well when i saw the move knight e5 as
well i just thought okay that's
sufficient compensation yeah we don't
need to go any further any further okay
so knight h6 so why is it bishop d7 the
question is whether anything else is
much stronger than knight takes h6 and
not h6 might have some shock value by
the way he has played knight takes h9 as
usual
yeah on a minute and 19 moves to go
whatever it is
by the way you were saying the first
move was bishop e3 yeah that's the top
move of the engine but i don't want to
think about it wow yeah creates an
additional idea of nigeria
and it's the same idea of bishop c5
actually
yeah it actually takes on c5 i think
after that yeah
it actually makes a lot of sense once
you plunk it on the board but coming up
with the idea impossible no this is not
the one
30 seconds as we're going to get a yeah
he's going to play either bishop takes
h6 or knight a4 those are the t those
are the two moves that i i think are
possible in this position realistically
20 seconds and counting and he doesn't
see it doesn't feel to me
like he's he's got it in his mind to
play knight
knight a4 bishop e3 whoa dc
i think he wants bc 95 or bc
bc
i think that's i think that's his that
would be my explanation for why or maybe
knight a4 actually maybe maybe knight a4
now having included gcbc gotcha yeah bc
uh pardon me d5 takes c6 on the board
after the recap yeah the five is the
problem my a4 might be clever here
but we have sort of committed to d takes
b takes a bit too early which maybe
means that knight g4 becomes slightly
more attractive here because we actually
badly want to stop knight e5 and 94 was
the best movie there right yeah
yeah i like that uh because when when
you played knight e5 against me peter i
just said uh yeah absolutely i i i
didn't like i think we should be well
d4 completely different approach and i
think we should be sticking with this
view because this is this is a very very
exciting time trouble and yeah
our viewers have seen enough of us
by this point they never never never
seen
okay c6 is hanging h16
remarkably d4 is hanging though can i
just eat that knight give me that you
can but it will i mean white is not
going to be horribly unhappy but i will
i will take i will go back to g2 and i
will claim i have some compensation but
yeah it's definitely playable and only
594 is a plan or 96 might be good yeah
are you sure you have compensation
earpieces some conversation yes but yeah
i'm i'm enjoying this much more for
black than i than i use i'm beginning to
think h6 bishop f4 g5 bishop h2
those two bishops of yours are not
exactly uh
also as i mentioned 96 actually captures
it if we want also 96 could rob you of
your compensation i don't like the move
in knight d4 how about you uh alejandro
no i have an engine so i don't like it
yeah and that's why he gets the big
no but it does agree the engine does
with your evaluation of bishop takes d4
queen takes d4 e5 in both senses yes
it's the correct move knight f5 is also
okay for black as well but bishop takes
every queen takes d4 you are right that
white has some compensation but
it doesn't think it's quite enough yeah
played which is fine it's a very logical
move right he wants to be as as
complicated as possible because he is
giving up on six i assume we can take on
c6 here well better but yeah he wants to
keep the position as tactically
complicated as possible against somebody
else
well because they should be bishop what
am i doing after bishop b7 by the way
it's not completely clear
to be honest uh
that was my that was my big hope and and
then i was hoping i'm not losing to rook
c8 which right is the bigger problem
here because i'm not quite sure how i'm
replying to rook c8 uh there's
that's the knight takes e7 yeah
four ten seconds
three seconds it's gonna be this guy's
doing
my god how can you do it every single
day by the way this is not yeah this is
a
universal occurrence throughout the
tournament yeah right i mean i remember
against richie uh
he was getting down to seconds each and
every time he was finding all of the
great moves yeah did
n does knight c6 have i i have a feeling
that this has a a clear drawback right
though yeah bishop seven is you should
be seven bishop three eight i think just
kind of rock c8 yeah so bishop so we're
gonna take on e7 what do we get it
doesn't work like i was trying to make
it work but we just don't have enough
attackers yeah right should be seven is
very strong
it's very strong and
the engine i briefly cheated there the
engine says we should be seven
which which i mean he might actually
play because i think he will realize
bishop three rook c8 is extremely
awkward so and and you otherwise you
just kind of lose the knight on c6 so
right bishop
not bishop f3 but immediately
immediately before but then you're worse
against pretty much anything i guess a
before night before and then some move
black is already better because black
has fantastic bishops on two long
diagonals exactly and uh no longer no
longer upon down or anything so yeah
this is enjoyable bishop takes is
probably also quite good bc5 dc5 by the
way i'm thinking just h7a
b4ab knight before i'm thinking h7 h6
i've got this knight h4 no this is not
saying the bishop on this beaut
don't beat a dead horse yeah everything
is good for black after b4 is just
structurally terrible for the whites
yeah
bishop b7 on the board this is this has
gone slightly off the rails for for
bogdan
i think he just missed knight h6 he is
very quickly he very much missed knight
h6 and then panicked kind of panicked
yeah i was still hoping not hoping but
sort of on previous form in this
tournament i was expecting him to play
knight a4
uh because knight f4 seemed like a very
large game
very powerful knight on c5 straight away
the knight on c5 play positional
compensation there yeah for passive
knight on c3 and we've been seeing
throughout by the way this night on c3
has not played a role in the game and in
fact has been a tactical liability for
white
yeah again uh two minutes
yeah two minutes
and playing on increment for pogba and
but we're expecting yeah
good but you can also throw in h6 and
ask a similar question just the next
move
yeah
i i really like the move h6 but frankly
if rook c8 wins
it it comes pretty close it comes pretty
close i think the only move is g2 g4
right so and yeah welcome
sort of you're welcome to finding it on
30 seconds and then playing it on the
board and making yourself play yeah
forcing you physically forcing yourself
to play the move g2 g4 in this position
like it's just
that's really lifting your kimono
oh boy oh boy and we do this
six yeah i just thought that was fine
too for a while i don't know if they're
still going back on it but h6 had liked
considerably more than rook c8 roxy was
also fine rook a6 also a good move
uh do you have to calculate a little bit
here knight takes e7 check
right no it's not so much a calculator
97 bishop b7 and yeah some kind of 95
yeah we're just going for some kind of
weird positional compensation here with
knight d5 because the rook on a6 is
definitely
worse worse than rook on ca but it's
about 20 seconds 20 seconds to figure
out something whoa
i played g4 just too ugly
uh yeah i don't think i don't think that
it might be a desperado kind of i don't
think anybody plays g4 6 also has the
practicality that you're playing here we
go he's spent all the time
on
he snapped on e7 his best chance yeah he
knew he knew he had to uh and uh yeah
after knight takes e7 bishop takes b7
for russia will also has the option of
including bishop take c3 just to get rid
of some of the attackers which is
important yeah
that might be a very uh clever play
actually yeah it's actually a necessary
play oh even yeah but bishop takes e3
the bishop on h8 has been
hiding for a long a long while and uh
can get rid of this knight queen takes
and then at the end
uh
the battlefield were a piece down we're
appears down we do have like we don't
have to resign immediately because the
king on g8 is slightly you know feeling
slightly drafty and there are some
active pieces but black after all is a a
a piece for one pawn up
and uh should be expected to
convert it into a full point that guy
doesn't sound like a lot
it makes a lot of sense to take on c3
once you realize that all of white's
counter plays revolves around the d5
square and bishop takes c3 takes away
both of them the queen is distracted and
you just eliminate the knight yeah yeah
i think it's maybe maybe even take on e7
first and then put put the knight on d5
and play rookie one and choose to to go
that way is also i'm just a little
afraid that if i take on e7 first
you take on c3 and then maybe queen
definitely ah that's very nice
that's very nice maybe i don't know it's
25
it's a definition i mean you're just
well you're you're you're making uh this
peace sacrifice
chaotic all right all right here it
comes
yeah there's a yeah bishop bishop takes
it
he knows he understands best move
for ruja
yeah he's going to be up a piece
and
he just needs to make the time control
basically pretty much he needs to make
it to move 40 without uh you know
anything uh drastic changing in the
position quincy three just go
uh i i don't even know how to uh
continue continue asking pertinent
questions here like you want to go
rookie tour if but you you feel like it
probably isn't fast enough in particular
because h7 h6 exists which will push the
bishop away from the
fantastic they still have a lot of moves
to go i mean
you don't have time to resign it's the
type of thing you know so never think
about resigning these these moments
nobody resigns in this position yeah
except all the players come to the
playing hall
after afterwards and they go oh my
plight so terribly i was thinking about
resigning and that's not true they never
think about resigning but they always
say yes i'm thinking about resigning
here and then and then they go on to win
it's like yeah
rookie too as we sort of expected but
after h6 that play along the e file will
you know get end of story i also like
just
how how how the 500 k8 yeah
exactly i mean basically the business
square here is covered and i cover
the business square on
the eighth rank with rook a8 knight g7
might have allowed bishop e7 or some
disturbance once
you play knight c5 for queen g7 it's
game over yeah it's a you just need to
solve some immediate problems here and
not allow any any cheap shots exactly
okay the one thing i can imagine is
maybe if you could put your queen on d5
and somehow
uh coordinate a
penetration along the e file maybe
something but at the moment it just
feels like ferrugia is a piece up and
should
be going on
h6 i think h6 is a logical move here as
well yeah just uh
g5 is clearly the best square for this
bishop so why not chase it away unless i
mean it kind of provokes bishop c1 b2
right that's the the other potential
idea that you you have in these types of
positions i think you actually do go
bishop c1 here and at least ask the
question
yeah there we go
like
there was never any threat along the
diagram but actually
you know i'll always meet king h bishop
b2 with king h7 so i do like i i i'm
definitely warming to this whole h7h6 at
first i thought i was simply
on the way necessarily yeah
unnecessarily weakening uh the king's
side but king on h7 is going to be very
secure so
it looks okay to me but actually
something interesting but we we should
stick with this one but i'm wondering
what's happening in the
rapport dominguez game because i'll ask
alejandro to
keep an eye on that game uh
yeah i was wondering if rookie five just
wins the pawn on g5 but there's
definitely i mean i guess it's king e3
or something or rook e5 rookie fight
wants a pawn but it doesn't win the game
we can go back to the yeah
just briefly uh all right
well keep an eye on that one and bishop
c1 and okay
yeah i mean i've got to cover this i got
you covered guy i see i see where where
you're
heading you want to put a rook on e8
i'll stop you
again uh the desired bishop b2 check
made on the
is going to be met by king h7 and here
it goes
bishop b2 how many seconds three
yeah king h7 came very very quickly as
the mate on h8 is now protected
or hope or something but it's just very
difficult to create a threat here i
guess knight f5 knight c5 in some order
yeah knight c5 first i would think bring
the knight it's not playing into the
game but
the the problem is creating something
meaningful after rook fe1 because you
are down a piece and at this point you
want to do something right precisely
that's how i play knight c5 what's your
next move exactly i i very much like
just covering the business square rookie
six stopping
uh
and like you say once you get knight f5
in
all all
black needs to do
is engineer trades i mean it's the
oldest strategy in the game of chess
when you're ahead material
drag your opponent to their doom by just
trading off their the attackers in this
case black would love to take a pair of
rooks off the board and uh there goes
the
there goes any uh
compensation knight c5
good move
yeah and uh i mean white basically has
the absolute best setup they can have
right now double doubled on the one open
file the battery on the long
diagonal full force and there you just
can't create a single threat yeah
exactly it's very uh saddening
for for bogdan here because yeah he
would like to somehow improve seconds
and ten seconds and he
realizes he's reached his apex position
but there's nothing
that he could further
gain he's dropped his queen back queen
e2 comes with absolutely no threat
exactly and we can move the knight to
defend the pawn well the six is hanging
uh yes exactly yeah but i mean knight f5
is coming yeah after knight of five
queen d5 we're still not threatening
anything exactly it uh yeah it makes
maybe makes your your possession look a
little bit more harmonious for a second
right it's just not doing very much you
feel better about yourself yeah
the only real question is exactly what
yazar was saying exactly how do we take
like a pair of rooks to start with how
do we take it off the board you can go
rook d8 prepare rookie 7 i don't know if
it's even necessary we can also
uh
into the h6h5 somewhere thank you thank
you i really really like that move a lot
i mean again i've got this i've got this
uh background of being a french defense
player and i've come over the years to
really respect the knight on f5
defending my king and i love the move h6
h5 just stopping g2g for forever
and then like you say you can start to
wonder how do i challenge the e-file
it's a very very grim position for white
what's happening in the fabiano game
anything special see black's king has
ran run all the way over
[Music]
i don't know
oh fabi's not made any progress over
yeah they've reached time control but
the king would ran all the way to see it
now funnily enough once the king did
reach the c8 square and the move queen
g4 was played here black's best move is
actually king d8 yeah
amazing threatening to win the game
right now but still within they've made
the time control we'll catch up we'll
catch up with those players in no time
as we keep an eye on uh
daniel's game
yeah h5 actually has been played by reza
on bishop c3 in response and once again
he gets up from the board in 37 seconds
but he's been doing this every day we've
gotten a bit more used to it by now
exactly
yeah no threats but yeah the the big
issue here is exactly uh how to make
progress with black um
it's not so easy it's not that easy you
still have to you still have to
think about things yeah i very much like
bishop c3 because it also pins the uh a
rook to the protection of the a5 pawn
because if you imagine the a5 pawn
coming off the board that becomes an
unclear position yeah we're not so happy
we have some play yeah b3 before we'll
come and i i'm i'm thinking i would love
to put the queen black queen on f7 so
let me just play a move uh let's say i
play queen g8
idea
moving the rook
and offering a trade of queens uh peter
it it it takes me some time to unwind
the pieces if
if i can put it in there he's gone
knight d7 so he's playing it very very
concretely he wants the knight over on
f6 to block uh to block the long
diagonal we were talking about the fact
that the a6 a5 pawn is hanging but
probably not after knight f6 because not
i like that too i like them even though
maybe you actually have to bite the
bullet and try to take on a5 knight f6
queen g2 but once black actually starts
creating threats of of his own this will
collapse
like true true he's gone rookie six
instead understandably doesn't really
want to bother with uh
uh trifles such as a pawn on a5
say say what
trifle
did you hear this
this is the word of the day
all the words that he's been throwing
out today this is the one that got you
trifle
i mean appetizers snacks what what what
i live for these trifles knight d7
rookie six on the board
which no which
move number is this that's 37 37.
okay um
uh rooks it makes an impression but yeah
rook c8 played yeah reza clearly decided
that he does not want to
protect a5 over much and
if white wants to spend time be taking
it although i guess he's not actually
sacrificing it because queen a5 he can
play okay rook takes a2 and exactly
that allows rookie eight in the end
nine yeah and as usual
the countdown starts and finally he
takes with the bishops the trifle
the trifle is captured yeah because rook
c5 i guess he has queen d2 so he doesn't
lose material that way
so that's the
rook trade that i'm trying down 65 for
e5 but then maybe we play bishop c3 and
we claim that
uh you know compared to you clipped up
oops yeah you clipped the pawn yeah you
could do that but why not try your
knight on d7 for the rook on e6 instead
of rook e5 go knight
to e5 and how's this work getting out of
this
queen c8 is right
i'm going to play bishop c3 and after
quincy and i'm going to play rook takes
d6 and i'm going to claim that i'm
channeling the uh the old masters and
you know the old masters will be very
proud of you very very proud of yeah uh
we didn't have any of that we in fact
have neither six played the queen knight
f6 the queen will drop back to i'm
guessing d3
i was going to guess d2
yeah one of those two squares
g5 in the air yeah yeah
you keep it in a dark square
pulse
yeah
yeah knight g4 bishop c3 back and then
maybe f2f3
if uh you know with the a5 pawn gone now
even some of the end games become
less less hopeless for white right i'm
not completely uh
happy that i've dropped off this a pawn
and i i haven't traded off a pair of
rooks
either um
i'm not a fan of knight f6 no no the
engine thinks it was a terrible move
yeah okay
still kind of winning though
kind of winning but it does make his job
a lot harder because white now has a
plan
yeah if i can improve my position to the
maximum and just push my a pawn bishop
c3 another issue yeah bishop c384a5 and
we don't have to resign rook e8 yeah
nobody's forcing you yeah clearly
clearly he uh
and whoa
dropped so much yeah i'm just assuming
bishop c3 we can even take on e8 first
to
displace the knight on f6 and then go
bishop c3
okay fair fair uh and yeah
this is now kind of semi-playable for
why it's somewhat surprising yeah we're
gonna have a game in our hands if
black's better you do have extra
material but
do you guarantee you win all these
positions all the time or for real if
you take every single major piece off
the board
which might happen two knights versus
the bishop do you guarantee you win it
every time no not every single time
even though you know queen with a couple
of knights
is a very very what if i force queens
off yeah queensland i think it's
actually closer to a draw but the issue
there is i think
white often will just get mated because
the the absence of the h pawn will start
getting failed in in those end games
that we're describing but yeah and we're
they're going to have plenty of time to
think about it because everybody left
the board they did reach time control
you know you guys know how happy i'm
always about time controls being reached
and everything in 30 minutes and we can
stop the action so that everybody takes
a break yay yay but that's us too but
yeah we have this position on the board
and the engine is really hating the last
few moves of ferruja now saying that
black is better you still do have a
piece but you have to be precise the
move rook e6 is putting a lot of
pressure on the sixth string there's
also this past pawn a lot has changed
dramatically in in essence
they really want to play the move knight
g4 saying you need to create some
threats you need to start putting some
ideas of your own forward it also makes
sense to move the knight out of f6 where
everybody's targeting it and after f3
you go to e5 uh you cannot really take
bishop takes e5 because d takes rook
takes the engines are saying
the bishop was the only source of
counter play for white it doesn't matter
you have three pawns this is one of
those scenarios because you have the
pawn on f3 the fact that you have a
knight and a queen combo matter so much
more than the past pause on the flank
you can go queen g7 or queen ba try to
penetrate down on the dark squares and
it's going to be difficult for white to
hold the engine is thinking rookie 6
knight g4 f395 leave that knight alone
go c5 try to break open this diagonal
yet again and the game just kind of
continues something that
well it's a big achievement for deck
considering he was just
down a piece for a pawn entering the
complication so good achievement for him
doesn't guarantee that he's going to
save the game but at least gives himself
a fighting chance meanwhile in this one
things have happened the king got
pursued all the way to the queen side it
got pulled back a little bit with this
last clever move knight f5 king c
8 queen g4 threatening knight d6 check
picks up this queen as we were talking
about so the king went to d8
and after queen h3 we have uh mamadiarov
thinking
they've made time control but it is
still a pleasant for shock it's not a
position where he is losing like we were
thinking about earlier his king getting
caught but he is still worse his king's
still much worse than whites the knight
on f5 is still a nuisance uh it's easier
to attack
black spawns than white spawns blacks
knight on d7 it's a bit passive it
probably has to reroute somewhere but
where the pawn on d4 is doing a great
job controlling it that being said there
are no immediate threats the queen on e6
and the knight on e4 hold very important
positions and it's not easy to play
for white for a win knight f8 seems to
be the best move by the engine
challenging white to find a follow-up
you want to put the queen all the way on
h5 but it starts getting rid of some of
the important pieces specifically if i
can trade off this knight on f5 that
would be fabulous the knight on f8 also
trying to go to g6 harassing some of the
white pieces so if 9f8 is played the
engines think black is fine otherwise he
will be suffering for a while
and what about richie's game against
lanier my first sight i'm thinking
richie's winning i mean he's gonna go
king of four king e5 and just uh
absolute domination but king of four f6
yeah
g6 knight
and uh
we don't need to give up any material
right we can go king of fate yeah it's
the fortress oh you want to go king f oh
i'm sorry in this position after g6
king's king of fate i thought was also
completely fine
totally fine for who
bishop
here
and you go what a4 uh
go h4 verses
g7 here what's the problem and i get a
pawn and i take on c4 oh no you've got
bishop d1 bishop b3
you're on time
yes yeah so you do play h4 i guess yeah
all right uh having made time control
the players uh taking a break
are commentating so socially yes we'll
see you on the other side of this break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to bucharest
romania for day five of the super bad
chess classic actually while we were on
a break one game finished that is the
game between richie report and dominguez
which ended up in a drawing we do have
richie ritchie welcome back to the
studio we haven't seen you since uh day
one a lot of things have happened in
your tournament tell us a bit about how
you lived the past few days uh
yeah i mean i played i think i played
the okay games except uh against the act
it was
hard to comment
um but yeah today as well okay lanier is
very solid i tried to
something of beat but
didn't get much let's speak about that
you started off with this move knight to
it when everybody in the playing hall uh
including some of the players were kind
of smiling you know
entertaining this idea of yours oh yeah
92 i mean you know okay there are so
many hooks in this position i don't see
a reason why 92 cannot be another one
yeah why not yeah
of course white is not
you know aiming to get any advantage or
anything but
okay it hasn't been played too much and
it's moved too so i was
pretty happy about this uh to play this
one yeah and he chose more or less uh
the most conventional approach knight to
f6 d4 i mean basically i went for this
petrov line yeah where my knight
if it was on s3 i guess why it would
better okay with this arguable but we
don't need to e2 it should be harmless
uh or
at least i believe that was his his
logic
but i mean also on the other hand maybe
i can claim some you know slight edge i
mean
i don't know i felt like
somewhere here
yeah somewhere here maybe i wasn't um i
could have posed more problems because
the thing was that after
97
cars so we have here yeah like uh i am
always very close but never on time like
bishop g5 can be met with rookie 8
and then he can just take on c3 here and
bishop e6 and i guess this is also
questionable like we should be three but
i would think okay he's fine and also
what i did uh
always one move away yeah you played
bishop
yeah again yeah like bishop c6 is very
concrete uh
he just wants this knight d5 radius i
played here and again like i would be
doing well if he would go knight f5
takes
takes
check
it's very forcing lines
takes
one
yeah and he's forcing his stick
i take back and this is very unpleasant
because i will get a group on the seven
with a p5 following up so i think so for
example yeah
is very unpleasant so like i was hoping
for something like this but of course he
found 95 and here um it's a pt because
like this line doesn't work i think look
at seven
and here it seems to be very good that
bishop b6
here takes knight takes and king d8
takes and bishop h6 oh
it's like uh almost uh crashing for by
this rookie 7 idea but there's no rho c4
right yeah there's also okay i have to
take on f7 so okay then
there's no point of entering this of
course after concern so yeah it's uh
enough and i couldn't go for this which
would have been very nice of course to
to do this with g7 and then i went for
this maybe five bishop f6 but this is
really like uh almost almost nothing or
was entirely nothing so and yeah of
course in the in the time travel i
somewhat misplayed it so at the end i
was even the one who had to be precise
which i think i managed but like not a
an extraordinarily you know interesting
game from here
uh richard definitely up to this point a
sub par let's say uh situation
especially by your standards uh what are
you going to do uh to ride the ship back
on track after the rest day i mean you
know it's very hard to to complain i
played four games i think pretty well or
at least decently okay i had you know
sweet black so like or any kind of
handicap and then i had this white game
where i first hang i mean the first time
like almost winning in 20 moves which is
quite
surprising even for for me and then
after that i basically just trapped my
own bishop on e8 in one move after which
it still will grow and i think i am the
one who is pushing for a win and just i
mean uh missed that 95. for queen takes
the two in one move like
very hard to explain and all these two
things to do in one game it's very hard
to explain so i don't feel like anything
should be changed too much because okay
if i do it again i mean uh okay what can
i what can i do here i mean i will just
keep on repeating and doing the same
until it stops i guess yeah and what's
the plan for the rest day are you going
to visit the
the the city bucharest are you going to
go to some restaurant what's black i
believe maybe all of that but it's not
entirely up to me as my wife is here and
i think she's you know not enjoying
herself too much
since i'm playing very badly and then it
is very boring to be on chess tournament
so like uh i will adjust to whatever she
likes him richard keep the spirits up
and we'll see you in a couple of days
hopefully guys back to you thank you
christian thank you richard and these
are our updated standings peter
with two games still in
play
absolutely wesley is still leading the
three three and a half out of five
heading into the rest day
uh pursued by lebanon and maxima
srilagov on three points and
theoretically could be caught up by
bogdander but he is a piece down against
uh
even though his position improved i
don't think it improves to such a degree
that he is uh playing for a win there
we'll see though if he if he can hold it
it would be uh quite a success yeah and
he'll be in a tie for second and i think
very very happy going into the rest game
and we have fabi
also
playing with shaq at the moment and at
at one point we thought that fabby
was going to be winning the game um what
is
oh i see you've got the farouza game on
your board alejandro i speak about that
we've just seen them move
knight f6 d7 by perugia i can speak
about both let's see what's going on
because first spent some time actually
significant amount of time dropped with
the knight back to d7 and the engines
ask a pretty simple question what do you
do against queen g5 do you play 95 how
do you defend this pawn exactly i assume
the idea is queen h6 right but the
problem is that you have this move
rookie eight it's a nice intermeta jutsu
if they're in the van they can now
understand this here rook 8 shade is
going to be mate how do you defend
against this knight f6 bishop takes f6
95 even just going into the end game is
not so clear right you go here takes
takes i could start pushing i could even
just take my pawn back that's three
against none on the queen side i'm not
sure that white really is playing this
for a win against the knight but
you're fine you're absolutely fine in
this position you're not even worse so
queen g5 is a great move the engine is
already thinking this is 0.00 like
black's not even better despite being up
a piece because well you have lost
another pawn on the a file it's two
pawns for white you might be getting a
third one white is consolidating its
attack on the king setting you haven't
been able to repel it fully you haven't
been able to repel the rook from e6 you
haven't coordinated your rook on f7 the
knight on d7 is not where it's supposed
to be you're a few moves away from
putting your pieces exactly where they
should be it's coming and i think it's
coming yeah queen g5 yeah i think he mr
k8 i think he very much intended queen
h6 here and thought queen g5 is a bit of
an empty gesture because 28 quincy one
check would be
uh you know another way to attack the
back rank would lose immediately the
quincy one check but he mistricate and
and and then yeah it really does look
like
it will be yet another day
uh of uh you know missed opportunities
for for ali reza who
i mean he
and you can say that he you know draws a
fair result because he was borderline
lost out of the opening but that was a
very conscious decision he was basically
faced with a draw for a move 12 13 there
was a repetition on the board which
wasn't forced but did look like bogdan
would probably repeat if he repeated
and he went from what he must have known
was a very very risky position
strategically just to keep pieces on the
board just to continue playing a very
complicated position and he did end up
out calculating and not playing bogdan
there
and then
if he fails to put this to bed if he
fails to win this one this one will hurt
quite a bit as much as maybe
the missed opportunity that he had
against lavonne as well
and we do instead of the move queen h6
we have seen
queen gg
yeah that that is kind of an awkward
move g8 is keeping all three results
open because
right i mean that queen is very passive
truly
yeah uh he's i i'm guessing he's
dreaming about playing knight to e5
c5 is his next move knight c5 rook eight
seven or ninety five and rook a seven i
think
knight c5 we figure it out
let's see where your row goes first
exactly
yeah i'm wondering if there's something
concrete we can do if we should just
play something like i don't know b3 b4
here or
i'm a little bit worried like whenever i
touch these pawns oh
yeah yeah that's the second there's a
second move there on your screen yeah oh
that is that's gorgeous that's gorgeous
so the engine wants to play g4 it's got
to be g4 otherwise you are worse because
knight c5 is coming
you can put it on your board pardon me
after queen g8 knight c5 is the big
threat yeah and the machine likes g4 g4
you have to take because yes
yes and the follow up is rook takes d6
and who is better in this position and
why and why
you can't capture on d6 with the knight
the whole point of the move g4 is of
course that that opens up the h file so
queen h4 is just mate
nice so
how do you continue
if we move our rook yeah removing the
pawn on d6 is just so important because
it takes away the e5 square from from
the g7 knight rookie seven i'm guessing
we can
i mean even queen takes g4 i suspect is
not unplayable right because the rook is
still not hanging
it's starting to look bad for a black
yeah well it's pretty clean
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i was beginning
to have
my doubts as well g4 easy move to miss
yeah that's
g4 is easy to miss rook takes d6 yeah
he's gonna miss but there's no problems
with g4 pawn takes queen takes g4 this
position that i have on the border you
can just take on g4 here as well you
have queen e5 ideas later you have rook
takes d6 like this later you can't play
knight c5 i'll just take on d6 if you
play knight e5 i'll give you this check
you never want to pin yourself right you
can't really go to g7 you have to use
this knight awkwardly and defend on the
h file but again you're blundering this
d6 pawn constantly i'm gonna take that
one and it's still a mess it is still a
mess and bogdan has played the move g4
let's see if he follows it up by first
taking on d6 because i don't think
alireza has a choice here you have to
take on a g4 in this particular moment h
takes g4 rook takes d6 will be very cool
queen takes g4 is also okay so we're
gonna have to figure out which this one
is but this one has gone from blacks up
a piece to a three result game
pretty quickly yeah we've lost control
yeah there's no question about it that
uh farouza has given his opponent more
than enough chances to save the game and
as you said even sneak in a three result
yeah and this is uh wow one of those
cases where i think
uh you know we see bogdan finding this
tactic so very quickly i mean we haven't
seen him play with 86 yet but
on current form i wouldn't at all bet
against that happening and i think
it's a
a case of
you know him gaining confidence mid-game
because i think somewhere by move 25
when he lost that piece
and compensation wasn't really all that
obvious at all i think he probably
uh
was sort of coming to terms with this
game not going his way and then
uh the market improvement that his
position
undergone between moves like 30 and 40
is is you know bringing new life
and
i think he's back to calculating quickly
and confidently and
hoping for a good result today
wow
i'm still kind of uh
stunned
by this turnaround that we're seeing and
obviously
h6 h5 was played to cement the knight on
the f5 square g4
h5 takes g4 you got to do it and uh
queen takes
g4 as well this is going to play
d6
it's a it's a very like you you don't
expect these shots to be of like the
reason you miss them is that you just
don't think in a position with three
pieces on the board such sacrifices are
possible right so you just you just play
the the logical movement the g4 is very
logical here you you've opened up the
age while queen h3 check is now a threat
and
you just don't look for better but
better was available
well it's still remarkable that better
was available
it's stunning in fact that rook takes d6
and you're losing this
key pawn that you wanted to leverage
whether it be for 95 or knight c5
e5 played already by
alireza we're talking about the move
queen h3 in this position because you
want to pick up the third pesh key i
don't see a problem after knight h6 rook
takes d6 i know that there's a check on
f3
but you can even maybe choose a square
honestly yeah oh yeah probably just a
check even king on f1 feels pretty
yeah i'd probably go to f1 to not have
to think about queen a8 ideas
but aren't there pieces here around your
king that you should be worried about i
mean no no no not really what we all
hold on what do you do king king of one
yeah the bishop also very importantly
covers the e1 square so you can't even
properly threaten us with the queen
eight looks logical but it doesn't
really create a threat and by this point
white is extremely happy with end games
so i'm very much looking looking at
queen e6 there and yeah no i'm not
interested in it i mean it's you know
like i'm looking
trying to force tactics is what i'm
trying to do peter i'm not sure that i'm
gonna
very understandable because n games
might be better for white now right with
three connected past months okay so
knight g for e3 i thought i think queen
d3 also reminds black
white can create threats rook d7 rook d8
all of those things are now very much in
the air yeah i like jesus
and halfway through the tournament it's
a critical game for both of these
players we have the rest day tomorrow
and bogdan daniel's deck has shown
incredible resilience in this tournament
that game against richard rapport it was
blow after blow but richard made the
last mistake and bogdan daniel took full
advantage of it meanwhile ali reza what
a different story he's had he had really
good position against nepal at some
point ended up losing that game again in
a wild complicated one but that one
against aronian has to be the one that
really really stings just completely
running out of the opening his opponent
blundering
inexplicably but surviving
and and it just has not been a good
showing for early versa
this one not so far not so far it felt
like he had his chances oh that he still
has his chances because it's a three
result game but look at the position it
went from upper piece consolidate make
it to mu 40 to
i don't know who's even better here
right
and again time trouble was very much a
factor peter in much of this
late middle game and it was probably
right about here that the move rook a6
kind of like was a
the mystery move yeah if you if you
compare okay okay six with rook c8 he
would have been if if the reaction is
the same which is probably it wouldn't
have been because it really does look
lost yes but if the reaction is the same
black is up about 210p exactly that's
exactly the point that i wanted to make
that for whatever reasons
the move rook a6 came and then later as
we're about to discover right here the
rook came back and
uh
was quite frankly uh
back on c8 uh two moves later
i mean it took two tempe to get it to
yeah and it's difficult to point out
exactly like the big big mistake but uh
starting from 97 i kind of stopped uh
stopped liking what he was doing i think
it was here that the machine was really
pounding on the table
for the move knight g4 as uh alejandro
was pointing out that we could
if you go for the pawn knight now that
we've
uh weakened the square uh
weaken the structure it doesn't it
doesn't look lost but you probably
actually end up getting mated
it was really knight g4 knight d7 on the
other hand
allowed this extraordinary g4 rook takes
d6 idea but queen takes g4 nothing wrong
with it
either and suddenly um
well it's it's
well anybody's game right yeah anybody's
game and we are expecting queen h3
shockingly for for those two players uh
bogdan is also doing better on the clock
than alireza is bogdan is uh
down to 19 and a half against 13 for his
opponent
by the way after queen h3 check i am
forced to play knight h6
i mean this is just this would be worse
would be walking into rook takes d6 and
it's no longer a three result if it's a
one result game pretty much
and uh
for white so we are expecting that after
queen h3 check knight
h6 rook takes d6
do we have to play knight f3 check peter
is it is knight g4
maybe
i don't think it's enough of a threat
and
white probably finds a way to to deal
with it i'm i'm trying to snack snap off
a pawn and uh
make pretence this is around
now king side is sort of safe enough
that i'm wondering if i can just play f3
and
look at you quizzically
really
this guy is like hanging
i mean yeah queen beaters or queen f8 is
what worries me but uh i'm not trying to
get on this diagonal yeah like rook d4
or something and i'm provoking 95 though
rook d4 was not the move that i was
planning to make i was playing to play
c5 but c5 like queen a7 queen c7 is
worrying me
uh i would be very worried here
it feels like
white's king is getting yeah it could
collapse on the other hand if it doesn't
lose
your knight on g4 doesn't have very many
good squares like 93 queen e6 will
straight up lose i believe so
just a second i i'm i'm stunned by that
you could even
reach for your f pawn
wow i'm also wondering like what is the
big deal with the f1 if i go with
something like queen h4
yeah what's going on well that as well
yeah queen h4 yeah
yeah i mean
the training
training
exactly exactly exactly what did you
call it uh by the way it wasn't a snack
it was trivial
trifle
okay
um what is happening in the meantime i
do want to to point out we have another
game going and uh
i think quite quite a bit better here
yeah
uh it has gone sort of back slightly off
the rails for for sacrileges now the
queen of d6 is an incredibly strong
piece 97 is one thing that immediately
attracts attention here i wonder what
the reply is even
because uh
yeah i'm not quite sure how you don't
reach the entire setup yeah queen f4
check is not what you want you're just
going to
lose the c6 pawn and probably even more
after knight b4 so knight e7
that looks
it's crunchy
very crunchy i'm i'm actually surprised
the engine is not giving plus a million
right yeah queen of two is a clever move
here creating some lean f2 yeah but the
fact that you have to give up c6 was
check and that's your best move should
be an indication of just how far white
has progressed in the game truthfully uh
you you're setting up a perpetual check
but you do you sure think that white has
uh ways of of dealing with that we'll
start with check right yeah
it's surprisingly difficult to deal with
this threat yeah because the light kind
of gets gets in the way you could play
knight g6 yeah you could play knight g6
but there was a follow because d4 is
hanging yeah we take on different
things have something to improve right i
was thinking you were taking on c2 for
some strange reason but and i have 95
but taking on d4
is
a good move uh
hmm
yeah i think 97 check maybe is even
unnecessary because it's hanging on e7
it's not hanging on c6 so we could try
uh like 96 king c8 and uh some move here
i don't know queen h6 queen e6 something
you know just
have attending e1 and snapping the
perpetual
taking control of some of the important
squares but yeah this is now very
troubling for black yates so
it went from being reasonably safe i
assume to to this and this
might still end up getting held but
not not not in that nice way
no no you're definitely suffering
as black here big time i like this move
queen e6 a lot
uh like you say just uh covering e1
um
and well no this is very bad
i'm a pawn grubber right i've got uh
yeah we had a second pawn and
i'm still i'm still surprised it's not
like plus a million
yeah right 95 is coming 97 i guess i
guess they go king c7 and it's slightly
awkward because uh we need to make a
move yeah here king c7 and like if the
knight goes somewhere queen [ __ ]
takes d4 suddenly becomes a check right
that's a chance so we need to spend a
tempo on something and then maybe queen
of four will be an awkward check to meet
and so on like it's i can see how
weirdly this is still very much an
ongoing game because the king on h2 is
not safe from perpetuals
and uh
our connection between the knight and
the queen our own queen has been
destabilized to a degree right exactly
oh wow but and this i think is the
reason that five hasn't played 97 yet
because 97 until you until you spot
queen f2
you you think 97 kind of ends the game
right because so
there's just no good reply whatsoever
this is the current position yeah i
wonder i wonder what the other options
are i suspect something like c2 c3 might
be playable for instance
uh because queen takes bitsu you get the
feeling that you will get mated somehow
right
i don't know exactly how but you get the
feeling it might lead to getting mated
i'm pretty sure every single end game
starting with queen f4 check is
borderline lost and that's that's
important actually to show if you play
queen for check here i take take i play
king h3
knight f6 king h4
so the idea is we want to approach this
pawn and pick it up and if you stop me
you stop me for one move but not it's
not much longer yeah yeah and this looks
even let's say after 94 here i probably
lose the beetsu pawn but i guess the
jeep on queens no i think 994 has to be
played prior to that you have to play
it's the same
no you need to have knight have to check
that's the point like you need to play
king g4 knight have to check i will take
on f4 you'll play knight g3 king g5
knight bitsu but i think after king of
six the g pawn just wins frankly
it seems to me that it's extremely
unlikely that black will be anywhere
near in time to do anything about it
exactly
uh so yeah it looks right
and to remind everybody uh we have one
rest day in the tournament and that is
tomorrow peter very much forward to it i
think certain players are but then we'll
finish with four in a row
and a playoffs on a saturday may 14th if
necessary
it could very well be necessary because
i mean wesley is very much enjoying his
situation at the top but he's not
running away with things exactly
we could have we could have people uh
catching up with him
i was thinking that it's not so trivial
that the g pawn is going all the way
yeah
yeah after c3
uh but again in knight e7 you have to
first of all see queen f2
that already is uh
quite i think you get there by by simply
processing elimination
unwillingness to resign right we'll get
you to stubbornness yeah
there's nothing else i i think that
that's how you get there
happening here um besides this move
queen e6 it could also play if
queen g3 oh yeah you could yeah i mean
i'm thinking you have to play queen c2
i was going to go check and
you know me also where does the king go
because king b7 queen d6 looks kind of
awkward queen h7 check exists you have
to calculate i was actually going to
take the pawn because i've got queen c7
jet as well yeah that also looks very
very attractive for white it's a
it's a good extra pawn and i was hoping
that queen h5 check would be met by
queen
that is why you go to the other way the
other way right yeah
seven yeah to d8
why would that be better like 995 anyway
my goodness
g5 yeah queen g5 is not hanging with
check i don't know why this is an
improvement
i was hoping that i can destabilize you
with queen h7 and then queen e4 and then
i blundered yeah and then gonna chase
them well
no no no let me show alejandro
so there's two ways
no he's sharp he's got uh yeah he's got
that spidey sense and then going for him
[Laughter]
super super powers
alejandro um
okay uh we definitely like fabby's
chances and we've actually been thinking
here though it's like approaching eight
minutes and it's been a while yeah nine
left it's been nine nine and change left
and again there is no third time control
there's
and it's a long thing for fabio i mean
kind of a surprise
uh 97 c3 is there like crazy move king
h3 no
it seems very artificial i i don't quite
see why that would be good
queen takes c2 doesn't seem to be losing
so why are we forcing forcing black to
blackmun takes it right
sure i mean i
i think i mean he could repeat the key
the queen came from e7 he could go back
to e7 and then look for better but i
don't know what that better would be
honestly after king c7 26 check looks
like such an obvious move there
um
yeah a bit confusing exactly
specifically what is he spending time on
here
not not really sure is there any way
inclusion of c4g takes c4 is good for
white
why would that be wow wow
what is it fps
no no it's not even fbs it's me trying
to figure out what could make him spend
more than half of his remaining time
otherwise i wouldn't dream of suggesting
giving away pawns at this end game like
thank you it's an end game why are we
giving away stuff exactly uh i mean the
only i mean knight eight e7 so
compelling you start to think that maybe
like g7 uh yeah my g7 might be bringing
it to e6 and you start uh oh but he
finally
thank you fabi i chose you for a reason
in my
in my predictions uh
my my predictive powers are waning
i i feel something
this there's a
there's something wrong in the force
there's a disturbance in the force f
abbey is not playing
uh what it's all about and here's the
language of chess they had a lot look at
that they loved the flight square very
very nice the german word for air
lufthansa airlines the check check the
line peter check the line fbs something
i didn't know you introduced iqp
everybody knows but loose piece drops
off lbdo take that
xwing
swish and zook and zytnot again all the
german words what's a good russian word
that is in the lexicon of chess players
alejandro has been calling them peshkas
for two days straight and i've been uh
somewhere very somewhat started it is uh
it's not really
yeah it's it's not like a colloquial
it's just what the piece is called i was
just kind of wondering why that was
happening and uh
whoa shark just instantly went queen
takes c2 there well that loses
yeah
that very much loses very much losers uh
again there's no good
i mean
loft come on you've got there's no good
russian expressions
plenty but uh
they will they will remain unexplored
for now
when when you uh
when you uh trade uh the
polygayeski had this way of of of
talking and a postmortem like
i beat you
yeah
he was explaining the trade
but instead of trade you instead of
wording using the word trade he would
use the word beat i would i have no idea
beat you here i beat you here no
idea i was being beaten everywhere
i i understand what this is a caulk from
yeah okay uh but if
no no no no no yeah let's let's uh enjoy
fabi's beautiful position after knight
16. i get the feeling that very simply
97 95 q7 king g3 is winning right
exactly yeah ag3 queen d3 i'm trying to
figure it out
knight e7 check king has to go to d8 to
maintain the protection of
we're looking at knight takes by no
means the only move but at the moment it
does threaten to win the game on the
spot with check and check
and this is where alejandro was saying
yeah actually honestly i just missed 23
check i thought it was much simpler than
it is
but
maybe we're just going to win this
position you kind of slalom up the board
i mean yeah 4g 5 exactly yeah g4
do we do we go f5 do we have to be fancy
or we don't have to be fancy
i guess we don't have to i think i think
it's fine to just be straightforward
here okay
and g7 f5 i guess yeah
again i can't take this pawn because
anything that pretty much should never
or queen c7 c8 well both of those are
constantly threats here queen f7
immediately lose tonight f6 and
everything comes off and by the way we
do have a different uh
way of avoiding the perpetual check
actually he went back
this is repeating today in time yeah i
think he's just going to gain some time
i don't think he's giving up bits of his
check i don't think it's required
even though you could actually consider
the king of two queen bee took g3 maybe
this is the way to go no exactly uh but
i guess maybe it's clever you go keep
queen c to here but quincy two you have
king e3 now now
yes very much so
c1
king
f3 and g1
d1 e
e4 c2 is always the c i always drag you
back and here d3 returns
oh that just returns
i think it probably ends up being the
same it probably ends up with us having
to play queen g3 king g4 in some in some
version depending on how it is the angel
says king g1 is a draw you have to go
through sorry king g3 said you have to
go through g1 and then on king f2 queen
c2
this is only move to win is king e3
and then on queen c1 we were playing
right yes run to d3
and let me close that direction why is
king g3 draw i don't know
one at a time
i don't think it's this way i think you
have to go the other way
what's the other way c3 b3 a3
the other way the other way
wow you want it to be one way but it's
the other way
yeah i thought i was going to g6 and you
wanted me to go to a3 i took the wrong
uh
i took the wrong highway but no more
checks right no more she does win yeah
queen to 3b3 and we're
done okay
by the way this is where i think
fabi the calculator really
uh is in his element he's
very very he has to avoid the
pitfall of playing queen king g3 and go
up the board let's maybe put that on the
board let's see where we miss something
okay if we don't mind we we went to g1
queen d3
we need to
acquire two
yeah taking g2 is checked is more
important than taking default check of
course yeah this i can
i can imagine being the case but what
happens after king f5
yeah
yeah we forced you to take on g5 yeah
you're not escaping the check section
that is nice that's a very very nice uh
yeah because you can't hide behind the
pawn right yeah interesting and once g5
and g2 disappear off the board the
checks from behind will be plenty
forever
that's not what he wanted
he played king g1 he played so many one
we'll see instantly on the board no
reason not to play king f2 you kind of
realize quickly that queen b2 loses
yeah queen bee took g3's end of game
instantly because checks simply run out
we control both c3 b3 and a3 yeah he'll
figure this out i think this is just
yeah i think he stumbles upon it i think
and he uh as you say he sees as king
being driven towards the queen side uh
and he'll just calculate that it's not
even a very difficult calculation
because yeah we have enough control over
the third rank to to realize quite
quickly that we get to a3 and
on a3 we are completely safe and in the
meanwhile black's king and knight are
completely stuck so
you're only playing against the queen uh
i'll just turn our attention
quickly or briefly or whatever to
the game of ferugia when we left it
indeed we did see 95 queen h3 check
knight dropped back to h6
locking this check against the king
rugby six as expected and yeah there is
a played queen if e8 here eight minutes
each until the rest of the game the idea
here of course is to meet queen e6
either immediately i suspect immediately
although you could maybe try including
knight of three check but you play
rookie seven there
black no longer wants to do any anything
at all to do with end games and games
are legitimately i think risky by this
point exactly
there's three and three very good and a
beautiful bishop on c3 so we play rookie
seven here and there is no immediate
comfortable reply to this from white i
think you can play queen of six but the
queen might continue getting chased
around i don't particularly right i
don't yeah
at this moment you kind of stop you know
queen e6 rook e7 is a kind of a
showstopper but rookie six yeah then
black goes knight of three check
asks us to choose a square and the queen
goes somewhere depending on which square
we choose
queen of three sadly doesn't work due to
queen takes e6 that is sadness
yeah so king of one i assume something
like queen g8 queen g7 happens and if we
put it on a long diagonal i'm assuming
queen a8 happens i i can more or less
rally behind this move because then
knight and knight f3 but this looks like
we're walking into knight g4 like slap
bang into knight g4 ah
ah
uh
i do have bishop d4 but then why did i
put my game
okay queenie it is a smart move it's a
very smart movie and again uh the
players have
eight minutes
and we've been seeing uh
daniel
uh running his clock down to three
seconds four seconds
even
did he get no i don't think he got to
one second today not today not today not
today yeah today has been has been very
diligent it's been a good time
management for him
[Laughter]
excellent yes excellent
excellent
wow
surprising round after after the
waterfall of uh three victories
yesterday uh we only we only have had
three
draws thus far um we got one live game
and one that we do expect to be decisive
yes as bobby has found the move king d3
i think that was the last difficult move
he had to find right and this king's
gonna skadoodle to the queen side
played king c8 because with the queen on
c1 he currently does not immediately
lose the queen six check or queen c7
made for that matter very important very
important but yeah there has to be a way
to now with the king
reasonably safe on d3 to for why to
restructure his pieces and just win
i would assume
true that
well
a moment ago our knight was on c6 we
only re-rooted the i think queen e6
might be very strong right just play
queen h6 here and just go after the
knight
queen e8 yeah and the
we avoid the perpetual in in exactly the
same fashion nothing i think as far as i
can tell nothing has changed we just go
it's even easier because e1 is
controlled yeah yeah we also in this
case
yeah yeah well it doesn't matter because
the knight only seven gets picked up as
checks i'm sorry queen e8 of course yeah
quina just wins it i i i was kind of
thinking of queen e6 setting up knight
takes b6 so i was happy to play queen
takes d4 and stop your threat oops
um yes uh queen e6 is a very very strong
move i was also
i was thinking that i don't know i
didn't the knight but it's just so good
on d5
i'm just very reluctant to to have it
leave that square it's just such a
fantastic square it it is it is indeed
see it seems like shark's misadventures
in this tournament continue he goes down
to minus two
and again what what a contrast to last
year's
plus three no
losses uh
kind of a
march
a triumphant march if you will uh
through the streets of bucharest for the
yaziri not this year
what's gone wrong from peter it's hard
hard to say but it's quite clear that
he's not playing his a game and and then
we go back to this idea that you know uh
they're destiny everybody wants to play
their a game but nobody really knows
exactly how to achieve it like exactly
and it's so
by the way i saw that uh
shaq kind of like wrote down the move
expected 86. he knows handwriting on the
wall and uh yeah
very very frustrating he'll he'll double
and triple check out of you know due
diligence but he knows is that queenie
e6 sets up this killer threat of queen e
a check picking up the knight in the
meantime no perpetuals
nothing to play for really
there's nothing black can do
there's no king d8 either
so yeah they will diverge uh fabi will
get back to 50 and uh shaq will be the
first player to actually go from minus
one to minus two in this tournament wow
wow for fabio very important back uh
bounce back victory i would say again uh
candidates coming up next month you know
at best alejandro what will this victory
mean for him
i think i'll be happy to get a point on
the board here more than anything
it feels so unsatisfying to go a full
tournament without a victory and those
happen at this level right everybody's
difficult to beat but he's going to be
happy to find a win here uh break that
kind of mediocre tournament he's had so
far certainly bouncing back from a loss
with a win
it's a very nice thing to do yeah he'll
find himself in a much more comfortable
position
very good um
in fact funnily enough uh daniel did
play the move queen e6 he did get hit
with rookie seven but he'd prepared he
played quincy
somewhat surprisingly
at some point
[Music]
i i briefly glanced at what the machine
was suggesting and one of the ideas
machine had about the previous position
was
provoke rookie 7 and just go back to h3
which i thought was kind of funny
just take away the knight of three check
ideas by moving the rook away from the
f7 square pin the knight on h6 again
so that it cannot come out and knight
eg4 apparently is never a strong enough
threat for us to really be worried about
but quinty five is much more logical and
alireza yeah rudyard being the main
threat already very quickly goes 95 f7
not only attacking the rogue but also
uh protecting g8 and it's possible to go
wrong here but most logical moves in
this position are fine and rook f6 is
definitely one of them yeah and this is
one of those positions where you would
really like to have
access to the i mean this bishop on c3
is basically i i was kind of thinking of
it as a one-dimensional animal uh uh um
protecting the long diagonal but in fact
uh covering the e1 square is very useful
extremely important yeah extremely
important
and no i've
i don't know i
i'm
you know we've been talking three result
three results but it's
getting more and more disconcerting if
you ask me i'm beginning to think i
would maybe even choose to play white at
this moment the knights are not making a
very good impression what about
yourselves uh do you feel the practical
um
this is becoming kind of
comfortable for white because yeah the
checks are not really forthcoming the
white queen is now occupying the center
of the board you can chase it away with
rook d7 but then it goes to e6 which is
also pretty decent square and
it's a very decent thing i like about
this position for white is that it's not
super clear for either side to see how
to improve the position right but for
white it's easy you just go a four a
five a six if nothing changes true yeah
you have a very clear cut plan here you
have a you have a way of improving but
every one of your pieces the rook on f6
the bishop on c3 queen on d5 really feel
like you know like they're they're
zenith they're yeah
they're good as it gets
peak powers whereas black's knights are
kind of huddled and maybe
playing more like a nurse made to the
king than playing advantage
but let's turn back over to
fabi's game because it feels like he's
about to yeah i want to nominate the
final move of the game i actually saw
the final no king i thought kingpitsu
just actually pro prompts an immediate
resignation in the conversation because
shaq did find a way not to lose on the
sport by bringing the queen over to b5
and i thought king
with the ig of a2a4 against any sensible
move just wins the piece but king b726
exists which i originally missed
um
and also black did establish an idea of
queen a5 quinty to check which is why
knight f6 for instance isn't winning on
the spot and you have to be slightly
more precise he still goes king bisou
play king b7 i think everything else
does legitimately lose a piece to a to
a4 so he'll play king b7 but there's
always knight's e3 too right i mean the
knight ending is probably just winning
but you would like more i think with
white hair right you would like to not
have to play the night ending if if at
all possible i think it's not i i think
it is actually and he's resigned he
didn't even try really really really bad
i thought that this night ending it's
not much of a an ending after you see
them you can even play g5 here yeah yeah
it's lost but you can continue kind of
shuffling along foreign
yeah just king b2
no king no no i i thought king b7 might
have been played but nope king b2 shaq
had seen enough
oh boy yeah
really going from bed to wars for uh for
the azeri player and he's not really
i mean he's playing in the right spirit
he's he has definitely been he's sort of
very very combustive very fighting with
the white pieces like he
knight to a6 will go down as one of the
great curiosities of this event
how do you put your knight on asics when
you your knight clearly belongs on the
king side alejandro if you could bring
that position upon your board
you don't want to it was just so bad
that uh confounding uh his colleagues
here on panel
as uh he had this position and he needs
to defend the dark squares take it away
please
yeah i mean
yeah it's it's painful it's painful to
even talk about it's just such a strange
choice i think it's mainly a symptom of
him not playing well in this tournament
it's just things are misfired and it was
a 30 minute thing right it was something
that he thought forever couldn't find a
comfortable plan to kick out this bishop
on f6 to solve his problems fully on the
king's side
white's last move was rookie one to f1
and then he thought for 30 minutes came
up with 986 got into a huge amount of
trouble he actually came back
right in the game it's not like he just
died out of knight a6 somehow he was
able to fight himself his way back but
it was always suffering from him
starting with the move knight a6 and he
just wasn't able to hold all the way
throughout but the move itself is it's
impossible to explain how many times we
explain to amateur players you don't put
your knight away from the rest of the
pieces especially not on the rim
it goes against normal chess principles
yeah
no question about it the
and with one game remaining
these are our standings yeah
and uh there you see uh shakira jarafin
in last place uh uh currently tied for
las vegas is still playing and
should not really lose this game even
though i mean it's been very very swingy
and uh frankly not trending in alireza's
favor for the last hour or so but still
his vision remains i think safe enough
and if he
if he catches himself in time he should
not be losing it uh with wesley still
safely on top on three and a half points
yeah the move that i really wanted to
press uh alejandra to show was actually
in this position where knight a6 was
played
clearly there's dark square weaknesses
all around uh shaq's king side
and it was like the move queen e6 bishop
e5 rook okay this was the key move yeah
i mean
so that you could play knight c8 and
fight for control of the f6 square
this is true and this is probably the
difficult part of the equation and you
know part of the reason why uh knight a6
was played and this i can sort of relate
to if rookie seven is legitimately the
by far the best move in this position
it's not easy but why not just queen of
five that was puzzling me then and it's
continuing to puzzle me now look at one
queen of five like just
it's just not bad
it seems entirely playable to me i just
don't see why you would be particularly
worried even about this end game right
because you you will have ways of
dealing with the dark square weaknesses
and instead you just spend the tempo
kind of worsening the position of one of
your pieces right in a position where
tempe are clearly quite precious and
your king is under attack yeah and then
alejandro had a really insightful
comment as well after you'd shown me
this position and you were to say okay
what's a good move for black you'd be
thinking knight a6 to c7
to bring the knight back into play oh
dear uh and uh with this victory uh fabi
climbs back
to 50
and he is with christian in bucharest
thank you uh yes sir yes we are indeed
here with a very happy victor of the day
fabiano carona fabiano uh first of all
congratulations welcome back to the
studio topsy-turvy event so far how did
you live the last couple of days
well yesterday was uh quite a bad game
it wasn't
really that i was calculating badly but
i just made a very inexplicable decision
um based on
like two miscalculations one was that i
missed bishop d1
and um and
cite like overestimation of my
compensation
and other was that um before i saw
something wrong down down the line and
and this culminated in just like an
instant loss um
so yeah it was very good to come back
because that was
you know
already some people were pulling ahead
and i was flying behind the tournament
so it was kind of necessary to at least
stabilize it great victory today did you
expect uh shaq to open up with the
petrov uh i can't say i expected it but
it was one of the things i thought he
might play because in the grand prix
series he was playing it quite a bit
uh
and he also had had exactly this line i
don't remember exactly where he deviated
but i think he played 97 here against
anish giri it was an online event but
anyway it showed that he was
at least familiar capable of playing the
petrol so
so yeah we played a long theoretical one
i think only here
i made a new move because
um
i think young played 93
and the candidates and beat
wang hao
and knight h2 is an
interesting rule i mean
the points of h67 with some uh which
seems to have been played possibly once
this knight to h2 and h6 already uh
novelty did you feel like this knight h2
move surprised your opponent uh i don't
think so because he quickly played queen
d7 i think he knew that the move exists
maybe he didn't know the position in
huge detail but
uh at least he was ready for it
and
yeah he took which is i think correct
um
and rook f8 and we took took
uh yeah i think we were playing
correctly mm-hmm and then at this moment
after rook
he totally shocked me i was expecting
queen f5
queen six nine 94 rookie for like any
move except for knight a6
everybody was completely shocked did you
guys get to discuss uh the game
afterwards uh well the only thing he
said was that knight a6 was a very
strange move which uh so he understood
also that that was a huge mistake yeah i
think he had something in mind maybe he
was counting on this
and there was some and maybe he missed
up four here and
um
and so maybe he was based on some sort
of miscalculation but also it's such a
like strange move to make yeah his king
is
rather vulnerable and he's just like
taking away one of the defenders from it
so obviously it can't be very good
and yeah i guess i thought f4 was very
strong but um
now i see that it was the wrong move the
thing is i
i was kind of expecting 94 f5 take queen
h3
f6 rook f5 it's what we have in the game
with the knight zone a6
and um
for e7 knight g4 it's quite important
because it's not immediately evident
that white wings here rook h7 rook h5
and i have this night h6
very nice so um and my viet i kind of
assumed
that it was losing uh
for
for the reason that uh i wanted to play
f5 but i put up four queen h3
f6 g4
and this position which is totally
reached by force i thought was winning
in advance
but after rook at five he has queen g6
and i can't quite get my rook into the
attack like it's very close to being
made but it's not and then i had this
idea maybe king h1
to um well it seems like you're just one
move away from yeah yeah let's say he
makes one careless move then here
and queen h7 is very important and i
made him he has no way to defend it here
we go here eventually
uh and then i was looking at like rookie
seven
rook f5 queen g6 and i couldn't see the
way to win here i spent like at least 30
minutes
thinking about this one position
uh and i just couldn't see it i was
thinking about knight g4 in it
it was um
yeah maybe i i should have been more
practical not burned all my time
because okay what i what i chose was
rather safe like
i get an advantage it's
definitely not you can see it's not
winning but it could easily dissipate as
well yeah but at least i should have
done this with some more time on my
clock because i got this for a few
minutes
and uh i'm sure that at some point he
was yeah i was surprised he didn't play
knight f8
because
okay i can take it
um but yeah he'll defend his b-pawn
somehow
um
and then knight 36 is coming yeah knight
g6 or e6 and
he has a lot of counter play but he
played this passive a6
and i was very happy because i can play
queen f3 okay i decided first to weaken
him a little bit before this
um
and at least here i have like total
safety and
yeah the reason i didn't play knight g4
was in this position i didn't see
i mean it looks like the most natural
way but i didn't see how to continue
here
um yeah maybe just a4 and something slow
he's a bit tied up
but um
a4 seems like
not such a natural human move at that
point yeah i think it was only when he
uh
did you at all consider repeating the
moves or at this point you knew that you
want to play on and you were just trying
to gain some uh some moves no no i
wasn't considering repeating i mean it's
it's a very safe advantage like he he
can't really
there's no way that he'll win this
position right there correct
um
and i thought that i still have quite a
quite a pleasant advantage
yeah here i was surprised by knight g5
because oh sorry
um
at least like he can play i thought king
c8
c4 i was playing because if he takes 97
and i pick up the knight and this
position at least like now his d-pawn is
very weak i was thinking about queen e7
and trading queens and winning pawn
but
um like ig fun
is either just
losing borderline losing or just
completely lost so i was surprised he
went for it
um maybe he he thought that it was
somehow holding
but
um
but yeah i was actually expecting king
c8
with some various knight endings yes
this i think was one of the main lines
and right now knight i think between
these six i wasn't sure maybe maybe
first queen d6
um but
queen d6 if he plays king david we get
the game right uh and if he trades
queens like this
um then yeah i thought this was a good
version yeah like i wasn't 100 sure but
i thought it should be winning so he
avoided it and
um
queen f2 wow i didn't consider this one
yeah queen to have f2 seemed like the
only way for him to fight at this point
basically the idea is that
uh if you try to defend on this side
with placing the knight on g6 then he
can just simply take on d4 oh this was a
great great chance to hold
yeah maybe it's i mean i have to first
find this queen six move it's not
entirely easy and then the game goes on
right well in the game it was just like
very very forcing
it was just important i saw that this
king g1
was important because if kg3
queen d3 you know if the checks begin
again so
um i was a bit surprised that he didn't
take on b2
because
i thought he had queen b5
and
yeah it's some sort of this is wrong but
i wasn't 100 sure but yeah i guess it's
um
because i wasn't 100 sure how i keep the
perhaps a4 here can you do this
i think
yeah then then we have some
okay queen queenie's excitement is
without this uh
it's another zigzag
because and if you do go queen to a but
now um four what's the uh queen g yeah
yeah
you have a three
okay this is very nice i assumed it was
winning somehow i was actually going to
go for this one
because here it looks like a sixth one
but
uh but yeah what he did
was uh was probably like a little bit
more tenacious but yeah it's still lost
huge uh victory for you uh right before
the rest day what uh are you going to do
during the rest day how do you plan
well we have this fundraiser
for ukraine
uh i don't know what time it starts but
uh it's it's going to be
from what i heard uh some sort of like
pro-am event
uh with like tandem chess so some
uh you know fun stuff and after that i
don't know i'll probably try to get some
sports in because i haven't been doing
anything i've just been sitting
all day every day so that'll be nice get
some sports in get the energy up and
we'll see you in a couple of days thank
you guys back to you thank you christian
thank you fabie congratulations with
fabie's victory in the books
uh how does that affect our standings
peter yeah now that we have three
players on 50 and uh one of them is uh
actually not on 50 bogdan
with the game in hand
which is uh sharpening up quite a bit
again and they're both uh very very low
on time so we should perhaps without
further ado
jump right into that game as uh both
players are down
to their last minutes
yeah the queens have come off but the
end game remains very very sharp with
the night's knights jumping the knights
are very tricky piece on one minute you
really would prefer the knights to the
bishop here honestly and i say that as a
absolutely huge bishop aficionado myself
yeah you you kind of prefer the knights
in this spot well
but on the other hand when you've got
three past pawns
and then at some point you blunder 95 93
yeah
well life is spain
isn't the uh role of the pawns to uh
they're lust to expand see if i from d5
his issue i would play c5 in the
heartbeat here unfortunately rook d5
picks picks one of our guys up no i
meant uh before he played bishop e5 i
was thinking that he was supposed to
play b4 in c5 he wanted to stop neither
four i think he was very annoyed by the
prospect of the knight landing on the f4
but maybe it wasn't really such a threat
because he was b5 then yeah exactly that
was a you
you gave me purpose
a purposeful reason to play the movie
he did not play that he jumped
immediately with bishop e5 allowed the
rook to sneak into d2 and we've caught
up to the players but again i still feel
like this is a
completely a three result game no i
don't think blick ever loses this i
think really yeah i think black is
completely fine as you can see uh he has
realized that maybe something has gone
wrong and allowing knight c5 is very
dangerous and he's played before he's
given up one of the three on the queen
side as well very good instantly uh
solves the you know the question
yeah yeah that is
still okay because c5 c5 and the pawns
start running and it's not that easy
actually
right yeah c5 how do you stop right
anything yeah the feeling has to be that
you know perhaps
from a practical viewpoint just like
going c5 through k4 picking up the b
pawn giving c7 knight takes c7 and just
kind of shaking hands
is something that many people would do
but alireza i have a feeling if he is
anywhere
to keep the game rolling he will
continue he will continue playing
because he very much
has that has been the case throughout in
fact
i
this tournament and all the tournaments
we've been watching him and frankly he
he just does not like uh ending games
prematurely
he doesn't but this one
i think it's time to pull the plug right
so rook a4 c6 rook takes c7 knight takes
c7 is what
uh peter advocates uh you shake hands
you call it a good game and uh well i'm
uh as an owner and there you go as an
honorary member of the chicken chess
club yeah
representatives of the chicken chess
club here on in in saint louis i would
very much like to to yeah
be be sensible here and not do anything
rash but we'll see i mean he could
knowing it's already maybe go he goes c6
97 c7 knight c8 and continues playing
well here we go by the way are you a
gold member of the chicken chess uh
association lifetime memory
c6 on the board and like you say if ali
wasn't there
nobody's interested in that it was going
to be a draw
knows what's up yeah and yet another day
though
another day with interesting chess and
only one decisive result right
paralleling rounds one through three
uh where we were uh regaled with some
fantastic fighting chess some of the
draws yeah and what do you see on your
screens right now is people actually
running out of space on their scoresheet
so they were given fresh scoresheets to
start writing from 61. for those for
those of the viewers who perhaps are
slightly unfamiliar with this procedure
the score sheets uh from the traditional
old days were all printed up for 60
moves
they normally are three columns of 20.
exactly and then you have to get a new
one exactly and theresa there i think
just checked out of the game
starts looking up to the scene he knows
this is a dead draw exactly he's just
trying to figure out where he's trying
to figure out where right what happened
i had a piece where did it go
exactly yeah bishop g3 kind of inviting
knight takes g3 and at some point yeah
you you kind of
that would be fully quality right you
know there's a there's a pawn on g3
there's a pawn on g6 or rook on the
seventh rook b2 or rook on the seventh
uh
no no no nothing nope
nope
okay noping out of that but yeah we we
do know how this movie ends and
continues a very very impressive
tournament for the young romanian uh
very swingy uh very swingy play today uh
you know all kinds of things happened in
this game he was much better than
probably lost then
uh somewhat better somewhat uh somewhat
worse here you see that clear lack of
experience not playing them with king f1
playing the silly move rook
[Laughter]
yeah and also like he's taking away
squares from the rook so you you can't
even find a threefold this way what are
you doing like is this this is a clear
misplay
but uh for for uh
for ruja i mean this is really
disconcerting yes i mean he's going to
go into the rest day wondering what the
heck is going on it also feels like why
what it means what do i need to win a
game is it three connected past pawns
is it an extra speed
i think he needs a rook at this point i
mean could i have a rook
it's
it's it's disconcerting
and we
have found a three-time repetition the
most logical one yeah finally finally we
see that and there we go a handshake i
don't think i don't think they actually
got the three but i'm really hoping the
arbiters don't don't make them continue
this has been an excellent game of chess
it really doesn't need to be
artificially prolonged for extended yes
for an additional couple of moves for no
reason um
where was the moment that would have
been the most decisive for ferugia is it
that rook a6 moment uh but i think it's
actually h6 not rook c8 i think
alejandra was arguing 4h6 and i think it
was the cleanest i think if we were to
say at what point did it really start
going downhill it was here when he gave
up his second pawn so up until then he
had played one of the better choices
perhaps not the best choice in every
case but good enough to keep a pretty
decisive advantage and here in this
position it was this move knight f6
which the engines really hated they
thought it went on the wrong way that
the knight was not properly placed on f6
actually really wanted to play them with
rook c5 which had the double attack i
thought that was the original purpose of
already set up now you don't have a lot
of moves here you don't want to trade
queens just yet you want to play queen
d2 and keep up the options here on the
a5 bishop the problem is the move knight
e5 right and we talked about this during
the broadcast that this rook doesn't
have a lot of squares the knights are
doing a great job of defending the pawn
on d6 and which means keeping the rook
away from the rest of the pieces and for
the moment this move queen c8 queen
takes e6 it's a huge threat and it
doesn't matter if you have three
connected past pawns that rook is a rook
yeah against the piece they'll fight
just fine but against the rook they're
not
and in this case queen c8 is coming and
that's just
enough
wow
big turnaround for ferugia i'm just
saying that uh his loss to
levon
yeah in terms of uh let me introduce
more more chess terms than which will
show up on the ground tomorrow yeah yeah
i mean
he's left so so many sklonsky bucks on
the table in this turn how many bucks
sklonsky bucks skolanski bucks uh
he was better close to winning at some
point against jan as we keep on coming
back to then there was this this game
against levon and then
uh today
so yeah in in a slightly different world
he he would be on plus three right now
right and leading above wesley and he
finds himself on minus one with no
victories right and yeah that's that's
going into the rest day yeah and it
plays on your mind and what is what's
going on and why am i it's it's just not
been his tournament at all and
and let's ask uh christian to interview
uh farouza right now
thank you yasser yes we are indeed here
with ali razafir alireza first of all
welcome back to the studio quite a wild
game uh today you started off with the
kings indian did you want a fight from
the beginning was that the approach
yeah of course he's very solid player so
king's indian was a normal choice i
think
to just get a playable position but
yeah and then
and he played this uh
early on bishop p2 and h4 yeah it's very
fashionable
h4 h5 h6
yeah were you ready for uh this approach
by him did you expect it
i expected and because he doesn't have
many games in king's indians so yeah it
was not a big surprise
so maybe we went
yeah now in the opening yeah he got me
of course he had preparation
so yeah queen b6 coin b3 is a
good movie you know he was trying to
play very solid but
yeah and then i wanted to
of course here i don't know why he came
back to you went out of the repetition
you said okay yeah you i'm probably
worse but i wonder i want to play i want
to fight this was the point of king's
indian
yeah and then i'm not sure about this f5
move okay
it's very risky but i should do it
probably and then
and here he blundered of course with
knight d4
okay still
here already is very
yeah i saw 94 it's a very good move but
with only 30 seconds on his blog did you
feel like he's going to sleep yeah i
think i thought okay he was very nervous
so he played knight d4 and yeah he got a
winning position easily here
but yeah
yeah it was peace up but okay it's not
easy of course because the king is
always weak
but yeah he continues here
and it's not like you're getting close
to stabilizing but right you were just
going for i think
g4 yeah i was very scared of going to h
yeah and then rook
what's the shot
knight h6
yeah yeah my rook is hanging so because
you cannot cover with the queen queen h6
the rook on a8 is saying
very good point very good point earlier
yeah so looks yeah he took yeah i
really didn't see this idea of queen c8
rook traps zero to c5 yeah queen d2 192
95 bishop c3 and now queen to c8 just in
time to trap the rook right and if it
takes you take and uh transition into
this endgame which
yeah because if i don't have this
question then i'm not
okay not lost but
yeah okay we continue and then yeah here
he's okay
it's very difficult
and
and here i saw that he got some chances
because his king is weak how did you
assess this position did you uh look at
it as a three-game result or do you feel
like you're still having the advantage i
thought i had a little advantage but it
was wrong because it's very concrete
move by move this 25 knights of sun
and here
king g2
yeah i blundered queen c6 of course
i completely missed this queen c6 i'm
very lucky this end game is not losing
this thing game could easily be losing
here absolutely yeah three game results
especially with those three connected
passers yeah but i have some counter
players might uh two knights around the
king yes because he cannot go c5 96 it's
could go very wrong for him also
absolutely well it was a difficult game
very very complex battle uh you're going
into the rest day without a victory
after this point what are you going to
do to ride the ship yeah it's a very
difficult tournament
um i'm happy to be playing here
and i didn't play for five months
i'm trying to get in shape and try
to prepare best for the candidates
what are you going to do during the rest
day are you going to take a walk go to a
restaurant or focus mostly on chess yeah
anything is good just not to play one
days
it's a good day
because playing is very difficult now is
all the
[Music]
resourcefulness absolutely very complex
game very energy draining yes keep your
energy up get uh get the rest day and
we'll see you in a couple of days thank
you thank you ali reza guys back to you
thank you christian our standings with
the round finally completed with wesley
leading the the field with three and a
half out of five uh shakira midaraffin
are dead last now with one and a half
and the rest of the field uh bunch
closely together uh with
three people uh tied for second
including uh bogan daniel dayak who just
finished this very very exciting game
against reza
wow and just to remind everybody
tomorrow is the rest day do not join us
tomorrow but
join us again on wednesday as we see
round six and we pick up the final four
rounds with the playoff on saturday uh
if necessary
uh another another eventful day but
let's take a look at our predictions as
uh
well um
i'm not doing that great nobody's really
doing all that well
you know yeah
i really feeling uh
the angst here
elvar is kind of why is sparse okay
and everybody else is looking really bad
well right
it's so bad today at least
i think it's just you and i
no
no it's me just here just me no lavonne
of course
and final thoughts uh from bucharest
well guys i have to say uh today i
thought that i'm probably going to get
my first win for ali reza and my
prediction unfortunately it didn't
happen it's a very difficult tournament
for him up to this point but he's
definitely uh getting in tune so i'm
definitely looking forward to see what
he's going to bring to the table in the
remainder of the games and i'm also
looking forward to get some dinner
because well i'm starving anastasia how
about yourself yes same here it's been a
long day but
it was still eventful and we also had a
very nice novelty at the very beginning
if you remember 92 move a new trend um
in the openings now and also there were
many great fights and endings so i
really liked the games even though we
came back to the same place only one
decisive game right so
in the round five so expecting that all
players will
have a lot of energy after the free day
and also i would like just to mention
that tomorrow we are going to have a
nice event here is in the same place
in sheraton hotel there will be a fun
rising event for ukraine and
players from the tournament including
also some guests natalia zhukov and
alexander onystrok
play against guests honorary guests
invited by the organizers organizers and
super bet foundation will be the one who
will organize the whole event well that
one is definitely going to be a fun and
very useful one guys i'm looking forward
to the rest day how about yourselves i
definitely good luck with the
fundraising have a good dinner christian
and
let us know what you have
and final thoughts alejandro
it was a story that we've told before
one decisive game of the res
missing his winning chances let's see if
he can ride the ship after the rest day
but i'm looking forward to taking a day
off i need my sleep this 5 30 a.m be at
the studio at 5 30 am it's killing me so
i'll see you guys on the other end of
the rest day i'm excited for it look at
him pretending he's here at 5 30. i know
i know look at this look at him
50. only us only ourselves and the
production look at him pretending he's
here at 5 30.
look at him pretending he's good i have
great witnesses i paid them a lot
thank you everybody for joining us uh
tomorrow is a rest day yay uh join us
again on wednesday same time same
channel as we'll be bringing you round
six of what has been a very eventful
tournament absolutely see you then bye
everyone
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the saint
louis chess club is prohibited